[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravie de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour cette
première séance de questions d'actualité
de 2021 meilleurs vœux à tous on est
ensemble pour une après-midi consacrée à
l'actualité parlementaire autour de cet
événement phare de la semaine au Sénat
les questions au Gouvernement et on va
vous faire vivre tout cela avec nos
journalistes je suis avec Steve Jourdain
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat bonjour Steve
alors quel est le menu de ces premières
questions d'actualité de 2021 bonjour
Tom bonjour à tous pourquoi est-on à la
traîne en matière de vaccination que
faire face à l'augmentation de la
précarité des étudiants à l'université
voilà quelques-unes des questions qui
seront posées tout à l'heure au
gouvernement mais oui la crise sanitaire
toujours au menu des questions
d'actualité Alexandre Poussard se trouve
lui salle des conférences et Alexandre
vous allez avoir de nombreux invités
ministres et sénateurs à votre micro
bonjour Tom et je serai notamment avec
l'un des sénateurs qui sera sous le feu
des projecteurs en 2021 il s'agit de
François Noel buffet le président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat et sa
devrait examiner des textes importants
comme le projet loi censé lutter contre
eux le séparatisme la réforme de la
justice des mineurs ou encore la fameuse
loi sécurité globale à tout à l'heure
Alexandre
c'est notre histoire triste Sonia de la
provoté qui est à l'origine d'un rapport
parlementaire sur la stratégie vaccinale
face au sénateur de la République en
marche Martin à lévrier on va ensemble
parler de la crise sanitaire des vaccins
et des éventuels nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires qui nous attendent
[Musique]
mais d'abord en cette semaine de rentrée
parlementaire on va s'intéresser à
l'exercice compliqué auquel ce livre le
gouvernement aujourd'hui tenter de se
projeter sur les grands textes à venir
en 2021 en 2021 c'est la dernière année
complète du quinquennat et donc la
dernière année pour faire passer des
réformes mais tout cela dans un contexte
où la pandémie nous plonge dans
l'incertitude et dans la gestion au jour
le jour on va en parler avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau François Patriat
bonjour bonjour vous êtes président du
groupe rdpu rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants et
sénateurs de la Côte-d'Or merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous également sur ce
plateau Philippe d'allier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateurs les
républicains de la Seine-Saint-Denis
avec nous en visio covid et
distanciations sociales obligent nous
sommes également avec Jérôme du Rhin
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de la Saône-et-Loire et enfin
Emmanuel caput est également en visio
avec nous Emmanuel Capus sénateur les
indépendants de Maine-et-Loire merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous
bonjour je le disais alors qu'Emmanuel
Macron a réuni ses ministres en
séminaire pour fixer le cap de ces
prochaines réformes reste à voir s'il
reste encore des marges de manœuvre le
point avec Jonathan du priez avec
Aurélien Romano il ne reste qu'un an à
Emmanuel Macron pour lancer de nouvelles
réformes une année que le chef de l'État
veut utile même si l'admet de voir Gérer
matin midi et soir la crise du covid
peut-il donc encore réformer dans un
temps imparti très réduit certains
sénateurs macronistes sont convaincus
qu'il y a encore une marge de manœuvre
j'attends que on puisse faire des
réformes qui soient beaucoup plus basées
sur le social l'accompagnement des plus
fragiles on a aussi besoin de cette
reprise économique et je pense que le
plan de relance que nous avons voté et
qui se décline moi après moi va nous
permettre aussi de de repartir sur de
bonnes bases économiques mais à
l'approche de la présidentielle les
oppositions pilonnent déjà le bilan du
chef de l'État peu de choses auront été
faites avaient même taclé Gérard Larcher
dans le JDD dimanche dernier du côté
vraiment triste alliés de la droite au
Sénat certains parlementaires espèrent
qu'Emmanuel Macron aura la lucidité
d'abandonner des réformes comme la loi
4D ou encore celle des retraites il faut
que le Président de la République assume
de dire qu'il y a des sujets qui ne
seront pas abordés en la fin du mandat
qui sont mis de côté et que le prochain
Président de la République celui-ci s'il
est réélu ou un autre on reprendra un
nouvel agenda à partir de 2022 le
calendrier parlementaire chargé reste
l'obstacle majeur pour Emmanuel Macron
dont les textes sur le séparatisme
convention climat ou encore état
d'urgence sanitaire seront examinés ces
prochains mois au Parlement le chef de
l'État serait donc bloqué c'est en tout
cas ce que pense le socialiste
Jean-Pierre Sueur ça me paraît une
naturelle
que ce chef de l'État Emmanuel Macron ce
gouvernement souhaite avoir un bilan
même si c'est compliqué tous bouscule et
on y voit pas très clair face à ces
critiques Emmanuel Macron en tant
continuer sa politique du en même temps
on en voyant des signaux aux électeurs
de droite comme de gauche avec une
priorité pouvoir présenter des résultats
concrets aux Français
François Patriat c'est un peu la mission
impossible pour ce séminaire
gouvernemental aujourd'hui tracer des
perspectives alors que on nage dans
l'incertitude sanitaire la gestion en
jour le jour c'est pas facile c'est
compliqué de se projeter au gouvernement
de prioriser la question sanitaire des
malades des familles des difficultés de
ce pays c'est pas un reproche très bien
j'entends bien donc on peut pas le dire
aujourd'hui on est paralysé parce qu'il
y a ça la priorité c'est le sanitaire et
nous savons très bien que la crise n'est
pas finie deuxième chose faut-il pour
autant dire que les réformes qui doivent
être conduites ou qui ont été commencées
doivent être poursuivis je le pense et
il y a un espace réduit c'est vrai il
reste 6 7 8 mois utile pour pouvoir
passer 4 5 6 textes mais pas plus sans
doute le séminaire cet après-midi et le
séminaire de la majorité de ce soir
auquel je participerai en décidera les
priorités mais enfin je ne peux pas
laisser dire dans le même temps à ceux
qui ont pilonné le gouvernement pendant
trois ans qui sont opposés à toutes les
réformes qui ont bloqué je pense
j'entends le président du Sénat
s’exprimer bloquer la réforme
constitutionnelle dire peu de choses
aurait été faites
pendant 3 ans pour bloquer l'action du
gouvernement on aimerait nous dire après
mais en fin de compte peu de choses a
été fait moi je regarde l'opposition
dans d'autres pays européens je trouve
que l'opposition n'est pas seulement là
pour pilonner elle l'a pour se poser la
critique est normale les attaques sont
en politique quotidienne mais il
n'empêche que il peut y avoir un sens de
l'intérêt général et qui aille au-delà
de la critique quotidienne ce qui me
satisfait mieux c'est un peu dur ça peut
politiser
se souvenir que le grand coup d'arrêt
aurait forme de ce gouvernement de ces
gouvernements c'est la crise des gilets
jaunes donc c'est des sommes 2018 il y a
deux ans et ça ça n'est pas l'opposition
qui en est responsable le gouvernement a
dû prendre un virage et d'ailleurs il
faudrait peut-être se souvenir que le
Sénat a beaucoup le gouvernement au
moment de la crise des gilets jaunes
puisque sans décembre 2018 que en tout
dernier ressort avant tout d'urgence
nous avons adopté les mesures qui
devaient calmer la crise c'est pourquoi
parce qu'il avait en 2015
qui avaient été proposées et notamment
les augmentations de taxes sur les sens
ont mis le feu aux poudres voilà donc
2019 ce n'est pas passé grand chose la
réforme des retraites a été amorcée elle
a été abandonnée et puis après on est
tombé dans la crise du covid donc il
faut bien constater que alors je veux
bien qu'effectivement François Patriat
porte tout cela sur le compte du Google
de l'opposition et du Sénat en
particulier mais franchement c'est un
peu oublié ce qui s'est passé voilà
alors il y a au moins un point sur
lequel on est d'accord c'est en fait il
ne reste pas une année
utilement et en termes de calendrier
parlementaire c'est huit mois puisque à
partir d'octobre on sera dans le budget
2000 2022 et donc s'il y a des textes à
passer c'est y compris jusqu'au mois de
septembre de l'année en cours et donc il
va falloir que le gouvernement fasse des
choix alors que nous aurons 2800
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques à
la fin de l'année et que ça on ne peut
pas faire comme si ça n'existait pas et
qui va donc falloir réformer pays pour
trouver la plus grande efficacité de la
dépense publique et quand j'entends dire
que la loi 4D qui est effectivement
celle qui doit traiter la répartition
des compétences entre les tels et les
collectivités et pour être plus
efficaces pourrait ne pas venir devant
le Parlement je le regrette très si
c'était le cas il faut dire que l'année
2021 est déjà très très embouteillée on
voit que certains textes vont
monopoliser le Parlement et notamment et
ben la commission des lois on en a dit
un mot tout à l'heure Jérôme Durand dans
la commission dont vous êtes
vice-président on voit qu'il y a
séparatisme sécurité globale qu'il y a
la réforme pour inscrire l'environnement
dans la Constitution qu'il y a le projet
de loi issu de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat il va y avoir votre peau
on a effectivement il y a très peu de
manœuvre on le voit il y a énormément de
textes tout est embouteillé la messe est
quasiment dite
oui je vais commencer par dire que je
suis d'accord avec François Patriat sur
un point c'est que
la priorité c'est une sanitaire la
priorité c'est le sanitaire après
expliquer que dans ce pays c'est
l'opposition qui empêchait que le
Président de la République a un beau
bilan c'est quand même mal connaître les
astres de la Cinquième République parce
que si la deuxième partie du quinquennat
est abîmée par la crise sanitaire
Philippe Dayet a dit très justement que
la première partie du du quinquennat
Emmanuel Macron se l'ai abîmé tout seul
avec la crise des gilets jaunes donc
dire que l'opposition n'est pas
constructive après ce qu'on a consenti
au Parlement dans cette période de crise
sanitaire les clés du camion confiées au
gouvernement et au président de la
République je pense que on peut
difficilement attendre plus du Parlement
qu'est-ce qui est utile aux Français la
loi MKD on a sans doute besoin d'une
évolution nos institutions et notre
organisation territoriale mais
fondamentalement si des jeunes
gouvernement traite cette crise
sanitaire au fond au mieux alors il leur
a fait son travail correctement et
l'utilité c'est l'utilité pour les
Français ou c'est l'utilité pour le
bilan du président de la République moi
je crois que c'est l'utilité pour les
Français donc on a la crise sanitaire on
va être on va faire notre boulot sur les
textes qui ne sont proposés ils sont
nombreux vous l'avez dit notamment à la
commission des lois et il faut pas
attendre de l'opposition qu'elle soit là
pour dire la même chose que le
gouvernement sinon on ne sert à rien
donc on sera constructif sur le peu de
texte qu'on aura le temps d'étudier dans
la période qui vient Jérôme durant
disait que la priorité ça reste le
sanitaire effectivement Emmanuel Capu il
y a une certitude c'est que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire il va se poursuivre
un projet de loi et présenter
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres
pour demander sa prolongation jusqu'au
1er juin et puis ensuite être sur un
régime transitoire jusqu'au mois de
décembre est-ce que pour vous et bien
ces dates là elles vous paraissent
aujourd'hui raisonnable et est-ce que ça
montre pas pour le coup et bien que
cette gestion bousculée par la crise
elle va nécessairement se poursuivre
jusqu'à l'été et même peut-être au-delà
et ça va continuer et bien à
embouteiller bien sûr l'ensemble du
calendrier des réformes
calendrier des réformes il a été
totalement bousculé d'abord par la crise
populiste comme la défilent d'allier
puis par la crise sécuritaire et enfin
par la crise sanitaire donc il est
évident que le préalable obligatoire
pour que relancer les réformes c'est la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et c'est
ça passe par la vaccination de masse de
la majorité de la population pour
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'on puisse
relancer le pays c'est effectivement la
priorité des priorités et ça passe par
la vaccination et l'accélération de la
vaccination et derrière cette année ça
doit pas être une année inutile et il
faut maintenir le rythme des réformes il
y a déjà eu beaucoup de réformes moi je
vais pas rentrer dans la polémique mais
on n'a jamais autant réformé le droit du
travail on a réformé la SNCF on a
réformé les impôts vers on a baissé on
n'a jamais autant baissé les impôts donc
il y a eu beaucoup de bonnes choses de
fait on peut pas s'arrêter là pour la
France ça n'est pas possible donc moi je
suis aussi d'accord avec Philippe
d'allier sur le fait que on ne peut pas
continuer à faire des réformes sans les
territoires et je pense pas que passer à
la trappe la loi 4D ce soit une bonne
chose
la crise du covid a montré que le couple
préfère mère a extrêmement bien
fonctionné je pense que la crise des
gilets jaunes a rappelé aussi au
gouvernement et donc il faut je pense
dans la loi 4D tirer les conséquences de
la crise sanitaire de toutes les
blocages qui ont qui sont apparus
notamment dans la crise sanitaire avec
notre régime de santé qui n'a pas
totalement bien fonctionné qui peut être
amélioré le régime des ARS notamment qui
peut être amélioré et la confiance dans
les territoires et ça ça passe à mon
avis par l'une des priorités qui est de
passer cette loi 4D effectivement au
début je pense à l'année prochaine comme
texte prioritaire voilà on voit qu'il y
a un lobbying pour la loi 4D au Sénat ça
m'étonnera personne François Patriat
bien non d'abord les gilets jaunes
j'entends bien de dire que c'est vrai
que la crise des gilets jaunes entravait
du gouvernement mais que le gouvernement
y a répondu avec parfois la Corée du
Sénat je l'entends je n'entends bien
pareil mais dire que la crise des gilets
jaunes elle est due à Emmanuel Macron à
la seule taxe sur le carbone qu'avait on
sait bien que la crise des gilets jaunes
c'est l'aboutissement d'un processus qui
date de 20 ans et que Emmanuel Macron a
assumé et qu'il a assumé je crois que le
courage qu'il a eu à travers le grand
débat public et le gouvernement
est bonne peut-être la goutte d'eau je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas ce ne veut
pas dire que la crise des gilets jaunes
c'était une bonne attaque c'était une
accumulation si le pouvoir d'achat c'est
les libertés etc bon c'est le risque
souvenez-vous deuxième chose moi je suis
très fier du bilan d'Emmanuel Macron et
on va voir l'occasion aujourd'hui oui
pareil au séminaire gouvernemental le
baromètre de l'action publique et de la
réforme
qui montre combien les réformes prises
par le gouvernement ont été ambitieuses
et on va voir sur les territoires
comment ils ont été déclinés ça prouve
bien d'abord que l'action
du Parisien aujourd'hui on voit un
paramètre des promesses nus ou non voir
insatisfait site sur le dédoublement par
exemple des classes de CP et de CE1 de
CE1 sur l'exonération de la taxe
d'habitation encore sur le plan vélo
puis c'est assez honnête puisqu'on voit
aussi ce qui est dans le rouge on voit
par exemple parce culture la culture
décidément bien malmenée ou encore le
déploiement des maisons de santé c'est
un bon exercice pour vous Philippe
d'allier ce baromètre est-ce que c'est
plutôt transparent ou c'est un exercice
de communication pour valoriser le bilan
on est entré dans la phase où
effectivement comme le fait François
Patriat le gouvernement va chercher par
tous les moyens mais cette bonne guerre
à mettre en avant ce qu'il a pu réaliser
ceci étant dit pour du bilan oui bah
évidemment c'est l'heure du bilan année
pré-présidentiel on entre dans l'heure
du bilan ceci dit ça peut encore être
une année utile parce que si je partage
l'idée qu'effectivement l'urgence c'est
la crise sanitaire mais ça aujourd'hui
c'est l'exécutif qui est à la manœuvre
je ne pense pas hormis la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence et on va le faire
euh on n'a pas besoin de nouveaux textes
ça le gouvernement est en charge des
oppositions on se rappelle lors des
dernières prolongations sur la durée ce
que nous n'aurions pas accepté c'est
pour que pendant une période très longue
effectivement on ne revienne pas devant
le Parlement ça c'est une accessoire
mais effectivement on va prolonger cette
cette période mais après j'allais dire
au quotidien c'est le gouvernement qui
gère donc ça laisse de l'espace et ça
laisse du temps parlementaire pour
poursuivre les réformes parce que si
nous ne le faisions pas ça veut dire que
le prochain rendez-vous c'est en juin
2022 vous croyez que dans la situation
ou spi on peut se permettre de perdre
encore 18 mois et quand je dis 18 mois
ça sera un peu plus après après les
présidentielles de 2022 pour engager les
réformes il faut que chacun comprenne
bien que la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes je vais pas jeter la faute sur le
président de la République mais il a dit
quoi qu'il en coûte et il l'assume mais
ce que ça entraîne comme conséquence sur
le budget de l'État et les finances
publiques ça peut devenir dramatique et
donc nous avons besoin de réformer et de
poursuivre le travail fort et en parlant
de réforme il y a une question une
question assez épineuse le gouvernement
va t-il vouloir remettre la réforme des
retraites sur la table la question se
pose et d'ailleurs Alexandre et bien
vous êtes celle des conférences vous
êtes avec Eric Bocquet vous vous êtes
d'ailleurs effectivement en terme c'est
très fort de retraite elle est
emblématique du quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron avec un système universel par
point des retraites en France
Eric Bocquet cette réforme des retraites
elle est impossible à poursuivre dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire n'est pas
souhaitable sur le fond je crois que les
Français l'ont dit l'opinion était
majoritairement contre ce projet de
réformes la réforme des retraites c'est
vraiment un emblème de ce quinquennat
Macron qui est en mission depuis 3 ans
et demi on arrive au dernier tiers du
quinquennat donc évidemment la pandémie
a bousculé un peu l'agenda mais il y a
une volonté forte dans ce gouvernement
d'avancer dans un sens plus libéral
encore dans cette société même s'ils
sont défend donc non cette réforme des
retraites n'est pas à faire du tout et
les Français je crois l'ont dit très
majoritairement et pourtant le
gouvernement s'en défend et estime qu'il
y des parties sociales dans cette
réforme des retraites notamment pour
améliorer les retraites des femmes et
que cette dimension sociale de la
réforme elle pourrait être poursuivie
avant la fin du quinquennat oui mais
c'est l'histoire de c'est le pâté
d'alouette ça vous voyez on met un peu
social pour beaucoup de libérales à côté
il y a de vrais dangers ce système de
retraite par capitalisation c'est versa
qu'on veut aller aujourd'hui remet en
cause complètement notre modèle social
qui tient la route modèle social qui
fait la preuve de son efficacité y
compris dans la crise très difficile
qu'on traverse alors il y a une autre
réforme qui est suspendue et qui
pourrait revenir sur la table c'est
celle de l'assurance chômage là encore
vous et bien vous déconseillez au
gouvernement de la poursuivre écoutez il
suffit de regarder le nombre de planches
sociaux entre guillemets qui tombent
tous les jours dans ce pays et je pense
que malheureusement on n'est pas au bout
les effets de la pandémie d'abord la
crise sanitaire la crise économique je
crois dans les semaines et moi qui
viennent il faut s'attendre
malheureusement de nombreuses faillites
de nombreuses difficultés pour beaucoup
d'entreprises et donc un nombre de
chômeurs qui va augmenter une pauvreté
va augmenter donc franchement c'est
vraiment pas le moment de changer les
règles du jeu dans cette période très
difficile et pourtant peut-être que le
gouvernement voudrait inciter le retour
à l'emploi dans cette période difficile
avec une réforme de l'assurance chômage
attendez il faudrait que les employés
existent les emplois disparaissent
aujourd'hui il faut en créer et il faut
réorienter l'argent vers la création
d'emploi vers la recherche vers le
solliciter les dividendes qui explosent
depuis quelques années comme depuis très
longtemps il faut mobiliser de l'argent
dans le sens de l'intérêt économique et
de l'intérêt social de ce pays donc leur
vie sainement qu'on nous promettait ne
s'est pas produit la richesse a explosé
énormément de temps la pauvreté on a
passé le cap des deux millions de
bénéficiaires du RSA d'un locataire du
RSA et la pauvreté a atteint tous 10
millions de personnes dans ce pays donc
franchement il y a encore beaucoup de
travail à faire dans ce domaine là merci
beaucoup Eric Bocquet pour votre
intervention
Emmanuel Capu on a entendu Eric Bocquet
qui sans surprise s'oppose au retour de
réforme telle que la réforme des
retraites ou la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et pour vous est-ce que c'est le
moment et bien de reprendre de revenir
sur ce type de réforme des réformes qui
peuvent braquer l'opinion est-ce que
l'art est à l'apaisement et faut-il
attendre encore pour ce type de réforme
mentir aux Français on a une dette qui a
explosé à cause du quoi qu'il en coûte
on est passé à 120% de PIB de tête
d'endettement
c'était justifié ça l'est encore compte
tenu de la situation sanitaire mais ça
va être
remboursable il va falloir le rembourser
pour plusieurs générations donc on ne
peut pas mentir aux Français en leur
disant que ça ne coûtera rien aux
Français et donc on ne peut pas remettre
les réformes structurelles de ce pays a
trop tard je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui
on a le temps de le faire d'ici la fin
du quinquennat mais si c'est pas fait
avant la fin du quinquennat ça devra
être fait immédiatement dès le tout
début du prochain parce que les réformes
les retraites on aura plus les moyens de
les payer et je rajouterai au surplus
que l'effort portait par les jeunes ne
doit pas porter que sur les jeunes parce
que la l'endettement aujourd'hui ce sont
les actifs qui vont le régler pendant
toute leur vie
et il est donc équitable que chacun peut
cet effort soit réparti sur toutes les
générations y compris sur les
générations les plus âgées qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus protégés face au
covid
idem pour la réforme du chômage on peut
pas mentir aux gens effectivement
chômage augmente et de façon assez
importante et y compris dans les
derniers chiffres qui sont tombés la
semaine dernière mais on évitera pas la
réforme du chômage et je lirai même plus
ça doit être une opportunité l'ensemble
de ces réformes doivent à mon sens être
examinés au vu de la situation sanitaire
qui a montré que notamment en termes de
relocalisation les industries
stratégiques de relocalisation des
emplois on a des choses à faire en
France et en Europe et on ne doit plus
voir les choses de la façon dont on les
voyait avant la crise sanitaire voilà il
y a des enseignements à tirer de la
crise selon vous Jérôme durain vous
entendez Emmanuel Capu qui me dit eh
bien le quoiqu'il en coûte il va bien
finir par avoir un coût et pour lui et
bien il faut donc faire toutes ces
réformes structurelles et notamment à la
réforme des retraites
je crois qu'on peut pas raisonner dans
notre bulle sans le pays réel chacun de
mes trois collègues là c'est bien
comment ça se passe sur le terrain on a
des gosses qui sont perdus on a des
entrepreneurs qui sont au bout du bout
on a des gens qui vont mal tous donc se
dire les gars on reprend le réformes
comme si rien ne s'était passé alors
qu'on connaît une crise
gravissime comme notre pays en a
rarement connu ça n'est pas le moment à
un an de l'élection présidentielle de
remettre au tout sur la table comme si
on avait tout devant nous qu'est-ce qui
est utile qu'est-ce qui est souhaitable
qu'est-ce qui est possible faire la
réforme des retraites en ce moment ce
n'est pas souhaitable les gens vont mal
le billet est traumatisé il est abîmé il
est accro ce n'est pas souhaitable
organisez l'état différemment et on sait
que c'est une nécessité on a vu les
débats sur les préfets les agences
régionales de santé l'absurdistan
l'organisation de l'État la place des
élus est-ce que vous pensez qu'on va
faire une bonne réforme de
l'organisation territoriale de dans la
période avec tous les textes qu'on a et
dans le contexte où on est je ne crois
pas donc gérons déjà la crise sanitaire
faisons du bon travail sur la priorité
redonner le moral redonner la santé
redonner la mort le moral aux gens et
couper ce qui peut l'être et puisque
Emmanuel Capu le dit il y en a pour
plusieurs générations il sera bientôt
pour le prochain Président de la
République de reprendre ce travail là
parce que notre priorités c'est la santé
des Français c'est la santé économique
et sociale de ce pays et je pense qu'il
y a plein de gens qui sont d'abord sur
autre chose que les réforme que nous
dont nous des bâtons ici entre nous ça
vous fait réagir
on a il faut laisser du temps au temps
il faut l'apaisement aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas d'accord j'entends bien
Jérôme je connais son sentiment est je
connais son sens politique aussi des
responsabilités mais dire aujourd'hui
repoussons à plus tard ce qui va nous
permettre de préparer l'avenir
c'est pas responsable politiquement on
doit gérer le covid Jérôme a raison mais
dans le même temps on doit aussi faire
en sorte que les dire pas de réforme de
retraite est-ce que ça veut dire par
exemple mais c'est pas grave les
retraites laissons s'enfoncer le régime
de retraite laissons s'enfoncer la dette
se fera une dette supplémentaire on
verra ça plus tard repousser à plus tard
j'allais dire des réformes qui vont
permettre une fois que la crise sera
passée à l'économie et la rôle plan de
relance qui va venir la relance qui doit
revenir de me la confiance qui doit
revenir tout le monde je sais bien qui
aujourd'hui j'entends bien qu'il y a des
gens
on aura toujours une bonne raison de
repousser il y aura toujours une bonne
raison de repousser et moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a deux ou trois
réformes importantes je sais pas ce
qu'il arrivera des retraites je crois
qu'on doit continuer à y travailler
aujourd'hui mais il y a des réformes
aujourd'hui qui sont importantes dans
l'organisation de notre état dans sa
volonté de pouvoir répartir
la loi sur la dépendance la loi de
programmation
séparatisme la loi sécurité la loi sur
le climat il y a le climat qui est
urgent aujourd'hui
on va le gouvernement déterminera
lesquels et à ce moment-là on verra mais
pour vous personnellement ça doit être
quoi c'est une ou deux lois
supplémentaires je pense que je pense
quoi les prix peut y avoir une loi
j'allais dire d'égalité sociale
on voit bien regarde dans matière il y a
la loi sur la justice des mineurs c'est
important aussi pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de lois
sociales qui viennent encore en cours
pendant pendant ces 6 mois une ou deux
doivent être choisis on va voir avec le
gouvernement on en parlera ce soir
comment on va les choisir et apprendre
les soumettre aux Français donc c'est
l'égalité sociale pour vous la priorité
pas forcément des réformes de la vie
quotidienne des Français la vie
quotidienne Philippe d'allier il y a
plein de choses importantes et et utiles
maintenant je crois que la
responsabilité des politiques c'est
d'expliquer clairement aux Français dans
quelle situation se trouve le pays et
avoir le courage de le dire parce que ça
n'est pas très populaire effectivement
de porter un message qui consiste
pourtant dire que nous avions 1200
milliards de dettes en 2004 2000
milliards en 2014 2800 milliards à la
fin 2021 si quelqu'un dans ce pays pense
que ça peut continuer comme ça sans
qu'il y ait des conséquences graves pour
tout le monde pour tous les Français des
plus riches au plus modestes comme pour
toutes les entreprises celui qui
tiendrait ce langage là est un
irresponsable voilà alors je sais bien
que les périodes prélectorales sont peu
propices au discours de vérité il faut
être courage mais il faut que nous ayons
ce courage parce que les lendemains vont
être très difficiles sinon voilà donc
moi je je redis que on ne peut pas
arrêter les réformes même les réformes
qui vont être difficiles ne pas
s'attaquer aux réforme des retraites
mais ça veut dire quoi laisser filer le
déficit mais jusqu'à quand jusqu'au
moment effectivement on sera incapable
de payer les pensions sans les raboter
de 5 à 10% pour tout le monde il faut
que notre collègue du règne courage de
le dire aux Français ça toujours
repoussé à plus tard les réformes c'est
irresponsable et c'est de plus en plus
irresponsable parce que la situation du
pays dégradé de manière enfin soudaine
inattendue avec cette crise du covid on
ne peut pas faire comme si elle n'était
pas là Jérôme Durand je vous laisse
répondre
ce n'est pas responsable de vouloir
reporter la réforme des retraites
si Emmanuel Macron et le gouvernement de
Jean Castex trouve les moyens de
proposer des textes au Parlement c'est
ce sont eux les mettre des horloges qui
le fasse ne travaille à nous c'est
d'apporter nos idées de contribuer à la
mise en oeuvre de ces réformes d'être
dans l'opposition quand c'est utile et
quand on a besoin de nous je crois pas
qu'on soit irresponsable on l'a montré
plusieurs fois dans l'année sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire donc si vous pensez
que dans la période la réforme des
retraites est faisable faites-le
voilà il y a pas de difficultés pour
nous mais je pense que dans la période
ce qui est important c'est déjà qu'on
remonte ce pays sur le plan sanitaire
sur le plan économique et social et donc
dire la dette elle est immense il faut
arrêter ça veut dire quoi on arrête tout
ce qu'on a mis en œuvre pour soutenir
l'économie l'admire à bout de bras moi
je pense que c'est ça qui est
responsable donc faisons déjà ce qu'on a
à faire sur le plan sanitaire il reste
très peu de temps il y a déjà plein de
textes sur la table si vous comptez en
rajouter en Bouteiller le Parlement avec
des textes qu'on traitera mal qu'on
traitera trop vite pour faire des
réformes qui seront inabouties voire un
populaire alors je pense que ça n'est
pas une bonne idée Emmanuel capuv vous
votre réaction et puis sur aussi cette
cette période est-ce que c'est important
aussi pour le gouvernement de dire que
il y a la vision continue éviter le
procès en immobilier parce que vous
l'avez dit flip d'alliance on est dans
une période prélectorale il y a les
départementales les régionales et bien
sûr tout le monde pense aussi à 2022
aujourd'hui il faut montrer que les
réformes l'esprit de réforme se poursuit
je pense que plus que jamais le
gouvernement il doit montrer qu'il est
là pour protéger les Français il doit
les protéger de l'urgence sanitaire
vis-à-vis de du vaccin notamment il doit
les protéger de l'urgence
sécuritaire et là ça a été dit il y a
des textes qui viennent à la rentrée qui
sont positives sur le séparatisme sur la
sécurité et il doit les protéger
vis-à-vis de l'urgence économique de
croissance et effectivement je pense
qu'on ne peut pas dire aux Français que
ça ne va rien coûter le quoi l'on coûte
il va coûter à chacun des Français et il
faut donc faire en sorte que ce ne soit
pas que cette génération qui paie et que
grâce à la croissance et donc à la
fluidification de notre économie et à la
relance
ça ne coûte pas qu'on puisse rembourser
la dette et pas seulement en attendant
en reportant sur les générations futures
donc la clé c'est la croissance et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense que la
croissance passe aussi par la
décentralisation et par le rôle des
collectivités territoriales voilà il
nous reste juste deux minutes et pour
terminer je voudrais aborder un sujet
long comme une dissertation
ça n'interroge pas aussi un peu sur la
durée du quinquennat parce qu'on n'a pas
arrêté de dire c'est c'est trop court un
appui de temps qu'il s'agisse de Nicolas
Sarkozy de François Hollande ils ont
tous vu leur quinquennat complètement
bouleversé par une crise et la crise
économique de 2008 il y a eu la crise
terroriste là on a la crise sanitaire
avec d'immenses retombées économiques et
sociales est-ce que c'est pas trop court
cinq ans quand on voit qu'on est percuté
à chaque fois comme ça et on s'est à
peine projeté que c'est déjà la fin je
vais vous surprendre parce que je vais
rejoindre l'esprit de la Cinquième
République j'ai jamais été au stylo ou
c'est en genre même 10 ans le fait
d'avoir mis cinq ans
comme la concomitance de la
présidentielle et législatives fait
qu'on crée un phénomène que beaucoup
rejette aujourd'hui je trouve que les 7
ans c'est pas si mal 50 c'est vrai c'est
mieux qu'aux États-Unis ou c'est 4 ans
par ailleurs mais il faut avouer que 5
ans or la crise des gilets jaunes et
orque vide ça permettait aussi ça permet
aussi de faire des réformes et de le
continuer et moi je suis pas du tout
j'allais dire défaitiste pour l'avenir
au contraire je pense que ce bilan on va
pouvoir en être fier qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à réformer dans l'année qui
vient et qu'on pourra se présenter
devant les Français avec agir un message
d'espoir cet endroit se renouvelable ou
pas
du septennat la durée de la législature
c'était 5 ans donc c'est vrai que
rappelons-nous qu'on a eu quand même
beaucoup de cohabitation qui ont
radicalement changé la donne pour les
présidents de la République en place
donc à mon avis ce débat là est clos il
est derrière nous même si on peut
regretter même si effectivement on peut
regretter le septennat mais pour autant
la législature c'est 5 ans et 5 ans
c'est court notamment lorsque des crises
surviennent elle est très rapidement
Jérôme Durin Emmanuel capuche c'est trop
court 5 ans faudrait peut-être rallonger
un petit peu
pour travailler
pour la pour la pour le renouvellement
allez Emmanuel capule la fin en quelques
secondes c'est court mais on va pas je
pense pas qu'on va réformer ce le
quinquennat donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle effectivement la dernière année
doit être une année utile et que ça doit
pas être une année d'arrêt on peut pas
perdre de temps merci beaucoup à tous
les cas d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat de 2021 où l'on a tent le tracé
quelques perspectives mais pour leur
actualité c'est aussi avant tout la
crise sanitaire et ses conséquences il
va en être largement question dans une
demi-heure lors de la séance de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
une séance que vous allez pouvoir suivre
avec nos journalistes Alexandre Poussard
salle des conférences et Steve Jourdain
qui est dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi
je le disais il va une nouvelle fois
être largement question du covid oui
stratégie de vaccination thème alors je
vous connais vous allez me dire qu'on en
est déjà beaucoup parlé ici au Parlement
c'est vrai pas plus tard qu'hier Olivier
Véran était devant la commission des
affaires sociales mais pourquoi
avons-nous pris autant de retard dans la
vaccination par rapport à nos voisins
européens sur ce plan les élus estiment
qu'ils n'ont pas réellement reçu de
réponse de la part du gouvernement il
devrait donc revenir à la charge sur ce
thème dans l'après-midi ce que veulent
savoir aussi les sénateurs c'est quel
plan qu'on te mettre en place le
gouvernement pour précisément accélérer
la vaccination sur le terrain qu'elle
est le calendrier précis à moyen long
terme question à suivre côté communiste
côté socialiste et côté républicain
autre sujet de préoccupation cet
après-midi la situation des étudiants à
l'université on parle d'environ un
million 700 000 étudiants au total un
million 700 000 étudiants qui ont
théoriquement fait leur entrée le 4
janvier dernier théoriquement car entre
le flou sur les dates de reprise des
cours en présentiel et des examens
perturbés voire parfois même annuler les
universités ne fonctionnent qu'à très
bas régime les universités sont
littéralement à bout de souffle sont
épuisés le gouvernement sera interpellé
à ce sujet par les écologistes les
centristes et les socialistes dans un
peu moins d'une demi-heure maintenant
merci Steve et on vous retrouve
effectivement dans une demi-heure la
covid et la politique vaccinale du
gouvernement on va en parler avec nos
deux invités déjà installés sur ce
plateau Sonia de la propreté bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice tant triste
du Calvados si vous venez de coécrire un
rapport sur la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement dans avec le texte l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques avec
nous également le sénateur Martin
arriver également vous êtes sénateur la
République en marche des Yvelines
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales qui a auditionné et
bien hier Olivier Véran le ministre de
la Santé sur ce même sujet la politique
vaccinale mais on va d'abord voir
ensemble comment a débuté et bien cette
campagne de vaccination dans les EHPAD
reportage dans leur à Charleval près de
Rouen dans un établissement pilote le
premier à avoir pu vacciner ces
résidents Samia de Schir et Fabien
Ricard
cette précieuse dose de vaccin
surveillée comme le lait sur le feu
depuis qu'elles ont quitté le super
congélateur qui les maintenait à - 80
degrés pour être livré dans cette
pharmacie de l'Eure un compte à rebours
s'est enclenché ce sont des vaccins qui
sont conservés entre plus deux et plus 8
degrés entre le temps de leur
décongélation et le temps
d'administration
ceci au maximum pendant 5 jours nous
avons la date de décongélation sur ce
document et voilà nous avons vérifié
l'intégrité de des vaccins et nous
apprêtons à les differer direction
l'EHPAD voisins pendant le transport les
doses doivent être maintenues à la
verticale et à bonne température grâce à
des pins de glace
et on se sent pourvu d'une grande
responsabilité puisque c'est des vaccins
qui sont tant attendus pour pouvoir
enfin se débarrasser de
cette crise sanitaire on l'espère
l'EPAD de la ville la Saint Michel est
un établissement pilote le premier dans
l'Eure un vacciner ses résidents contre
le covid-19 alors voilà Patrick merci
les fameux vaccins sur les 35 résidents
de l'EHPAD 27 ont accepté de se faire
vacciner Antoine Varin n'a pas hésité
très longtemps j'avais envie de faire
quelque chose pour moi et pour les
autres un peu dire bon ben ce que ça
sert au moins les travaux qu'ils ont
fait que ça s'est avec quelque chose et
ben c'est bien les résultats maintenant
bon j'espère que le résultat sera
jusqu'au bout que
après ça je vais voir la forme
l'équipe doit rester attentive à toute
réaction anormale donc nous gardons nos
résidences pendant 15 minutes afin de le
surveiller les éventuelles effets
indésirables le plus redouté étant le
choc anaphylactique c'est-à-dire à
chaque allergique une fois ouverte
chaque dose permet de faire 6 vaccins
mais ceux qui ne sont pas injectés dans
les 6 heures sont perdus le surplus a
donc été proposé aux familles des
résidents et aux personnels de l'EHPAD
mais uniquement aux personnes à risque
ou âgées de plus de 50 ans la directrice
aurait aimé pouvoir le proposer à tous
les salariés quel que soit leur âge je
regrette effectivement que la
vaccination n'est pas été élargie à plus
grand nombre de personnels ce que le
jour d'aujourd'hui il y a les demandes
voilà augmentent les demandes augmentent
et on se rend compte que c'est une
contrainte
hebdomadaire donc nous à chaque moindre
signe d'un salarié on le met en arrêt on
teste tous les salariés donc on refait
un test systématique toutes les semaines
la seconde injection aurait lieu trois
semaines plus tard les trois quarts des
résidents de l'EHPAD seront alors
vaccinés contre le covid mais ce ne sera
pas encore suffisant pour lever les
gestes barrières tant que le reste de la
population n'est pas vacciné les EHPAD
devront continuer à se protéger des
visiteurs
Sonia de la provoqué on va parler
largement de la politique vaccinale mais
peut-être une réaction à ce reportage où
est évoqué un petit blocage qui est pas
forcément représentatif mais tout de
même on nous explique qu'il faut donc
injecter l'ensemble du flacon qui
contient si dose en peu de temps en 6
heures et donc parfois pour la fin du
flacon les pâtes proposent aux familles
fragiles
âgées ou aux soignants fragiles et âgés
de se faire vacciner mais ils disent si
on n'est pas dansé cadre-là et on peut
pas vous vacciner
vous voyez ça normal alors il y a
clairement un certain nombre de
situations et de départements où on a
carrément anticipé cette question je
vois il y a des hôpitaux qui constituent
préalablement des listes complémentaires
et qui appellent quand ils restent des
doses en fin de de en fin de journée et
qui appelle un certain nombre de
personnes volontaires qui veulent se
faire vacciner c'est une façon de pas
perdre de doses vous avez dit si dose
c'est 5 normalement mais on se sent bien
les choses on fait 6 donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle
et il y a des EHPAD où clairement des
listes ont été constitués pour appeler
la famille etc donc en fait c'est pas
qu'on exclut de la population c'est que
on privilégie de pouvoir vacciner les
personnes à risque de faire des maladies
graves ou d'être hospitalisée voire
d'aller en réanimation donc si sur cette
liste là on a des personnes qui ont plus
à risque c'est elle qu'on va privilégier
mais s'il reste des doses et qu'on n'a
pas de personnarise sous la main à
vacciner on va vacciner quelqu'un de la
population générale l'objectif c'est
quand même les l'humilité le plus tôt
possible également au-delà de la
protection des personnes qui en ont
besoin Martin lévrier envoie aussi à
travers ce reportage et bien que les
réticences ont été élevés assez
facilement dans cette EHPAD des
personnes qui voulaient pas forcément se
faire vacciner initialement et d'avoir
un effet d'espèces de neige et faire un
petit peu vertueux et bien finalement
dans cette EHPAD par exemple tout à peu
près tout le monde vient sur votre
plateau il y a quelques mois j'avais dit
que les Français avaient été assez
extraordinaire pendant cette crise qui
dure toujours dans cette pandémie avec
le respect des masques avec le respect
des gestes barrières avec cet ensemble
donc il y a toujours en France une une
logique de controverse parfois
d'opposition et qui est d'ailleurs très
positive et qui fait avancer les choses
et sur le vaccin et le départ qui fait
avancer le débat tant qu'il reste dans
la controverse quand c'est le combat
c'est pas très intéressant mais dans le
cas de la vaccination on a eu exactement
la même chose il y a une forme
d'inquiétude et qui est tout à fait
légitime je veux dire un vaccin des
vaccins pas un en plus des vaccins
inventés en moins d'un an enfin moi je
suis émerveillé je tiens à le redire je
suis émerveillé devant les progrès de la
science qui vont nous sauver c'est
remarquable il faut le dire
je crois que là vraiment il faut il faut
remercier les chercheurs il faut
remercier l'industrie pharmaceutique il
faut se rendre compte du pas de géant
qui a été fait et qui va nous permettre
d'avancer et donc les Français sont
conscients de ça ce sont rendus compte
que tout était mis en œuvre pour que la
sécurité maximale existe et au fur et à
mesure toutes les inquiétudes vont être
levées pour 90 % des gens il y aura
toujours des réfractaires définitifs
mais là c'est plus de l'idéologie que de
là que de la science ce n'est la
provoqué vous avez coécrit un rapport
qui approuve globalement la stratégie de
l'exécutif mais tout de même vous avez
aussi déploré un certain nombre de
retard pris ces dernières semaines quels
en sont les raisons pour vous il y a eu
alors de la précaution de la complexité
administrative dans le processus avec la
visite près vaccinale etc qui était une
façon de perdre du temps avec avec cinq
jours entre la n'était pas prévu tout à
fait au départ donc ça a été un peu
quelque chose qui s'est rajouté je pense
aussi de la part dans enfin dans dans
les dans les EHPAD notamment c'était une
façon de pouvoir accompagner mieux les
personnes âgées il y avait cette
inquiétude de père des doses mais
clairement c'est pas un sujet cette
inquiétude de faire des doses parce que
si on constitue des X complémentaires on
les perd pas les doses parce que
l'objectif c'est vacciner
prioritairement les personnages plus de
vacciner tout le monde donc on voit bien
que il y a eu voilà et puis il y a eu du
retard à l'allumage c'est à dire que il
a été annoncé pendant les vacances de la
trêve de Noël parce que les vacances
tout le monde en a pas eu bien sûr il a
été annoncé que c'était avancé d'une
semaine la campagne telle qu'elle était
prévue quand on a eu le débat en
décembre le 17 c'était prévu le 4
janvier le 4 janvier clairement on n'a
pas commencé à vacciner en déroulant les
choses c'est à dire que il y a pas il y
a eu une forme de lenteur à l'allumage
des précautions probablement des
prudences
la défiance vaccinale était une épée de
Damoclès qui qui a inquiété on voit bien
finalement que le meilleur vecteur de
communication c'est par exemple médecin
qui se fait vacciner devant ses patient
comme ça pu arriver dans certains EHPAD
et tout de suite bien derrière il y a
une valeur d'exemplarité et puis ça
rassure je veux dire un médecin qui se
fait vacciné un soignant un infirmier ou
une infirmière une aide-soignante ou un
aide-soignante c'est ça change
complètement la donne et le regard des
patients c'est normal il y a ceux qui
sont du corps médical et qui qui
s'ils font et bien ça rassure puis à
ceux qui n'y sont pas et donc qui ont
besoin d'avoir les éléments de
rassurance autour du vaccin voilà
exactement un retard à l'allumage je
voudrais juste qu'on écoute parce que
Olivier Véran hier vient bien sûr a eu à
répondre à un certain nombre de
critiques sur ce sujet on le sait le
gouvernement a été largement critiqué
sur la lenteur des premières semaines de
la campagne vaccinale et lui hier a
impliqué certaines difficultés non et
bien à la politique française mais
plutôt à des difficultés d'ordre
scientifiques et européennes en écoute
Olivier Véran il y a des zones
d'incertitudes qui ne sont pas de nature
politique et qui sont de nature
scientifique par exemple est-ce que le
vaccin AstraZeneca sera validé par les
autorités européennes s'il laisse que
ces fin janvier est-ce que c'est fin
février est-ce que c'est fin mars s'il
est est-ce que ce sera destiné à un
public
âgé ou est-ce que c'est pour un public
plutôt jeune je n'ai pas les réponses à
ces questions
voilà Olivier Véran qui nous dit bon bah
les critiques finalement sur la
logistique pour lui elles étaient
outrancières elles étaient pas à leur
place mais il y a d'autres sujets
d'inquiétude si vous me permettez c'est
pas tout à fait le même sujet
AstraZeneca n'est pas encore validé et à
straveneca on attend la date de
validation donc
il a eu raison bien sûr
je vais pas m'engager sur une politique
de vaccination tous azimut parce que
c'est un c'est un vaccin je le rappelle
qui lui est température ambiante enfin à
zéro à moins de 5 degrés enfin 0 à 5
degrés ah non pas moi 5 donc il va être
beaucoup plus difficile à distribuer
mais on peut pas s'engager une on peut
pas engager une petite vaccinale tant
qu'on a pas les autorisations de lancer
sur le marché se produit donc c'est ce
qu'il disait pour le tout début je mets
des nuances quand même sur le début moi
je crois beaucoup à la pédagogie et j'ai
bien vu me j'en ai déjà parlé aussi ici
ma maman a plus de 100 ans elle est pas
en épagne mais en résidence de personnes
âgées et il y avait une inquiétude des
personnes âgées qu'il a fallu lever qui
a été assez longue à ça a été des
discussions avec mes frères et sœurs
avec le médecin etc donc je pense qu'il
y a eu tout ça aussi on ne voulait pas
rater la première marche je crois que le
gouvernement est 1000 fois raison de pas
rater la première marche parce qu'elle
était la plus importante il va aller
mieux prendre un petit peu de temps au
début pour convaincre les personnes
âgées qui sont les personnes les plus
fragiles vous l'avez dit à juste raison
et il va être mieux permanent un petit
peu de temps d'abord pour bien réussir
après et que le coup soit vraiment bien
lancé la précipitation l'urgence ne
répond pas toujours à l'important il
vaut mieux faire l'important d'abord
il faut pas faire les loges de la
lenteur non plus c'est à dire que là je
constate qu'on a un million 1,8 millions
de doses disponibles avec 500 000 qui
vont être distribués toutes les semaines
et il y a moins de 200 000 personnes
vaccinées ce que je veux dire ce qui est
un décalage entre la disponibilité des
doses et l'administration réelle sur le
terrain et donc là là où j'ai quand même
un sujet logistique là où je pense qu'il
faut qu'on il faut que ça déroule il
faut prendre du temps peut-être pour
bien faire les choses mais clairement il
y a un truc quand on part c'est
l'éventuelle troisième vague c'est le
variant britannique tous ces sujets qui
sont des inquiétudes nous sommes aux
portes de ces sujets là on le sait très
bien ça bouge quand même un peu les
incidences du virus dans les territoires
et de la maladie et donc clairement de
toute façon on est instamment obligé
d'accélérer et donc j'espère que le
temps qui a été un peu pris au départ va
aider à fluidifier très largement
l'arrivée de la dose jusqu'à
l'administration
ce sujet là et que la montée en
puissance est exponentielle est très
forte et heureusement mais attention
attention elle est très forte on propose
on devrait arriver au million d'ici la
fin du mois de vacciner
l'autre réponse j'attire votre attention
là-dessus quand on parle de d'un risque
de 3e vague c'est pas le vaccin qui va
l'empêcher si elle arrive dans les
semaines qui viennent il suffit de voir
ce qui se passe en Israël et dramatique
l'Israël c'est dramatique l'Israël le
pays qui est le plus vacciné et pour
autant qu'il confine totalement donc
attention
il y aura pas de 3e vague le vaccin
protégera ce qui serait hospitalisé
s'ils étaient en contact avec le virus
ou qui irait en réanimation et si c'est
le variant britannique qui aura beaucoup
plus de gens malades et chez les plus
jeunes également et à ce moment là il y
aura des places disponibles à l'hôpital
et on pourra aussi traiter les
pathologies classiques donc là
vaccination accélérée sur les
populations Istres c'est essentiel on
dit la même chose également tout à
l'heure des territoires et certains
territoires particulièrement touchés par
le virus réclame un effort particulier
pour eux et notamment plus
de vues ce Joseph nouvelle sénatrice des
Ardennes et allait à votre micro
Alexandre effectivement elle sait Joseph
qui fait partie de ses élus des Ardennes
qui ont écrit un courrier au premier
ministre Jean Castex pour lui demander
une priorité dans la livraison des doses
de vaccins pour ce département des
Ardennes qui est très touché par
l'épidémie
une démarche collective pour demander au
Premier ministre à ce que le nombre de
vaccins le nombre de doses de vaccins
soit adaptés à la situation sanitaire de
notre département qui est
particulièrement touchée on a été moins
touché lors du premier lors de la
première vague et là on est dans une
phase de plateau avec des taux
d'incidence et des taux de positivité
qui reste parmi les plus élevés du Grand
est donc on a vraiment souhaité une
démarche collective pas évidemment dans
le but de faire des stocks de vaccins
mais de d'adapter en fonction évidemment
de nos besoins qui sont énormes les
doses de vaccins et donc c'est c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a fait ce
courrier à la fois au niveau de mon
département et au niveau de la région
Grand Est les élus du Grand Est du
département des Ardennes qui disent que
et bien ceux qui cloche c'est que par
exemple les Ardennes ont autant de doses
de vaccins que un département comme le
Gers sous l'Isère qui est un peu moins
touché et qui est un petit peu moins
touché alors que nous on est quand même
particulièrement touché depuis des
semaines d'ailleurs on est touché par le
couvre-feu à 18h depuis déjà le 2
janvier avec une une espèce de plateau
et c'est vrai qu'on ne voit pas la
situation s'améliorer donc c'est
vraiment un cri d'alerte une demande
vraiment express sans polémique mais de
dire on a besoin de ces vaccins et voilà
on vous demande aussi un message clair
sur le nombre de vaccins disponibles
parce que on a aussi eu du retard par
exemple sur la livraison des des frigos
enfin des frigos qui permettent
notamment la conservation à moins de 90
degrés on l'a touché 10 quasiment 10
jours plus tard que que d'autres que
d'autres régions et puis cette polémique
également qu'on entend sur notamment le
vaccin moderna qui est quand même plus
adapté je trouve à notre je suis pas
médecin mais plus adapté à notre
territoire rural en termes de
conservation et là aussi on entend des
discours un petit peu variés donc ce que
l'on demande tout ce collectivement
c'est un message de clarté lisibilité
pour notre département alors justement
sur le vaccin moderna Olivier Véran le
ministre de la Santé assuré que là les
territoires les plus touchés seraient et
bien livré en priorité est-ce que ce
sera le cas des Ardennes comme je vous
j'ai entendu ce discours mais j'ai
entendu aussi un message en off qui
disait bon par différentes voix locales
qu'on ne serait peut-être pas priorité
pour le moderna donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai on réclame de la lisibilité et
vraiment un message clair de la part du
gouvernement alors toujours pour rester
sur ce département ardennais notamment
sur la métropole de Charleville-Mézières
il y a eu des mesures un peu en amont
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année avec le
couvre-feu à 18h une opération de
dépistage massif à Charleville-Mézières
il y a pas vraiment eu de conséquence
sur la situation sanitaire qui est
toujours dans le rouge il y a pas eu de
conséquences on est toujours dans une
phase plateau il y a pas eu envolée non
plus envolée de donc du nombre de nombre
de cas et je pense que là non plus je
suis pas un médecin pour émettre un avis
là-dessus mais je pense que l'intérêt
d'avoir fait ce à la fois cette campagne
de dépistage parce que ça a touché quand
même plusieurs territoires du
département et cette campagne dépistage
et le couvre-feu à 18h associer au port
du masque obligatoire depuis quasiment
dans tout le département depuis des mois
je pense que ça permet de sensibiliser
les gens à la situation qui est complexe
parce que on a tendance aussi les gens
ont dû dire ouais voilà ça va mieux on a
tel était le chiffre on fait plus
attention et je pense qu'au moins
l'intérêt il est pour moi au moins là
c'est de faire de la pédagogie de dire
attention le covid est toujours là on
est dans une situation quand même très
limite au niveau nos personnels
soignants au niveau de l'hôpital et je
pense que le message il était là merci
beaucoup elzof d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci merci merci beaucoup Alexandre
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord Martin
lévrier il faut une répartition des
vaccins affinés par territoire mieux
priorisé pour les territoires les plus
touchés comme les réclames et bien le
territoire des Ardennes mais c'est le
cas depuis le 11 janvier ou des
territoires ont été priorisés par
rapport à d'autres le PACA avait déjà
fait la demande je m'en souviens très
bien je l'avais entendu la télévision
avait pleuré en disant s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît accélérer chez nous
plutôt caillou ou c'est plus calme et
c'est déjà en cours donc ça a été dit
c'est affiché le ministre varan l'a
encore redit hier mais attention
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure en défaut de
stock les stocks on les a pour l'instant
c'est si on accélère très fort mais pour
l'instant pour les Ardennes comme pour
les autres départements moi j'ai pas
écho d'un département où il manquerait
des doses on n'est pas là du tout ça
serait presque souhaitable qu'on en a
qu'on arrive à cette deuxième ou
controverse quand on en sera là on se
dira tiens c'est déjà on avance de plus
en plus vite donc c'est très bien
de la pauvreté c'est pas forcément ça le
premier problème aujourd'hui le premier
problème c'est d'administrer toutes les
doses et puis d'avoir un plan de charge
puisque maintenant on sait à peu sur les
doses qui vont arriver par semaine qu'on
connaît la population concernée
l'effectif de la population concernée
par département c'est ça qu'il faut
ajuster au mieux en prenant en compte la
deuxième la deuxième injection à 21
jours au mieux quand même pour les
personnes âgées parce qu'on sait que ça
reste quand même important les 21 jours
et puis décaler un 42 pour pour les
autres mais moi ce que je pense c'est
que dans ces territoires là qui sont
particulièrement touchés la politique
publique globale de lutte contre
l'épidémie c'est c'est un package c'est
à dire qu'on doit tout adapter on doit
se poser la question de vacciner comme
on dit encore non c'était alerté tracé
isolé testé tracé isolé on doit bien
isoler mais on doit aussi pouvoir
proposer par exemple dans des dans des
clusters enfin des des cas groupés par
exemple dans des structures ou en milieu
professionnel de pouvoir vacciner ceux
qui sont pas spécifiquement des cas
contacts mais qui sinon qui sont dans un
état un environnement par exemple où il
pourrait diffuser du virus
qui n'était pas tout à fait prioritaire
qui le deviennent et donc peut plus
accélérer et autant qu'on accède mais
c'est au fur et à mesure parce que sinon
si on veut tout faire d'un coup ça ne
pourra pas fonctionner très grande il y
a des cas contacts des cas groupés qui
sont très importants et les cas contacts
nombreux et donc là je pense qu'il faut
renforcer les politiques sanitaires il
faut vraiment accompagner ce qui doivent
être isolés et pas se contenter d'un
coup de fil en disant voilà vous restez
chez vous cela alors c'est beaucoup plus
que ça alors que l'on voit Jean Castex
le Premier ministre qui est en train
d'arriver dans la salle des conférences
du Sénat le Premier ministre qui va
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions et notamment et bien
certainement la question sur la crise
sanitaire et sur les vaccins que va
poser Patrick canner le président du
groupe socialiste qui est à votre micro
Alexandre effectivement le président du
groupe socialiste qui va interroger le
gouvernement sur sa stratégie vaccinale
avec un retard dans le début de cette
campagne de vaccination mais la
livraison des doses de vaccins est en
train de s'accélérer le gouvernement
rattrape le retard oui un rattrapage au
combien nécessaire et le gouvernement a
réagi en réaction notamment
finalement à langonnade permettez-moi
d'expression qui a été celle du
président de la République il y a
maintenant une dizaine de jours donc il
était urgent que les choses bougent il
faut pas que nous ayons en permanence à
un train de retard parce que sinon nous
aurons finalement un guerre de retard
dans le sujet
200.000 vaccinés aujourd'hui après deux
semaines et demi de campagne voilà c'est
c'est mieux mais ce n'est pas encore
très glorieux et donc il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet comment se fait-il par
exemple qu'on n'est pas imaginé
précédemment les centres de vaccination
qui sont simplement en cours de
déploiement et moi je connais des élus
dans le Nord qui ont fait des
propositions pour créer des centres de
vaccination et qui n'ont pas eu de
réponse à ce stade pourquoi de n'avoir
pas anticipé et c'est ce mode
d'anticipation qui pose problème
aujourd'hui alors Patrick canard il y a
un autre sujet dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est le calendrier des
réformes du gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron dans cette crise sanitaire qui
monopolise dans l'action du gouvernement
est-ce que il est encore possible de
réformer le pays
actuellement je pense que un
gouvernement doit réformer le pays quel
qu'il soit il doit avoir un cap et moi
je me félicite que la crise sanitaire
qui est pourtant terrible ne soit pas le
seul objectif c'est le principal
objectif à régler mais ce n'est pas le
seul objectif et que des réformes
continuent à prospérer comme par exemple
la loi bioéthique avec notamment la
dimension de la création de la PMA dans
notre pays et bien nous y serons
favorables donc il faut que la vie
démocratique puisse se poursuivre
naturellement donc des réformes mais de
bonnes réformes et des réformes justes
pour être très clair mettons vraiment de
côté la réforme des retraites qui n'a
pas sa place dans le calendrier à venir
et le gouvernement est déjà en train
d'évaluer les réformes qui sont déjà
lancées avec un baromètre de l'action
publique qui est publié aujourd'hui
finalement ils sont déjà en train de
préparer l'élection présidentielle de
2022 à personne que Monsieur Macron on
se préparait à sa propre potentiel
réélection mais c'est légitime qu'un
président réfléchisse à pouvoir se
représenter
tout simplement il faut pas prendre les
Français en otage et en tout cas le
gouvernement ne pourra pas s'exonérer
des choix qu'il a fait jusqu'à présent
des choix très libéraux en début de
quinquennat qui ont été en fait compte
arrêté par la crise sanitaire le retour
de l'État mais dans des conditions qui
pour moi ne sont pas tout à fait justes
notamment sur le plan fiscal un dernier
mot sur la présidentielle 2022 et du
côté de la gauche de la sphère politique
avec Anne Hidalgo qui est en train
d'accélérer vers une éventuelle
candidature elle a lancé une plateforme
de réflexion et de rassemblement de la
gauche ça peut être la bonne candidat
pour la gauche et les écologistes pour
moi il est clair qu'il nous faut un
candidat de la gauche au ciel démocrate
de gouvernement manifestement il y a
plusieurs candidatures qui sont en train
d'émerger je m'en félicite parce que je
considère que ce que nous représentons
doit être représenté dans l'élection
présidentielle Anne Hidalgo fait partie
bien évidemment des solutions
sera-t-elle la solution ce sera d'abord
à elle d'en décider d'être candidate et
je pense que aujourd'hui elle coche
beaucoup de cases pour pouvoir mener à
bien ce combat merci beaucoup Patrick
canard d'avoir répondu répondu à mes
questions voilà on est 2021 début
2000 mais toutes les têtes sont déjà
tournées vers 2022 un mot sur
ce que demain on attend et bien
peut-être des annonces de la part et
bien d'Olivier Vérand qu'on voit
d'ailleurs arriver et de Jean Castex en
conférence de presse on parle
éventuellement d'un d'un couvre-feu
étendu à l'ensemble du territoire à 18h
dans les prochains jours il faut en tout
cas des restrictions sanitaires vu le
contexte pour vous Martinez le président
Kanner tout à l'heure et de son train de
retard systématique je rappellerai que
la deuxième vague a été contenue en
France de façon
très positive par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres pays européens d'autres pays
mondiaux donc si le gouvernement fait le
choix d'un confiseur pardon d'un
couvre-feu à 18h c'est qu'il a des
bonnes raisons et on sait bien sûr et on
sait que ce fonctionnement est efficace
donc si malheureusement on doit le faire
c'est qu'il faut le faire et là-dessus
j'ai toute confiance dans le
gouvernement qui a prouvé sur les quatre
derniers mois sa capacité à agir de
façon positive sur cette crise c'est la
preuve de son Ant participation nous dit
Martin lévrier au contraire donc un
couvre-feu à 18h sur l'ensemble du
territoire vous pensez que c'est très
suffisant que ma petite formation
scientifique quand même malgré tout
je me fais un peu me poser la question
de est-ce que c'est efficace à 18h par
rapport à 20h quel est le gain vous
doutez de terme économique ça c'est
certain que ça a des conséquences donc
je pense qu'il y a un rapport bénéficie
bénéfice car regardé on sait que le
confinement complet et très efficace
parce que ça casse complètement la
transmission enfin je veux dire c'est
des choses qu'il faut voir parce que
passer de 20h à 18h pour toute une
société ça n'a rien d'anodin et sur le
plan économique pas du tout et je
voudrais avoir la certitude ce qui n'est
pas le cas tout à fait du point de vue
des épidémiologistes pour l'instant que
c'est quelque chose qui est de nature à
endiguer complètement la vague
épidémique et bien merci merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
face-à-face largement consacré bien la
crise sanitaire un sujet qui va être
encore beaucoup abordé lors des
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement ça
commence dans quelques minutes et en
attendant Alex vous êtes toujours celle
des conférences avec le président de la
commission des lois François Naël buffet
Françoise buffet c'est un peu l'homme de
l'année au Sénat il va avoir du pain sur
la planche en ce début d'année et oui
beaucoup de textes importants que va
examiner la commission des lois a
commencé par un texte qui c'est fait
attendre longtemps c'est la réforme de
la justice pénale des mineurs François
Noel buffet à le ministre de la Justice
d'ailleurs Eric Dupont-Moretti est
auditionné aujourd'hui sur ce texte et
en fait le ministre est déjà en train et
bien d'organiser l'application de cette
réforme avant même l'examen au Sénat et
ça ça ne plaît pas beaucoup au sénateur
ça ne plaît pas beaucoup à la commission
des lois évidemment
on peut comprendre que les choses
s'organisent mais on peut pas admettre
qu'une circulaire ayant plutôt qu'une
lettre ayant quasiment valeur de
circulaire soit envoyée dans tous les
tribunaux pour dire comment ça va se
passer alors que le texte même va être
pris par l'assemblée par le Sénat dans
les dans les jours qui viennent et donc
on posera la question ce soir au
ministre puisqu'il vient en audition
au-delà de ça la difficulté c'est que
rappelez-vous nous avions demandé au
Sénat un débat sur ce sujet là au moment
madame beloubet était garde des sceaux
elle nous l'avait promis finalement de
la partenaire n'a pas tenu sa promesse
puisqu'elle a demandé à légiférer par
ordonnance ça a été fait aujourd'hui on
va pas se priver d'un débat important au
Sénat sur une réforme de la danse 45 qui
est tout aussi importante et donc de ce
fait nous jouerons notre rôle jusqu'au
bout voilà mais on était assez trouve ça
le procédé inégant si je lui permette et
le Sénat va jouer également ce rôle dans
l'examen de la proposition de loi
sécurité globale qui fait polémique
depuis plusieurs mois et les sénateurs
ont sont en train de réécrire l'article
24 sur l'interdiction de la diffusion
malveillante d'image de policiers en
cours d'intervention le ministre de
l'Intérieur Charles de Darmanin a été
auditionné sur ce sujet et il n'est pas
vraiment d'accord avec la réécriture du
Sénat qu'il estime trop dure car les
sénateurs veulent inscrire ce délit dans
le code pénal
à l'occasion de
ce point de discussion en tous les cas
si c'était un point de désaccord moi je
voudrais rappeler que la commission des
lois poursuivra l'objectif principal qui
est celui de protéger des personnes et
les policiers en particulier de tous les
actes dont ils peuvent être les victimes
les choses sont parfaitement claires
qu'elle soit la commission protégera
aussi les journalistes ça c'est
important dans la liberté de
l'information mais qu'il faut donc
rédiger totalement cet article 24 nous
ferons une proposition très simple on
l'intégrera dans le code pénal bien sûr
qu'on intégra dans le code pénal les
choses nous paraissent enfin je dis
c'est pas encore fait mais ça se fera on
proposera cela en tous les cas de façon
à ce que les choses soient parfaitement
claires que le quantum des peines sont
parfaitement établis et que l'infraction
soit bien écrite si je peux me permettre
et puis évidemment qu'on veillera à ce
que les journalistes ne soient pas visés
par cette incrimination là en
particulier et soit dans le régime
juridique qui est le leur et une
réécriture sénatoriale de l'article 24
qui va être suivi de très près l'examen
aura lieu en mars au Sénat merci
beaucoup François la nouvelle buffet
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et on va
tout de suite et bien se diriger dans la
tribune de presse en dents sur le
plateau sur le plateau de cul Xena pour
retrouver ta main on se retrouve
effectivement
Alexandre je précise que l'audition
d'Eric Dupont Moretti sur la réforme de
la justice des mineurs vous allez
pouvoir la suivre tout à l'heure sur
notre antenne à partir de
16h45 alors et bien les questions
d'actualité elles vont commencer d'un
instant à l'autre envoyer notre caméra
pointée sur le cabinet de départ d'où le
président du Sénat devrait sortir très
rapidement et bien pour venir présider
la séance et pour se rendre dans
l'hémicycle l'hémicycle ou justement et
bien nous nous rendons et où se trouve
Steve Steve Jourdain et bien pour un
point sur ce qu'on peut attendre sur le
menu de ses premières séances de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement de
l'année 2021 je vais pas vous surprendre
time il sera question évidemment de
covid cet après-midi et de la situation
des étudiants à l'université une
situation qui inquiète très fortement
les sénateurs on parle d'environ un
million 700000 étudiants au total un
million 700 000 étudiants dans les
universités qui ont théoriquement en
fait leur rentrée le 4 janvier dernier
théoriquement un cas sur le flou sur la
date de reprise en présentiel et des
dates de partiel d'examens qui n'ont pas
été respectées ou qui ont été perturbés
parfois les universités sont
littéralement épuisées elles
fonctionnent en tout cas à très faible
régime les profs sont met-on mécontents
les élèves sont en colère d'autant que
Jean Castex n'a pas eu un mot pour les
universités lors de sa conférence de
presse jeudi dernier ça sera donc
peut-être le cas cet après-midi en tout
cas le gouvernement sera interpellé à ce
sujet par les écologistes par les
centristes et par les socialistes et
puis il sera aussi question cet
après-midi de la stratégie de
vaccination on en a déjà beaucoup parlé
au Parlement pas plus tard qu'hier
Olivier Véran était devant la commission
des affaires sociales mais pourquoi
avons-nous pris autant de retard en
matière de vaccination par rapport aux
autres pays européens sur ce plan les
élus estiment qu'ils n'ont pas eu
vraiment de réponse de la part du
gouvernement il donc revenir à la charge
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle puisque
là aussi savoir les sénateurs c'est quel
plan compte mettre en place le
gouvernement pour accélérer la
vaccination sur le terrain quel sera le
calendrier à moyen long terme ce matin
on le sait les premières vaccinations
ont débuté pour les plus de 75 ans ça
s'est passé à Nancy un départ qui a donc
été anticipé par rapport à la campagne
nationale la campagne nationale qui doit
donc débuter demain et débutera
notamment avec ce déplacement de Jean
Castex cette visite de Jean Castex dans
la ville de Metz sur ce thème des
questions à suivre côté communiste côté
socialiste et républicain la séance est
ouverte on se retrouve juste après
serveur
je n'envoie pas de procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
au nom du Sénat je tiens à vous adresser
mes vœux monsieur le Premier ministre à
vous-même et ainsi qu'à tous les membres
du gouvernement
je veux également dresser mes vœux
personnels à tous mes collègues c'est la
triste et sénateurs et à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs qui font la vie
quotidienne du Sénat
je formule des vœux pour notre pays et
pour tous nos compatriotes notamment
pour que nous puissions ensemble
traverser et surmonter la crise
sanitaire qui impose souffrances
sacrifice est nécessaire discipline à
nos concitoyens notre vocation est de
contribuer collectivement à surmonter
cette crise
tout en préservant les exigences de la
démocratie que nous incarnons avec nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale et de
la démocratie parlementaire je vous
souhaite la meilleure année qui soit
dans les circonstances difficiles qui
sont aujourd'hui
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
chacun sera attentif à observer des
valeurs essentielles ici le respect des
uns et des autres et une valeur tout
simplement collective qui est aussi le
respect du temps de parole et vous
n'oublierez pas les réflexes pour la
protection sanitaire nous rentrons et
nous sortons pour les sénateurs par le
haut de l'hémicycle pour les membres du
gouvernement sur le devant en étant
attentif à l'ensemble des gestes
je donne maintenant la parole à Madame
Laurence Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste et
pour deux minutes merci monsieur le
président
les Françaises et les Français sont
inquiets et doutent de la capacité de
l'État à mettre en œuvre une stratégie
vaccinale à la hauteur des défis compte
tenues des retards prix pourtant la mise
sur le marché de plusieurs vaccins pour
combattre les formes les plus graves de
la covid-19 est une excellente nouvelle
et ranime l'espoir tout comme le
traitement annoncé par l'Institut
Pasteur de Lille qui pourrait être prêt
en février la formidable performance des
chercheuses et chercheurs aux quatre
coins de la planète pour contrer ce
coronavirus ce sont malheureusement
accompagnés d'une course effrénée des
grands laboratoires pour obtenir le
jackpot au lieu de jouer la coopération
votre collègue Agnès panier rue naché a
annoncé et il était temps la mise à
contribution de trois sites en France
pour concourir à l'effort de production
des vaccins monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous contraindre le laboratoire
Sanofi a participé à cet effort
collectif en mettant ses chaînes de
séduction à disposition et arrêtez sa
politique de suppression d'emplois
notamment dans les domaines de la
recherche et du développement quant
allez-vous recourir à la licence
d'office pour produire des vaccins à
prix coûtant et lever les brevets pour
mettre les vaccins dans le domaine
public
pour vous répondre je donne la parole à
Madame
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Cohen vous mettez en exergue
les folles espoirs couvrent
effectivement l'arrivée et la mise sur
le marché d'un certain nombre de vaccins
de vaccins qui ont plus le mérite d'être
particulièrement efficace puisque nous
avons des taux annoncé au-delà de 90% ce
qui je parle sous le contrôle d'Olivier
Véran ministre de la Santé et médecin
relèvent de de plus haut niveau que l'on
peut atteindre d'un vaccin ces vaccins
ils sont aujourd'hui très réservés des
doses ont été préservées depuis 7 mois
plus que nous avons commencé à
travailler sur le sujet dès le mois
d'avril et avec la Commission européenne
avec l'appui des grands pays de l'Union
européenne nous avons négocié six
contrats avec des réservations qui
permettent lorsque les vaccins
arriveront en mise sur le marché d'avoir
accès directement à ces vaccins nous
avons également et c'est un travail qui
a été entamé dès le adjoint avec le
lancement d'un appel à projet capacity
building fait en sorte de produire sur
le territoire français et de produire en
Europe c'était un des éléments très
importants de la négociation avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques de
s'assurer qu'en mettant nos forces en
commun on pouvait produire en Europe
nous sélectionnons avec les laboratoires
les sites les plus productifs les plus
capacitaires il ne s'agit pas de faire
du transfert technologique sur une
dizaine de petits sites car ça
consommerait beaucoup de force
scientifiques beaucoup de force
industrielles et aujourd'hui c'est
l'efficacité qui nous conduit et le fait
de produire pour les Européens et c'est
ce que nous sommes parvenus à faire je
rappelle que nous avons 600 millions de
doses désormais très réservés avec
Pfizer qui seront livrés cette année ce
qui veut dire pour l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne ce que veut dire que nous
avons l'appui industriel derrière et
vous avez cité les trois sites
s'agissant de Sanofi bien entendu le
travail sur le sujet mais
l'industrialisation d'un vaccin ça ne se
fait pas en claquant dans les doigts ça
dépend des sites ça dépend des
technologies et c'est sur ce travail
qu'ils sont partis je rappelle également
qu'ils ont ils investissent 600 millions
d'euros dans une usine de vaccins à
horizon 2 ans nous anticipons et je veux
saluer ce travail de Sanofi pour
accompagner la montée en puissance de la
vaccination
à ma connaissance à nos filles n’est pas
un petit laboratoire il est sur le
territoire du Val-de-Marne et je peux
vous dire que il y a des sites de
production il y a le savoir-faire il y a
les salariés et les chercheurs il faut
que sanofie effectivement contribue et
arrête de licencier ça c'est la première
chose vous avez refusé notre proposition
de loi d'un pôle public du médicament et
de la Recherche madame la ministre et
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas trop
tard il faut vous ressaisir il faut
écouter la voix de celles et ceux qui se
retrouvent à nos côtés dans la campagne
européenne de pétition pas de profit sur
la pandémie nous appelons à la
reconquête de la maîtrise publique de la
production et de la diffusion des
médicaments et des vaccins nous
demandons la levée du secret des
affaires pour une totale transparence
des contrats signés avec Big Pharma nous
exigeons que les vaccins et les
traitements contre la pandémie soit un
bien public mondial librement accessible
à toutes et à tous je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Patricia Sillinger pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole merci
[Musique]
monsieur alors que la crise sanitaire
que nous vivons frappe notre pays la
situation de chaque commune chaque
département chaque région demeure unique
cette pluralité des situations ne se
cantonne pas au cas des pandémies nous
le savons tous ici une même mesure prise
à l'échelle nationale n'obtient pas les
mêmes résultats sur tout le territoire
même si il est difficile de le prouver
et de le quantifier ce manque de
visibilité ne permet pas de répondre
efficacement aux besoins de transparence
des citoyens restaurer la confiance dans
l'État et les politiques publiques qu'il
mènent est essentielles celle-ci
nécessite un pédite un pilotage efficace
et une grande transparence cette
évaluation se doit également d'être
transparente clé de voûte d'une
démocratie qui fonctionne apporter les
informations citoyens de manière
objective et compréhensible et cruciale
il nous le demande et nous leur devons
monsieur le ministre dans le
prolongement de la promesse du président
de la République d'instruire son action
et avec elle celle de l'État sous le
signe de la transparence vous avez
présenté aujourd'hui un compte en
conseil des ministres un nouvel outil le
baromètre de l'action publique pour y
pourriez-vous nous indiquer comment
cette outil répond d'une part de
l'exigence d'efficacité et déficience
des politiques publiques et d'autres
parts comment contribue-t-il à la
promesse de transparence portée par le
chef de l'État
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la relation
avec le Parlement monsieur marcenot vous
avez la parole et merci Monsieur le
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Patricia Schillinger
je vois d'abord excuser Amélie de mon
Chalin qui n'a pas pu encore nous
rejoindre depuis trois ans dans cette
hémicycle depuis plus de 3 ans vous avez
débattu et adopté de nombreuses lois
l'enjeu de la mission qui a confié le
président de la République sous
l'autorité du Premier ministre Amélie de
mon chien de faire en sorte que ses lois
voté que nos réformes prioritaires
trouvent une traduction concrète et vous
l'avez évoqué dans le quotidien des
Français cette transformation de
l'action publique que nous menons depuis
2017 et plus que jamais une priorité une
priorité que la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons depuis maintenant presque une
année ne remet pas en cause bien au
contraire le baromètre des résultats de
l'action publique présentait ce matin
par la ministre lors du séminaire
gouvernantal et qui est désormais
accessible à tous sur le site du
gouvernement en témoigne de manière
tangible l'indicateur à l'appui cet
outil donnera avoir aux Français les
résultats concrets de 25 réformes
prioritaires menées par le gouvernement
sur la base d'indicateurs chiffrés
dans 8 domaines essentiels du quotidien
tel que la transition écologique le
travail le développement de
l'apprentissage ou encore le domaine de
la santé pour nous citer que ces
exemples les résultats précis qui
figurent seront accessibles départements
par département et toutes les données
seront disponibles en Open Data et
actualiser tous les trimestres afin d'en
mesurer l'évolution le baromètre
permettra à tous les acteurs en premier
lieu à vous parlementaires de savoir
concrètement ce qui avance chez vous
mais aussi ce qui parfois avancent moins
vite et donc ce sur quoi nous devons
accélérer ou évoluer cet outil
contribuera à renforcer la confiance de
nos concitoyens à voir nos pouvoirs
publics qui permettra aussi d'accélérer
la transformation concrète de l'action
publique au service des territoires et
des citoyens je vous remercie merci
Madame Sillinger
je vous remercie pour cette réponse et
j'espère que les territoires se
saisiront de cet outil et puis aussi on
aura la possibilité d'avoir les
conséquences par rapport à ces actions
merci
en seulement mes collègues nombreux dans
les tribunes du public et dans la
tribune d'honneur je voudrais donner
maintenant la parole au président
Patrick canaire pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
l'épidémie qui nous frappe si durement
depuis presque un an aujourd'hui nous
impose humilité et responsabilité
l'humilité devant un virus évolutif qui
nous oblige à nous adapter en permanence
la responsabilité pour soutenir les
politiques sanitaires tant qu'elles nous
sont présentées sur la base
d'information objectives même quand
elles sont dures pour nos concitoyens
c'est donc en responsabilité que nous
devons envisager à la campagne vaccinale
qui est notre principal espoir pour
maîtriser cette épidémie
dès le mois de novembre ici même nous
appelions le gouvernement à mettre en
place rapidement un plan clair net et
précis de vaccination ce n'était pas de
la polémique mais un appel à la prise en
compte une urgence absolue par
l'exécutif dans l'esprit des conclusions
du Conseil Scientifique rendu le 9
juillet 2020
nous affirmons que vous étiez dans
l'action alors que quelques semaines
plus tard vous n'avez été que dans la
réaction
c'est le dos au mur que vous avez réagi
après que la polémique a justement été
déclenchée par le Président de la
République lui-même
ce retard a un coût économique social et
humain conséquent ce manque
d'anticipation associé à une stratégie
assumée de la lenteur à laquelle vous
avez heureusement renoncé doit s'effacer
au profit d'une mobilisation générale
qui tarde à venir il faut associer plus
étroitement les élus locaux et faire
confiance à l'intelligence des
territoires plutôt que des cabinets de
consultants privés les centres de
vaccination devraient être en place ils
sont encore en déploiement le calendrier
vaccinal de votre arrêté il comporte
encore des incohérences une campagne de
communication devrait être lancée elle
n'est pas à l'état de projet je ne mets
pas en doute votre bonne volonté
monsieur le Premier ministre je
m'inquiète de l'efficacité de vos choix
mais j'aimerais une liste comment
allez-vous rattraper votre manque
d'anticipation pour gagner la course
contre la montre qui s'est engagée face
aux différentes mutations du virus
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Premier ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick Tanner permettez-moi
d'abord monsieur le Président de
répondre bien volontiers au vœu de bonne
heureuse année que vous avez bien voulu
présenter au Gouvernement de la
République dans cette année si
importantes et si particulière je
voudrais à mon tour monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs vous
adressez à mon nom personnel au nom du
gouvernement tous nos vœux tous nos vœux
pour la Haute Assemblée tous nos vœux
pour la France dans une période
effectivement et depuis plusieurs mois
extrêmement compliqué
monsieur le Président Kader je vous
remercie de votre question sur la
stratégie vaccinale et plus généralement
après celle de Madame là sénatrice Cohen
sur la stratégie
que nous employons depuis plusieurs mois
pour faire face à cette pandémie je
voudrais d'abord
élargir mon propos
en me remettant à la question précédente
sur ce sujet
la France Mesdames et Messieurs les
acteurs et il faut s'en réjouir la
France n'a pas à rougir de sa stratégie
globale de lutte contre cette pandémie
elle n'a pas oui oui oui oui oui oui
madame la sénatrice Cohen comment ce
comme souvent c'est un disque après la
stratégie des tests voici venu les
chèques la stratégie de vaccination
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs où
est la stratégie des tests s'il vous
plaît oui la stratégie des tests
monsieur le Président faites une enquête
comparative avec tous les autres États
européens nous y sommes prêts non qu'il
n'y ait eu non qu'il n'y a eu des
difficultés comme il y en a eu partout
mais la vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
France est parmi les pays d'Europe ceux
qui testent le plus et le mieux nous
avons nous avons des résultats pour 84%
des tests à moins de 24 heures
et quand on résultat de notre politique
contre laquelle le Sénat avait voté
lorsque je vous avais sollicité pour le
deuxième confinement dois-je vous
rappeler vous avez tout à fait raison
chers présidents avec beaucoup
d'humilité mais avec assurance que nous
avons aujourd'hui les taux d'incidence
parmi les plus bas d'Europe les taux de
positivité des tests qui est sans doute
un indice meilleur parmi les moins
élevés d'Europe ce sont des faits nous
avons confiné certes sans l'accord du
Sénat avant les autres et nous en avons
tiré bénéfice tout en préservant Noël
tout en préservant l'activité au mois de
décembre car là aussi car là aussi quand
les chiffres de l'activité économique du
dernier trimestre seront connus vous
verrez vous verrez mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs que nous n'avons pas je ne
vous demande pas de cesser de critiquer
et de contre le gouvernement c'est votre
rôle je demande simplement que nous nous
autoflageions pas
c'est de la Franc non non c'est pas
d'auto satisfaction monsieur c'est non
ce sont des faits c'est pas moi c'est
pas moi ce sont les Françaises et les
Français qui ont fait les efforts
nécessaires comme on l'avait demandé
entre noël et jour de là quand ils sont
largement responsables donc tout ne va
pas bien sûrement vous me direz
d'ailleurs dans quel pays tout va bien
vous voudrez bien les indiquer et nous
nous y rendrons
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que nous
menons une action déterminée contre
cette crise sanitaire c'est vrai que les
drames sont considérables les dégâts
tout autant mais à un moment donné quel
mot le jeu je suis ici dans la chambre
de la sérénité
même réponse monsieur le Président kaner
s'agissant de la vaccination la
stratégie vaccinale vous arrêtez
présenté dans cette émission je suis
désolé et tant qu'à contact je n'ai plus
venir moi-même et j'étais
avantageusement représenté par Monsieur
le Misa santé cette stratégie vaccinale
stratégie vaccinale
n'a pas changé
soyons fiers oui de tous les personnels
quels qu'ils soient
cette stratégie vaccinale on a commencé
par le plus difficile les personnels
dans les EHPAD et les USL des vous
connaissez toutes et tous ici je sais
qui sont les sénateurs et leurs
expériences locales et vous savez très
bien que pour les résidents
des EHPAD des USLD pour recueillir leur
consentement il faut prendre des
précautions il faut prendre des
précautions ne cherchez pas à juger
notre stratégie vaccinale qui va prendre
plusieurs mois et vous le savez mesdames
et messieurs sénateurs vous le savez en
France comme ailleurs on ne juge pas un
match qui va durer 90 minutes à la
deuxième seconde ça n'est pas possible
ça n'est pas possible notre stratégie
vaccinale elle va se déployer elle monte
en charge 8 présidents canin elle fait
appel au territoire simplement vous en
connaissez les contraintes on a des
délais de livraison correspondant aux
commandes
et on a des vaccins qui ne peuvent pas
comme je le souhaiterais moi-même comme
vous l'avez souhaité être déployé dans
les pharmacies par tous les
professionnels de santé contenu de leurs
conditions notamment de conservation
donc je vous le dis les choses se font
dans l'ordre sur tous les territoires en
impliquant les acteurs locaux
l'enjeu derrière ça l'enjeu derrière ça
et vous le savez parce que là c'est une
spécificité de la France là il pardonne
pour cette réponse longue monsieur le
Président l'enjeu derrière ça c'est de
susciter
l'adhésion d'un maximum de nos
concitoyens parce que ça n'est pas
acquis et je constate monsieur le
Président que c'est adhésion semaine
après semaine semaine après semaine
s'accroît et c'est à mieux nous allons
conformément notre calendrier que nous
avons anticipé effectivement la demande
du Président de la République ouvrir
cette vaccination à partir de lundi aux
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans
l'honnêteté commande de vous dire que
cette vaccination prendra plusieurs
semaines ils sont plusieurs millions
cinq exactement ça ne se fera pas en
huit jours
et donc ce ne sera pas la peine de nous
interpeller en disant comment la
première semaine vous n'avez pas vacciné
5 millions de personnes il faut dire la
vérité j'ai toujours dit la vérité y
compris quand il s'agit de prendre des
mesures difficiles que vous n'avez pas
approuvé je vous remercie monsieur le
président
vous avez quelques secondes et de la TVA
puisque le Premier ministre a pris le
temps de la réponse à quel taux monsieur
le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ce que je
vous demande c'est de l'anticipation des
vaccins stockés et non injectés c'est du
reconfinement assuré avec son drame de
problèmes sociaux et de problèmes
économiques je le dis très simplement
vous avez dit je vous cite le 9 janvier
à Tarbes une politique sanitaire et vous
avez raison une politique sanitaire
c'est une politique d'État monsieur
Premier ministre votre responsabilité
est immense devant les Français merci
monsieur le président
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
André Guillaume pour le grau du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
la question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé Olivier Véran pour
calmer le jeu une série d'études
diligentées par l'Association des maires
de France à partir des données publiques
dont certains nems de votre ministère
dressent la liste suivante que
l'espérance de vie des habitants en
milieu rural seraient de deux ans
inférieur à celle d'un citadin
parallèlement on constate que la
probabilité d'accéder au Service
hospitaliers de soins et de 20 moyens
inférieurs de 20% inférieur chez les
habitants de nos campagnes par rapport
aux habitants des villes faute de
diagnostic précoce du probablement au
manque de médecin généraliste si nous
connaissons les différences de
traitement entre ces deux types
d'habitats nous y sommes encore plus
sensibles lorsqu'il s'agit de la santé
de nos concitoyens
aussi nous vous invitons monsieur le
ministre à mieux intégrer les
associations d'élus d'aller différentes
instances de santé car nous connaissons
les difficultés du moment et les
dispositions prises par le gouvernement
dans ce domaine je pense notamment à la
réponse concrète des partiels qui vise à
augmenter le numerus clausus des
médecins mais dont on connaîtra les
mesures que dans 10 ans
intervient également dans ces
difficultés la nouvelle génération la
nouvelle organisation de travail que
souhaite légitimement exercer les jeunes
médecins mais qui affectent leur
disponibilité et enfin la création des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
mais dont le développement est plombé si
j'ose dire par l'obligation de disposer
de deux médecins pour envisager leur
ouverture mais question de se le
ministre est donc en attendant que ce
système Palisse cette carence de
couverture médicale constatée pourquoi
ne pas suspendre un temps avec le
concours des infirmières des infirmiers
cette obligation des deux médecins une
mesure qui pourrait être envisagée comme
provisoire globalement pas onéreuse et
qui apporterait une réponse concrète et
rapide à nos difficultés dans un secteur
des plus sensibles que nous connaissons
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est communiste des solidarités de
santé Monsieur Olivier Véro vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur André Guillaume merci pour
votre question vous avez raison de
souligner que parmi les indicateurs
parmi les facteurs qui peuvent expliquer
que l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
dans les territoires ruraux soit plus
faibles que dans les grandes villes et
bien il y a sans doute le problème
d'accès aux soignants et aux médecins
c'est un vieux problème et quand on
reprend des cartographies françaises il
y a des siècles il y a toujours eu des
divergences de répartition sur le
territoire mais aujourd'hui plus qu'il y
a cette situation est inacceptable vous
avez dit monsieur le sénateur que le
numerus closif avait été augmenté mais
que ça prendrait 10 ans pour former plus
de médecins en réalité nous l'avons
supprimé le numérique clausus mais vous
avez raison de souligner que ça prendra
du temps pour être effectif et pendant
des années des décennies nous avons
empêché déjà de médecins d'apprendre la
médecine en France c'était une
aberration mais rassurez-vous
l'augmentation avait déjà commencé avant
la suppression du numérique clausus nous
étions 3500 dans ma promo de deuxième
année de médecine en 98 il y a cette
année 10000 jeunes médecins en formation
donc ça viendra mais il faut tenir il
est des solutions qui existent la
télémédecine depuis la crise sanitaire
nous réalisons un million de télécons
par semaine contre 10000
téléconsultation par semaine avant la
crise il y a toutes les organisations
collectives les CPTs je crois beaucoup
au CPTs et les élus que je vois sur les
territoires me disent qu'ils en sont
satisfaits mais également l'exercice
regroupés dans ce qu'on appelle les
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaire
monsieur sénateur c'est vrai que la
règle veut qu'il y ait au moins deux
médecins dans une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire parce qu'il faut
pouvoir la stabiliser dans la durée et
que c'est trop fragile s'il y a un seul
médecin parce que si le médecin s'en va
les autres soignants se retrouvent sur
la touche toutefois la maison de santé
peut être créée même s'il n'y a qu'un
seul médecin les financements qui
accompagnent la création du poste
d'assistant médical pour accompagner les
soignants dans leur tâches
administratives ce financement là il est
corrélé au fait qu'il y ait des médecins
mais je prends votre point monsieur le
sénateur est prochainement je publierai
une ordonnance qui donnera du délai dans
les maisons de santé pour que s'il y a
un médecin et des soignants paramédicaux
ils puissent prendre un peu de temps
pour recruter un nouveau médecin et déjà
s'engager dans la voie de l'exercice
collectif je pense que c'est déjà une
bonne façon de répondre aux problèmes
que vous soulevez et nous continuerons
développer toutes ces offres de soins
regroupés dans les territoires ruraux
périruraux et urbain
monsieur Guillaume vous avez quelques
secondes
[Musique]
une fois n'est pas coutume la réponse me
satisfait
la parole à notre collègue Monique de
Marco pour le groupe écologie solidarité
et territoire merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues une étudiante de ma
circonscription en Gironde Léa m'a écrit
ceci je suis un moment clé de ma vie où
je dois faire des choix importants pour
mon avenir mais aujourd'hui il m'est
impossible de me projeter et personne
n'est là pour m'aider je suis seul
derrière un écran sans vie depuis des
mois je me sens lâchement abandonné par
mes aînés
madame la ministre un tiers des
étudiants montre aujourd'hui des signes
d'anxiété de dépression leur condition
de vie et d'études sont fortement
dégradées c'est surtout l'isolement
prolongé avait des cours uniquement
distanciel et une vie sociale réduite à
peau de chagrin qui risque d'avoir des
conséquences dramatiques
la réouverture des universités étaient
envisagées pour la rentrée de janvier
mais elle n'a finalement pas eu lieu les
consignes sont données tardivement avec
un manque criant de concertation les
étudiants et les enseignants se sentent
oubliés déconsidérés je dirais même
sacrifier
ne pouvons-nous pas faire preuve
d'imagination
d'intelligence collective ne serait-il
pas possible par exemple de proposer une
partie des cours en présentiel avec déjà
adaptés selon la taille des salles pour
rendre l'isolement de nos jeunes et leur
donner espoir dans la venue
il nous semble urgent de recruter
davantage de psychologues et de proposer
un chèque centre c'est aux étudiants
de répondre aussi à la précarité par
exemple par un moratoire sur les loyers
dans les résidences universitaires un
renforcement des aides des recrutements
dans 6 centres sociales il est aussi
plus que temps d'élargir le RSA au moins
de 25 ans qui en sont injustement exclu
en incluant les étudiants pour ne pas
laisser tomber nos jeunes face à la
crise
au-delà de la concertation annoncée pour
ce vendredi quelle mesure concrètes
envisagez-vous de pour faire face à la
détresse des étudiants et atténuer leur
isolement je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole de Thomas la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et d'innovation dans Frédéric
Vidal vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice vous avez raison nous nous
préoccupons chaque jour l'ensemble du
gouvernement parce que c'est très
interministériel parce que ça concerne
le futur emploi des jeunes parce que ça
concerne l'apprentissage parce que ça
concerne l'orientation pour l'accès dans
l'enseignement supérieur nous nous
préoccupons tous de l'avenir de notre
jeunesse et des étudiants vous étiez au
mois d'octobre dernier avec moi sur le
campus du CROUS à Pessac alors oui vous
avez vu comme moi la détresse de
certains étudiants vous avez vu aussi je
pense l'engagement exceptionnel des
personnels des CROUS des personnels des
services de santé des étudiants
eux-mêmes à côté des étudiants qui les
aident et qui les accompagnent et c'est
tout cela que mon ministère soutient
alors oui les cours sont en train de
reprendre progressivement dans les
établissements oui toute cette
progression est co-construite nous avons
dès le début du mois de décembre
commence à travailler pour une reprise
très progressive au mois de janvier et
puis ce vendredi nous allons continuer à
travailler pour augmenter le nombre
d'étudiants qui pourront bénéficier de
cette reprise parce que l'enseignement
bien sûr c'est avant tout une relation
humaine qui se noue entre un professeur
et ses étudiants et puis il vous
demandez plus de psychologue le Premier
ministre a annoncé le doublement des
psychologues dans les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et puis des
assistantes sociales les CROUS sont en
train d'en recruter 60 et puis les
étudiants ont perdu leur petit job et
bien nous en avons créé 22 000 dans les
universités nous allons continuer à
créer des emplois étudiants à chacune
des questions inédites que soulève cette
crise inédite comme aux questions qui se
posent depuis très longtemps sur la
précarité des étudiants et bien nous
essayons d'apporter des réponses
pragmatiques concrètes qui donne une
vraie solution et qui donne un vrai
souffle d'air à nos étudiants et une
fois de plus je remercie l'ensemble des
étudiants et l'ensemble des personnels
qui vivent cette crise du mieux possible
dans ce contexte très compliqué je vous
remercie merci la parole est à notre
collègue Danny wattleblade pour le
groupe Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoires
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
1246 pages dans la langue de Shakespeare
un 24 décembre ce brexit est décidément
le miracle de Noël que l'on espérait
plus encore une fois je tiens à saluer
le travail hors pair du négociateur
européen Michel Bernier et de toute son
équipe
47 ans de vie commune 4 ans et demi
d'instance de divorce et une pension
alimentaire dont nous que sont pas
encore le montant de nombreux intérêts
européens et britanniques sont
interdépendants nous devons assurer leur
convergence il va falloir appliquer cet
accord l'interpréter et faire avec les
possibilités les limites qu'il contient
monsieur le ministre pour le concitoyen
nos territoires cet accord laisse de
nombreuses questions en suspens
dans les hauts de France on s'interroge
sur ce qui se passera à la fin de la
période de transition prévue en juin
2026 dans le secteur de la pêche de
nombreux euros députés qui ont commencé
lundi d'examen de ce texte partage ce
questionnement
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
êtes attentif au crainte de nos pécheurs
comment envisagez-vous les effets à
court terme sur la pêche française elle
est perspective post 2026
malgré l'application provisoire de la
corde des pénuries dans les rayons sont
constatés je ne parle pas de ceux de
marques et Spencer en France mais de
ceux des supermarchés britanniques si
les rayons sont vides c'est bien que nos
produits n'ont pu être livrés
anticipez-vous des difficultés dans le
secteur des transports et pour nos
agriculteurs qui fournissent adhérents
et périssables à nos voisins
d'outre-manches enfin
je m'arrêterai sur un dernier point le
protocole d'accord des services
financiers promis pour mars 2021
quels sont monsieur le ministre les
étapes suivantes il apparaît en tout cas
à ces certains que notre négocier
négociation au Royaume-Uni et encore
bien loin d'être HV
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Europe et les affaires à
l'étrangères Monsieur Le Drian tu avais
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur à tablette vous avez raison de
te souligner que cet accord est
finalement un bon accord
il était
pas attendu à la fin de la négociations
qui ont été extrêmement difficiles et
vous avez à propos de cet accord posé
plusieurs questions auxquelles je vais
répondre brièvement d'abord concernant
la pêche puisque c'est un souci
important et que on ne considérait pas
antérieurement qu'on allait pouvoir
trouver un accord sur la pêche parce que
le Royaume-Uni considérait que la pêche
était le symbole même de sa souveraineté
retrouvée or sur la pêche vous
connaissez l'accord et le fait que nous
avons pu à la fois préserver l'accès aux
eaux britanniques mais aussi ne diminuer
la les quotas que de 25% à horizon juin
2026 je vais y revenir alors que
l'exigence britannique était de 80%. et
donc nous avons pu obtenir cela dans une
négociation qui je crois a été bien
menée et approuvé par l'ensemble des 27
c'est un acquis majeur il reste encore
quelques points à régler technique sur
l'accès au 6-12000 sur les îles
Anglo-Normandes il restera aussi à
négocier annuellement les TACs sur la
base de l'existence et il restera
appréhender la meilleure manière
l'horizon de juin 2026 mais nous avons
toute une série de d'outils pour
éventuellement prendre des mesures de
sauvegarde des mesures de rétorsion des
mesures de compensation si d'aventure
dans la négociation de l'accès aux eaux
britanniques nous étions en difficulté
d'autant plus que au même moment comme
vous le savez monsieur le sénateur se
négociera entre l'Union européenne et le
Royaume-Uni les accords sur l'énergie
donc avec deux leviers on sera je pense
en situation en juin 2026 de faire
valoir nos avantages et d'avoir la
garantie du maintien de ce qu'on appelle
la stabilité relative dans l'accès aux
eaux en ce qui concerne les en
particulier les services financiers la
simulation est très simple l'Union a
pleinement conservé sa capacité à
délivrer unilatéralement et au cas par
cas et en fonction de ses propres
intérêts les équivalences financières
lorsqu'elles seront demandées enfin
dernière observation parmi beaucoup
d'autres qu'il faudrait faire sur les
difficultés
mécaniques de la mise en place de
l'accord au terme d'alimentation et
d'approvisionnement d'un certain nombre
de surfaces britanniques ou de commerce
britannique il y a inévitablement les
difficultés de la corne et on savait on
avait dit au Britannique ce serait pas
positif pour eux et puis il y a aussi
pour revenir sur un autre débat la
situation sanitaire catastrophique
malheureusement catastrophique dont il
faudrait mesdames et messieurs
dessinateurs que vous vous informiez
avant de faire des comparaisons avec la
France pour conclure aussi Monsieur le
Ministre situation catastrophique qui
explique en grande partie les
difficultés que vous évoquez merci la
parole est à notre collègue Fabien Genet
pour le groupe les républicains
avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la Santé monsieur le
ministre face aux malades du covid et à
leurs familles parfois endeuillées face
à l'isolement à la peur et à l'attention
psychologique qu'impose la crise à nos
concitoyens face à la menace du variant
anglais et du risque de reconfinement
nous ne sommes pas du mal à polémiquer
mais nous parlementaires nous ne sommes
pas tirés au sort de façon anonyme et
irresponsable
nous rendons des comptes à nos
concitoyens nous relayons leur légitimes
interrogations or à vous entendre
monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
ministre tout va toujours très bien tout
va très bien avec les vaccins tout va
très bien avec les aiguilles tout va
très bien avec la stratégie mais si tout
va si bien pourquoi alors actuelle 20%
des Français ne sont-ils pas vaccinés
comme en Israël pourquoi 2 millions de
Français ne sont pas vaccinés comme au
Royaume-Uni ou au minimum 500 000 comme
en Allemagne peut-être parce que vous
avez choisi un rythme de promenade en
famille et que cette lenteur un
justifiée de votre campagne de
vaccination mais à la hauteur ni du
moment ni des Français telle est la vie
plein de colère du président de la
République heureusement le dévouement
s'en borne de tous les professionnels de
santé l'engagement des préfets des élus
locaux offre désormais un espoir sur le
terrain que j'ai pu mesurer dans ma
commune de Digoin en préparant
l'ouverture du centre de
néanmoins des inquiétudes persistent sur
leur rythme de cette campagne et en
particulier dans la ruralité pourquoi
par exemple tous les professionnels de
santé peuvent participer à la campagne
vaccinale sauf les pharmaciens pourquoi
ne pas les autoriser à venir renforcer
les équipes au sein même des centres de
vaccination pourquoi ne pas vacciner
sans attendre la totalité des personnels
des ehpads pour faire barrage au virus
pourquoi ne pas rendre obligatoire la
vaccination anticoïdes pour ces
personnels d'epad à l'instar du vaccin
contre l'hépatite B obligatoire pour les
personnels de santé plus largement au
lieu de chercher à convaincre les
incertains commençons déjà par vacciner
les volontaires car ils sont monsieur le
ministre très nombreux et très impatient
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre des Solidarités de la Santé
vous avez la parole
monsieur le sénateur jeûner d'abord vous
ne m'entendrez jamais dire que tout va
bien je crois pas l'avoir dit j'aimerais
bien pouvoir le dire un jour dans cette
hémicycle ou dans un autre ce serait une
formidable nouvelle ça veut dire que je
n'aurais pas à faire le décompte
quotidien de 300 morts 200 réanimation
1500 patients admis à l'hôpital et
quelques 20.000 contaminations je crois
qu'on peut être d'accord sur ce point
monsieur le sénateur et personne ne dit
les difficultés de mise en place d'une
logistique absolument immense dans notre
pays d'ailleurs avec des difficultés qui
traversent tous les pays vous savez
certains pays ont mis en place des
vaccinations dans certains grands
centres de vaccination qu'on appelle les
vaccinodrome je prends l'exemple de
l'Allemagne si vous lisez la presse
allemande vous verrez que la presse et
les élus là-bas d'opposition sont pas
plus tendres avec leur gouvernement que
vous ne l'êtes avec nous puisque là-bas
les gens peuvent faire trois heures ou 4
heures de queue dehors quand c'est pas
6h d'attente au téléphone et que
certains centres sont dépourvus de
vaccin bref personne n'est parfait
monsieur le sénateur personne niveau ni
nous mais nous essayons tous de nous
améliorer et en l'occurrence ce n'est
pas le ministre qui vaccinent ce sont
les milliers les dizaines de milliers de
soignants qui sont organisés dans les
hôpitaux publics dans les cliniques dans
les centres de vaccination à destination
des soignants dans les EHPAD et demain à
destination des personnes âgées de 75
ans et plus et c'est ces personnes-là
qu'on peut saluer parce qu'elles font un
gros travail et que elles ont commencé
dans des conditions pas évidentes et
qu'elles montent et qu'elle développe il
y a eu plus de 50 000 personnes
vaccinées dans notre pays on est sur un
rythme qui n'a rien à envier je peux
vous le dire à nos voisins et ce rythme
continuera de s'accroître
progressivement mesure que les doses de
vaccins nous seront livrés monsieur le
sénateur posé des questions concrètes
moi je compte sur les pharmaciens je
compte sur les pharmaciens notamment
lorsque nous aurons un vaccin
d'utilisation plus simple qui ne se
conserve pas à -80 degrés et qui n'est
pas en flacon de 5 ou 10 doses et donc
les pharmaciens savent la vaccination
anti grippal vous m'avez assez interrogé
cette année d'ailleurs je note que ça se
passe plutôt très bien pour l'instant
touchant du bois du côté de la grippe et
on est capable de vacciner 5 millions de
Français une semaine on ne se passera
pas du savoir-faire et de l'engagement
des pharmaciens quant aux indications
pour les professionnels de santé de
moins de 50 ans
la Haute Autorité de santé nous demande
de ne pas le faire c'est pas qu'ils
disent vous le ferez quand vous aurez
des doses ils disent pour l'instant
c'est trop tôt on le fera après on
commence par les fragiles les
vulnérables en établissement collectif
celles et ceux qui vont réanimation
wallopal celles et ceux qui font des
formes graves pulmonaires si on ne
faisait pas vous pourriez nous le
reprocher vous auriez pour le coup
raison de le faire monsieur le sénateur
merci monsieur lui dit la Parole est
maintenant à notre collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues madame Christian s'adresse à
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
la détresse que rencontre actuellement
les étudiants face à l'isolement
provoqués par la fermeture des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
le samedi 9 janvier dernier un étudiant
de l'Université de Lyon 3 a tenté de
mettre fin à ses jours on se défait les
30 sa résidence universitaire hier soir
toujours à Lyon c'est une autre
étudiante qui a commis ce même geste
désespéré ces gestes de désespoir
doivent nous alerter sur la détresse que
rencontre des étudiants actuellement
depuis la fermeture des universités
l'immense majorité des étudiants
considère que l'enseignement s'est
dégradé les cours en distanciels sont
devenus insupportables les étudiants ne
peuvent plus ils n'acceptent plus d'être
infantilisé madame la ministre ils sont
au bord de la rupture
comme le rappelle Eric Carpano le
président de l'université Lyon 3 la
fermeture des universités les cours à
distance l'arrêt des activités sportives
culturelles et festives ont favorisé
l'isolement et la détresse psychologique
avant la crise que nous traversons c'est
l'ensemble de la vie étudiante qui est
bouleversée en plus des cours on
constate que la situation économique a
plongé les plus fragiles dans la
précarité nous sommes au bord d'un
écrouchage massif qui risque d'entraîner
de nombreux gestes de désespoir comme
celui de samedi dernier et d'hier soir
Madame la Ministre les éditeurs il est
un vrai semblable de laisser les gens
s'entasser dans les métros et
d'interdire là aux prises des cours en
amphithéâtre même avec le port du masque
il emmène la qualité de leurs études de
la reconnaissance de leur diplôme sur le
marché du travail et surtout de leur
état de santé physique et mentale ma
question est simple madame la ministre
face à l'urgence de la situation et pour
éviter une succession de drames plus
compte faire l'état pour apporter une
réponse concrète à ces étudiants en
détresse
quand vous répondre la parole dans la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche d'innovation un amidal vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président
sénateurs monsieur sellateur votre
question sur la détresse psychologique
des étudiants me permet effectivement de
dresser toutes mes pensées
aux familles aux amis aux communautés
aux camarades de ces étudiants qui
effectivement dans ces situations de
difficultés souvent multicosales et
d'ailleurs des enquêtes sont en cours à
ce sujet et bien attendre à leur journée
dans votre question je crois qu'il y a
plusieurs choses qui se mélangent
d'abord je crois qu'il faut rendre un
hommage vibrant et appuyé à l'ensemble
de la communauté des enseignants
chercheurs et des enseignants qui dans
les universités dans les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur travail
d'arrache-pied pour que justement les
cours et lieux pour que justement les
diplômes de nos jeunes ne soient pas
dévalorisés pour que justement ils
puissent être accompagné au mieux dans
cette situation très difficile
dans ce deuxième confinement nous
n'avons pas fermé les universités
monsieur le sénateur tout d'abord toutes
les salles de ressources sont restées
ouvertes sur rendez-vous de manière à ce
qu'il puisse garder les étudiants
puissent garder un minimum de contact
avec leurs établissements ensuite des
enseignements ont été autorisés ce qu'il
était impossible de mener en présentiel
enfin depuis le tout début du mois de
janvier il peut y avoir pour les plus
fragiles une reprise des enseignements
en présentiel par tout petit groupe par
groupe de 10 et ce vendredi nous allons
continuer à travailler avec les
conférences les présidents avec les
conférences des directeurs
d'établissement pouvoir comment est-ce
qu'on peut élargir cela parce que oui
les étudiants les plus fragiles sont
ceux qui entrent dans l'enseignement
supérieur cette année les étudiants en
situation de handicap les étudiants
internationaux qui se retrouvent seuls
sur notre sol et nous voyons bien qu'en
réalité ils sont très nombreux c'est
pourquoi nous allons travailler pour
faire de nouvelles propositions pour
pouvoir faire revenir les étudiants sur
le lieu d'enseignement c'est très
important pour leur avenir pédagogique
et psychologique je vous remercie
mais oui allez-y
merci madame la ministre pour les
ateliers d'action mais cela est
visiblement insuffisant les phénom le
montre les étudiants ne doivent pas être
sacrifiés et pour le moment c'est ce que
l'on peut constater il en va de l'avenir
de notre jeunesse je vous remercie
merci je vais donner la parole
maintenant à Madame Patricia demain
pour le groupe les républicain
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adressée aux secrétaire
d'État chargé du numérique pendant que
le monde entier regardez effaré
l'envahissement du Capitole un autre
événement non moins important s'est
déroulé au nez et à la barbe de la
puissance publique les contes du
président des États-Unis sur le net ont
été supprimés un premier réflexe a
conduit beaucoup de ceux qui s'indignent
des accès récurrents de Donald Trump à
se réjouir de l'attitude des gafams
cependant à y regarder de plus près
cette censure doit nous pousser à nous
interroger sur l'état des libertés
publiques et si le risque que font
désormais pesé sur la liberté
d'expression c'est multinationales les
réseaux sociaux sont devenus un élément
essentiel pour s'exprimer aussi laisser
à des entreprises le soin de censurer ou
pas sur la toile constituent une
atteinte grave à la démocratie
la démocratie n'exclut pas d'interférer
et de réguler la liberté d'expression
mais cela doit pouvoir se faire au
travers de limites définies par la
puissance publique par la loi et réguler
par les États et la justice
force et de constater aussi que nos
grandes législations sur les libertés
d'expression sont trop souvent
inopérantes dans l'espace numérique les
fake news et la haine envahissent les
réseaux et là encore ce sont les
entreprises qui décident sur simple
clics obscur ce qui doit rester ou
disparaître de quel droit une entreprise
peut-elle décider ce qu'on a ou pas le
droit de dire tout défenseur des
libertés se doit de répondre à cette
question le gouvernement a annoncé le
besoin d'inventer une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique
qu'entendez-vous donc par là
bannir une chier vous avez la parole de
la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice de ma je rejoins
complètement votre analyse c'est à dire
qu'on peut à la fois se réjouir que les
plateformes est réagit par rapport à un
certain nombre de prêts de propos mais
c'est un précédent historique à
plusieurs titres premiers précédent
historique ça met en valeur de manière
éclatante le rôle des réseaux sociaux et
des plus grandes plateformes dans nos
vies démocratiques deuxième précédent
très intéressant cette action par cette
action pour la première fois les
plateformes reconnaissent des facto
qu'elles ont une responsabilité sur le
contenu qui est posté sur leurs réseaux
sociaux et qu'elles ne sont pas dans une
position neutre très intéressante car ça
nous donne un levier pour avancer avec
elle et pour agir troisième élément
effectivement vous l'avez très bien
résumé ça pose la question de des règles
du jeu et ces règles du jeu s'agissant
de l'opinion qui serait exprimée sur un
réseau social et de la façon dont cette
opinion peut-être réfrénée interdite
pour envers enfin d'être émise vers
d'autres personnes est une question
fondamentale et c'est pour cela qu'au
niveau européen nous nous sommes emparée
du sujet et vous savez que le
gouvernement français le président de la
République ont été et Cédric a été très
proactif sur ces sujets-là au travers du
Règlement sur le digital service actes
en bon français qui prévoit notamment
des régulations et qui vient d'être
présentées et soutenu par la commissaire
#ger et le commissaire breton en fin
d'année dernière il coûtera l'objet
d'une discussion tout au long de cette
année et c'est pour ça aussi que le
gouvernement est en train d'étudier s'il
n'était pas possible d'anticiper cette
démarche au niveau français de façon à
effectuer les règles du jeu du débat
public car il appartient au législateur
de fixer les règles du jeu et à la
justice de les voir appliquer et de
contrôler leur juste application je vous
remercie
merci madame de masse
j'ai entendu vos déclarations d'intérêt
madame simplement aujourd'hui il y a une
urgence parce que la transgression sur
le monde de numérique est un problème
sociétal qui doit effectivement
rejoindre les paroles zozaces et il est
l'heure de passer aux actes
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Sylvie
Robert pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vous avez la
parole merci merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche la
situation des jeunes est singulièrement
celle des étudiants est très
préoccupantes plusieurs événements
tragiques qui ont émaillé ces dernières
semaines et tout récemment soulève
beaucoup d'inquiétudes vie sociale et
collective inexistante et notamment sur
les campus flou manifeste quand au
scénario de reprise partielle en
présentiel incompris et parfois
compliqué après des mois de Visio la
confusion et l'absence de perspective
qui règne en cette rentrée de janvier
ont généré simplifier une angoisse et un
mal-être chez nombre de jeunes qui nous
oblige à agir et prévenir en plus de la
précarité qui augmente des inégalités
qui se creusent les symptômes de
détresse psychologique deviennent
alarmant les jeunes vont d'incertitude
en désespoir de constater que leur année
universitaire se déroule de manière
aussi chaotique malgré l'investissement
des enseignants des équipes pédagogiques
et des CROUS et nous savons d'ores et
déjà que la démotivation s'ajoute à des
risques forts de décrochage
malheureusement les jeunes et notamment
les étudiants ont été les oubliés de la
conférence de presse du 7 janvier
dernier alors madame la ni ministre que
leur dites-vous aujourd'hui comment
entendez-vous répondre à cette triste
réalité et au-delà des dispositifs
annoncés quelle perspective leur
donnez-vous
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche d'un Vidal vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Robert alors le 7
janvier effectivement nous n'avons pas
parlé des étudiants puisque la mesure
avait été prise annoncée avant parce que
ils étaient prioritaires justement dans
le plan d'action du gouvernement pour
avoir dès le 4 janvier dans un nombre
cercle limité d'établissement mais
simplement parce que très peu
d'établissements ont repris le 4 janvier
la possibilité d'accueillir des
étudiants par groupe de disques j'ai
entendu la polémique sur la date de la
circulaire heureusement que dans
l'enseignement supérieur on est capable
de préparer des rentrées universitaires
sans attendre que les circulaires
paraissent le Premier ministre avait
reçu les conférences des présidents et
des établissements au début du mois de
décembre et bien sûr le ministère et
l'ensemble des établissements avaient
travaillé à cette reprise la preuve en
est dès le 4 janvier il y avait bien des
étudiants de retour dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
lorsque ceci avait
vous parlez de la difficulté d'avoir des
examens en présentiel il y a en moyenne
sur le territoire environ 20% des
examens qui se sont déroulés en
présentiel ce sont des examens pour
lesquels les équipes pédagogiques ont
estimé qu'il était essentiel que les
étudiants soient présents mais
rappelez-vous à la fin de l'année
dernière la polémique était sur les
examens à distance et bien défavorisent
un certain nombre d'étudiants qui n'ont
pas accès aux ressources numériques et
comme il est hors de question que nous
donnions des diplômes comme il est hors
de question que l'on puisse dire que les
diplômes de 2020 comme les diplômes de
2021 auront moins de valeur et bien oui
pour certains examens c'est important
que les étudiants soient physiquement
présents pour passer les épreuves enfin
effectivement nous allons accompagner le
retour des étudiants parce que nous
sommes parfaitement conscients comme je
l'ai dit que l'enseignement c'est avant
tout une question de relation humaine et
donc oui nos jeunes ont besoin de
retrouver leurs profs et les profs
d'ailleurs ont aussi besoin de retrouver
leurs étudiants je vous remercie
on a beaucoup demandé aux jeunes et
notamment aux étudiants pendant cette
crise puis la gravité de la situation il
doit effectivement y avoir des réponses
d'urgence vous l'avez dit et notamment
dans le renforcement de l'accompagnement
humain qui leur aurait peut-être fallu
d'ailleurs anticiper mais voyez ce
qu'ils attendent surtout c'est de
pouvoir se projeter c'est d'avoir des
perspectives alors oui il y a urgence à
ce que votre gouvernement puisse avoir
enfin un vrai discours à la jeunesse et
notamment aux étudiants de notre pays
aujourd'hui merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue Bruno rejoint
pour le groupe les républicains vous
avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre nos campagnes sont
de moins en moins paisibles et la
ruralité n'est pas moins touchée que les
zones urbaines par la violence sur
l'année écoulée selon les propres
chiffres de votre ministère les
violences ont augmenté de 8% dans les
zones rurales et périurbaines quand dans
le même temps elles ont diminué de 5%
dans les zones
urbaines le constat est sans appel cous
et blessures plus
10%. séquestration plus 15%
règlement de compte et homicides plus
15%. viol plus
18%. une véritable radicalisation des
comportements qui se manifestaient
auparavant le plus souvent en zone
urbaine émergent dans les zones rurales
ou semi rurales
illustration dramatique de cette
dégradation le 23 décembre dernier trois
gendarmes intervenants pour porter
secours à une femme victime de violence
conjugales se sont fait abattre dans un
petit hameau du Puy-de-Dôme département
voisin du mien je tiens ici à rendre
hommage à leur courage et à leur
dévouement votre majorité monsieur le
ministre ne peut s'exonérer de cette
nouvelle géographie de la délinquance
extrêmement inquiétante et cet échec ce
n'est pas celui de l'ancien monde c'est
aussi le vôtre monsieur le ministre vous
êtes en responsabilité et avait le
devoir d'entendre la détresse de nos
concitoyens et des élus des territoires
ruraux il y a
urgence leur n'est plus au discours ou à
10 potiques expérimentations les
Français attendent des actes concrets et
ce rapidement
monsieur le ministre voici mes questions
quelle analyse faites-vous de cette
nouvelle délinquance qui gangrène nos
territoires ruraux et que comptez-vous
faire pour la combattre
pour vous répondre dans la parole est à
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérald
Darmanin vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur je partage évidemment l'émotion
qui était la vôtre lorsque vous avez
évoqué les trois gendarmes morts pendant
ces fêtes de Noël et j'adresse j'ai
adressé bien sûr au nom de tout le
gouvernement et j'imagine le nom de la
nation les notre tristesse et demande de
tels notre notre
grande provocation devant ces
difficultés très fortes que connaissent
les policiers gendarmes ont sont morts
l'année dernière
votre lecture monsieur sénateur n'est
pas tout à fait si vous le permettez
celle du ministère de l'Intérieur
d'abord parce que zone de gendarmerie ne
veut pas dire zone rurale la gendarmerie
c'est 51% de la population française
protégée certes 95% du territoire mais
70% des gendarmes et des statistiques
que vous évoquez sont dans les zones
urbaines et les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui sont publiés
complètement le 20 janvier prochain le
montreront deuxièmement certes il y a
des augmentations très importantes de
délinquance vous l'avez dit c'est vrai
plus présent dans un gendarmerie qu'en
zone de police mais ce qui ne veut pas
dire encore une fois qu'ils agissent
totalement de la ruralité d'un côté et
de l'urbanité de l'autre et ces
augmentations elles sont celles
des textes prévus par le gouvernement
depuis qu'il est en responsabilité que
je répète avec la ministre des violences
conjugales et intra familiales une
énorme importance de ces augmentations
quelle que soit derrière les zones
une augmentation aussi des refus de
tempérés des déliroutiers 20 minutes
toutes les 20 minutes il y a en zone
gendarmerie a refus de tempérer tous les
meilleurs Enzo de police et c'est plus
de la moitié des morts en service
l'année dernière des forces du stand
intérieures sont des refus de tempérer
et puis vous l'avez dit des
séquestrations qui sont souvent liées
d'ailleurs au premier point que j'ai
évoqué par
ailleurs notre gendarmerie de très bons
chiffres et je remercie les gendarmes et
leur travail courageux moins 40% de
cambriolage qui a encore deux ans était
le fait le plus important ou des faits
attentatoires au monde agricole qui
reste important mais qui diminue pour
une grande partie du territoire national
alors bien sûr il faut continuer à
travailler vous avez raison d'évoquer
qu'en plus l'année 2020 est une année
particulière celle du confinement et du
couvre-feu pas tout à fait que c'est
statistiques puissent l'illus de manière
linéaire que ce soit aux zones urbaines
ou en zone rurale mais monsieur le
sénateur n'ayait aucun doute sur le fait
que le travail que nous faisons
notamment beaucoup d'entre vous
m'écrivent sur les zones gendarmerie et
sur les zones polices la continuité de
la lutte contre la délinquance
l'activité de l'autorité judiciaire avec
le garde des sources répondront à vos
questions j'en suis certain
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Françoise Gatel pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur je voudrais vous
parler d'une rêve partie lunaire qui
s'est tenue à la Saint-Sylvestre dans un
charmant petit village d'Ille-et-Vilaine
auront mais sans doute de grands renons
puisque plus de 2500 tofers venus de
France de Belgique d'Angleterre et
d'Espagne si son rassemblés vous le
savez une une rêve partie interdite une
rêve partie extrêmement bien organisée
puisque les entrées étaient filtrées et
payantes puisqu'il y avait des stands de
vente de stupéfiants de nourriture et
d'alcool et extrêmement bien organisé
parce que tout le monde s'est rendu dans
ce lieu c'est drève partie lunaire était
aussi à haut risque non seulement
sanitaires monsieur le ministre il nous
en avons parlé puisque les conditions
sanitaires je vous laisse imaginer
comment les choses ont pu se passer
c'était une vraie provocation mais aussi
une brève partie à Auris qu'en matière
de sécurité vous ne savez bien monsieur
le ministre puisque un véhicule de
gendarmerie a été incendié et trois
gendarmes ont été agressés monsieur le
ministre alors la critique Estée la
République difficile et je veux très
sincèrement vous remercier de la manière
dont vous avez géré ou siffler en tout
cas la fin de la partie vous avez su le
faire en concertation avec les élus
seulement monsieur monsieur le ministre
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui vous
avez bien géré la fin mais comment se
fait-il que
2500 tefeurs et peut trouver le lieu
d'une fête qui était extrêmement
organisée donc un lieu non improvisé
alors que la gendarmerie n'a pas pu
infiltrer des réseaux lui permettant de
connaître le lieu et d'anticiper car une
fois que les gens étaient là on pouvait
pas se faire sauter les parachutistes
sur un lieu de cette nature deuxième
chose deuxième chose Monsieur le
Ministre c'est l'incompréhension d'une
partie de la population qui se dit qu'un
certain nombre de Français qui sont
allés en Suisse faire du ski sont
revenus se sont vus imposés une
quarantaine et je partage ma question à
vous avec le ministre de la Santé et
comme en 2500 tefeurs vous les avez
verbalisés vous avez très bien gérer ça
comment ont-ils pu se disperser en
France et disperser le virus je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur en deux minutes
madame la sénatrice monsieur le
Président je lis devant le ministre
breton du gouvernement
permettez-moi de vous corriger c'était
pas des teufeurs mais des délinquants
qui se sont réunis ce soir là
puisque nous avons établi dans une
manifestation illégale je rappelle que
la loi de la République c'est plus de
500 personnes c'est illégal une
ouverture judiciaire d'ailleurs a été
faite par le procureur de la République
et je le remercie 2000 verbalisations
2000 verbalisation a été mise 15
arrestations 4 mise en examen il y a eu
saisi de deux tonnes et demi de matériel
et il y a eu 15 murs de sons qui ont été
effectivement saisis puisque nous avons
effectivement fait ce travail en
collaboration avec l'autorité judiciaire
cela n'a pas été avuni il est vrai
madame la sénatrice que je n'ai pas
souhaité contrairement à quelques bouts
de feu qui m'encouragé parfois sur les
réseaux sociaux à la télévision donc
voyez les parachutistes sur des gens qui
avaient entre 15 et 20 ans dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et je
salue le sang froid des gendarmes et
j'ai préféré effectivement clôturer le
site sous l'autorité du Premier ministre
afin qu'il n'y ait eu nul blessé nul
décédé je rappelle d'ailleurs
que parmi les jeunes qui étaient
présents et dans des conditions
sanitaires que vous avez respectées et
de sécurité puisque 225 d'entre eux ont
été verbalisés pour avoir consommé des
stupéfiants cela s'est fait dans des
conditions ou l'ordre républicain a été
tenu ou les personnes et les ordinateurs
sont poursuivis dans certains même ont
été incarcérés vous évoquez la question
de comment cela est-il possible d'abord
madame la sénatrice c'est une question
que le Sénat évoquera dans les lois
renseignements sur certainement les
réseaux de communication parallèle
plutôt que le téléphone et le SMS
empêche bien évidemment le ministère
d'intérieur qui ne fait qu'appliquer la
loi de la République d'intervenir et
nous devons nous poser la question de
savoir comment dans l'ordre public nous
pouvons désormais prévoir à sa zone de
manifestations de cette ampleur quand
c'est une rêve partie ça peut nous
choquer quand ce sont des actes de
rassemblement comme les Black Blocs ça
ne choque d'autant plus que je
demanderai au Parlement sous l'autorité
du Premier ministre les moyens de
pouvoir se renseigner pour activer pour
activer les forces de l'ordre des
conditions acceptables merci
[Musique]
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Laurence Muller Braun pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
et messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
la nuit du 31 décembre un accident
tragique a eu lieu à bofsheim en Alsace
un jeune homme de 25 ans a eu la tête
arrachée en manipulant un tir d'artifice
il habitait ma commune et il était avec
un groupe d'amis qui voulait s'amuser il
ne s'agissait pas de délinquants qui
tire sur les forces publiques mais de
jeunes gens qui s'inscrivent dans une
tradition festive solidement ancrée en
Alsace et qui est de plus en plus décrié
par les habitants les autorités et les
secours
j'ai été interpellé par les mères qui
malgré les interdictions font face
chaque année à des débordements à des
mutilations et qui ont quelquefois la
lourde charge d'annoncer aux parents le
drame qui les frappe
aujourd'hui nous devons admettre que les
réglementations successives n'ont pas
permis d'éviter de graves accidents pour
être efficace les interdictions doivent
impérativement être accompagnés de
sanctions réellement dissuasives c'est
ce que propose la loi de sécurité
globale pour les tirs de mortier sur les
forces de l'ordre dans l'article 30
durcit et le régime des sanctions
concernant les tirs de divertissement il
faut obliger les organisateurs
d'événements et de soirée à inscrire
l'interdiction formelle des feux
d'artifice dans tous les contrats de
location de salle et surtout les
supports des communication sauf si un
professionnel agréé et recruté pour le
faire
transgression à cette règle doit être
assimilée au régime des délits
comprenant une amende forfaitaire et une
inscription au casier judiciaire j'ai
déposerai un amendement en ce sens lors
de l'examen de la loi de la sécurité
globale au Sénat il faut stopper cette
indulgence malsaine et complice monsieur
le ministre ma question est la suivante
dans la mesure où nous n'arrivons pas à
contrôler la vente et l'achat de ces
articles pourquoi ne pas réserver
l'usage des feux de divertissement au
seul professionnel comme c'est déjà le
cas pour les mortiers pour éviter que
chacun puisse tirer de son jardin pour
vous répondre la parole est avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur avait la parole
[Applaudissements]
je partage bien sûr émotion qui vous a
fait évoquer cette jeune personne
décédée entre Noël et Nouvel An dans
votre circonscription et j'adresse
évidemment mes condoléances à ses
parents et à la commune bien évidemment
j'ai aussi quand je pense au mortier au
feu d'artifice comme vous évoquez une
pensée pour tous ces policiers gendarme
qui sont souvent attaqués attaqué comme
c'était le cas Champigny-sur-Marne à la
fin de cet été ou d'ailleurs je voudrais
dire que le travail fait par les agents
de la préfecture de police de Paris en
lien avec l'autorité judiciaire nous a
permis de confondre les personnes qui
ont été responsables malheureusement
souvent des mineurs grâce à un très gros
travail pour relever les empreintes et
pour transformer en armes par
destination certaines de ces
utilisations de mortier vous l'avez dit
la loi sécurité globale dont votre
commission des Lois a bien voulu
modifier hier soir j'en salue les les
rapporteurs à évoqué que dans son
article 30 un délit punit désormais de
six mois d'emprisonnement de 75000 euros
d'amende qui permettra d'égardes à vue
dès qu'on parutions immédiate pour
l'utilisation de ces feux d'artifice en
dehors des professionnels comme vous
l'avez évoqué et pénélisera non
seulement l'utilisation mais aussi la
vente et dans la vente il y a bien sûr
les artificiers dont je sais qu'ils vont
un travail professionnel et qui doivent
le vendre désormais et je suis tout à
fait prêt à regarder avec les
rapporteurs la possibilité d'amendement
que vous pourriez déposer des
professionnels mais aussi la vente par
Internet qui est bien l'un de nos
problèmes et que nous devons suivre avec
attention et pénaliser les vendeurs
également par Internet de ces mortiers
nous l'avons fait dans des fonctions
précédentes lorsque j'ai d'aberci sur
d'autres sujets nous y arrivons ce qui
me permet d'ailleurs de dire madame la
sénatrice dans ce texte encore une fois
en construction je l'espère avec le
Sénat et je le sais avec le Sénat vu
l'importance des questions de sécurité
que la question du protoxyde d'azote et
je salue la sénatrice Valérie léthard
aussi des rodeurs même si la loi 2018 a
quand même largement fait des avancées
pour les saisies mais qui méritent
encore sans doute des moyens
supplémentaires pour nos policiers nos
gendarmes puissent être dans le texte de
loi que nous présentons et le
gouvernement donnera la vie favorable
dans un moment du sén at si c'est le cas
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Florence blatrix comptable pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chargée de l'industrie mais chers
collègues la crise sanitaire a souligné
la défaillance de notre appareil
productif dans des secteurs cruciaux de
notre économie je pense en particulier à
la pénurie de masque de gants de
matériel pour les professionnels de
santé en début de pandémie les chiffres
de l'année 2020 sont édifiants 30 plans
licenciement par semaine en octobre près
d'un million de suppressions d'emplois
657 plans licenciement entre le 1er mars
et le 22 novembre mais le pire reste à
venir nous savons qu'avec cette crise le
mouvement de délocalisation va encore
s'accentuer avec à la clé des
suppressions massives d'emploi
nous attendons un véritable bain de sang
pour reprendre l'expression de Patrick
Artus et en audition ce matin à la
commission des affaires économiques et
pourtant des milliards d'euros de
plantes soutien ont été versées aux
entreprises sans qu'aucune contrepartie
en termes de maintien de l'emploi de
reconversion de formation
professionnelle n'ait été exigée et
pourtant un grand groupe comme Michelin
qui aurait cependant la capacité de
mieux résister pendant la crise
rationaliste sa production et ajoute
encore au malheur avec l'annonce de la
suppression en France de 2300 emplois et
pourtant un autre grand groupe général
électrique qui s'était engagé à créer un
milieu d'emplois en France
ah non en septembre dernier un plan de
restructuration menaçant près de 800
emplois et comble de cynisme son PDG
s’octroi un bonus de 47 millions de
dollars comme récompense d'une gestion
purement actionnariale et financière qui
a conduit depuis plusieurs décennies à
des dizaines de milliers de suppressions
d'emplois face à ce constat ce dont
notre pays a besoin c'est dans les
tâches qui se dotent de véritables
outils planification pour réduire nos
dépendances industrielles madame la
ministre quel est votre feuille de route
nationale et européenne pour assurer
notre souveraineté industrielle et
retrouver nos emplois et en particulier
quel est votre stratégie concernant
l'avenir des Chantiers de l'Atlantique
la parole est à Madame peignait une
hachée ministre délégué à l'Industrie
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Béatrice
comptable ou poser beaucoup de questions
vous me permettrait d'essayer de
répondre au maximum de ces questions
merci aussi d'éclairer l'enjeu de
l'industrie je comprends qu'il est très
partagé sur ses bancs et je m'en réjouis
depuis le début du quinquennat le
président de la République a fait de la
reconquête industrielle un de ces
marqueurs économiques et il était temps
car la France a détruit un million
d'emplois industriels entre 2000 et 2016
et je rappelle que nous avons recréé de
l'emploi industriel en 2017 en 2018 et
en 2019 et ses créations d'emploi ne
sont pas le fruit du hasard ils sont le
fruit de politique déterminée et de
politique efficace en matière en matière
de droit du travail en matière de
simplification administrative en matière
de libreovation pour ne citer que ces
quelques chapitres ces politiques elles
sont aujourd'hui poursuivies et
renforcées au travers du plan de relance
nous avons voulu avec le président de la
République le Premier ministre et Bruno
Le Maire faire de l'industrie une des
priorités du plan de relance et 35
milliards d'euros sur les 100 milliards
de rôles du plan de relance et ces 35
milliards d'euros qui ont des
contreparties évidemment madame la
sénatrice lorsque nous baissons les
impôts de production que fait que
faisons-nous nous facilitons
l'investissement des entreprises qui
produisent en France qui font travailler
des salariés en France et qui
investissent en France nous
n'accompagnons pas les délocalisations
car une entreprise qui délocalise ne
paye pas d'impôts de production lorsque
nous accompagnons aujourd'hui la
transformation de 800 entreprises la
modernisation la relocalisation de
production en trois mois 800 entreprises
industrielles accompagnées à hauteur de
800 millions d'euros en échange de
projets concrets avec l'obligation de
rembourser si elle ne les exécute pas
lorsque nous avons 6500 entreprises qui
vont être accompagnées pour la
numérisation de leur production nous
agissons concrètement avec les filières
20 filières industrielles l'ensemble des
entreprises industrielles et de la scène
de leur salarié et c'est comme ça que
nous défendons l'emploi industriel et
que nous en recréons je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Françoise Dumont pour le groupe
les républicains
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre des Solidarités de
la Santé monsieur le ministre dans son
désormais habituel point du jeudi soir
le Premier ministre donné jeudi dernier
une liste des départements passant à un
couvre-feu à 18H Des dimanches le Var
était alors le seul département de la
région sud qui semblait épargnés par
l'annonce de Monsieur le Premier
Ministre puis samedi nous vous
rebondissements le Var et la Drôme
devait passer en couvre-feu à 18h les
départements français entrent dans ce
couvre-feu avancé en attendant sans
doute comme chez nombre de nos voisins
européens de nouvelles mesures peut-être
plus contraignantes encore car les
mauvais chiffres sont là ceux du nombre
de contaminés bien sûr mais aussi celui
du faible nombre attendu de vaccinés un
million tout juste pour la fin du mois
15 millions de personnes parmi les plus
fragiles pour l'été alors que les
Anglais ont quant à eux pour objectif
d'atteindre les 15 millions de vaccinés
d'ici la main de mi-février
dans le Var seul 2925 12 ont été
dispensés à la date d'hier et ceci alors
que ce département compte un million
76000 habitants dans les voies qui
s'élèvent celle des élus locaux qui
s'insurgent juste titre contre votre
politique sanitaire qui ne tient par
contre de leur maintenus pour rater la
vaccination du plus grand nombre de plus
vous les laissez dans le flou au regard
des séquences de livraison votre
stratégie aura en outre des conséquences
économiques graves dans les territoires
vous le savez mon département le Var et
le second département touristique le
plus touristique de France or l'économie
touristique étant particulièrement
volatile les touristes pouvant avoir
peur d'aller dans un département ou un
pays où la population serait très
largement non vaccinée votre stratégie
vaccinale particulièrement lente pourrai
signer l'acte de décès de notre économie
touristique varoise et française dans
son ensemble s'il était prochain les
chiffres de la vaccination n'étaient pas
bons surtout si ceux de nos voisins sont
bien meilleurs aussi monsieur le
ministre et avant les traditionnelles
annonces du jeudi pourquoi ne pas vous
appuyer sur les élus locaux sur
l'intelligence de nos territoires pour
optimiser la stratégie vaccinale et
ainsi prévoir un objectif bien plus
ambitieux pour l'été
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre et solidarité de la santé
monsieur Véro vous avez la parole madame
la sénatrice merci pour votre question
vous seriez surprise si vous venez avec
nous en déplacement quand on va dans les
territoires rencontrer des élus locaux
c'est vrai qu'ils sont parfois beaucoup
plus contributeurs pour nous aider que
ce qu'on peut parfois entendre à Paris
madame la sénatrice et y compris
d'ailleurs dans le Var madame la
sellatrice je suis en lien étroit avec
un certain nombre d'élus y compris de
votre bord politique madame la sénatrice
qui participe aux cellules de
coordination départementale pour pouvoir
mettre en place la stratégie vaccinale
il y en a un qui m'a dit qu'il avait
d'ailleurs recruté dans le département
qu'il avait recruté des médecins du
département pour venir faire appui au
centre de vaccination un maire m'a dit
qu'il avait un véhicule pour pouvoir
déplacer des personnes âgées isolées
dans les territoires du hover du côté de
la Dracénie que vous devez connaître et
que je connais bien et qu'il les mettait
ces véhicules à disposition pour faire
venir les personnes âgées isolées au
centre il me demandait s'il avait le
droit de le faire je lui avais dit on
est quand même pas si Jacobins qu'il
fallait que vous me posiez la question
en tant que mère de savoir si vous avez
le droit de transporter des personnes
âgées isolées à la maison vers un centre
de vaccination donc madame la sénatrice
c'est ce décalage entre ce que je
perçois parfois dans cette hémicycle ou
un autre et ce que j'entends et ce que
nous construisons avec les élus locaux
je vous invite à aller le constater
vous-même vous pouvez participer aux
cellules départementales de coordination
et d'organisation de la vaccination et
madame la sénatrice je vous dirai et
j'entends parfaitement les
préoccupations qui sont les vôtres mais
ce sont les mêmes préoccupations d'un
sénateur qui me poserait la question des
Alpes-Maritimes du Gers des pires des
Hautes-Pyrénées nous étions avec le
Premier ministre c'est que la
répartition des doses de vaccins dont
nous disposons elle se fera au prorata
de la population et non pas en fonction
de l'appel de telle ou telle élu ou des
préoccupations particulières du
territoire la seule entorse si je puis
dire que nous avons fait à cette règle
c'est de distribuer les 50 000 premières
doses de moderna au collectivité
territoriales aux communes du Grand Est
de Bourgogne Franche-Comté mais
également à Nice dans les
Alpes-Maritimes qui font face à une
recrudescence épidémique très forte et
je crois que chacun peut l'entendre donc
encore une fois la participation des
élus je serai à trois chez Monsieur
Baroin président de la MF vendredi avec
qui nous travaillons j'étais hier avec
l'AMF la DF la RF et France urbaine et
j'étais au téléphone encore tout à
l'heure avec le président Rottner pour
que nous puissions structurer ensemble
le moyen de permettre aussi aux régions
d'être d'intervenir en parfaite harmonie
avec les pouvoirs publics de l'État au
service de nos concitoyens merci la
parole est maintenant au président
Jean-François Longeot pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au Premier ministre au nom de
mon collègue Gérard podja monsieur le
Premier ministre en Nouvelle-Calédonie
dans un contexte où l'écart entre
indépendantistes et nonatépendantistes
c'est considérablement resserré lors du
référendum du 4 octobre dernier Val a
décidé de vendre son usine métallurgique
dans le sud du pays la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est alors enflammée
elle en a assisté à des scènes qui
rappellent les heures terribles des
événements des années 80
concerne la gravité de la situation nous
étions intervenus pour demander à ce que
l'État pilote désormais au plus haut
niveau ce dossier nous avions notamment
suggéré que le chant du dialogue soit
ouvert afin de construire un projet
consensuel pour la reprise de l'usine
au-delà de l'offre à l'origine du
conflit
il nous avait alors été indiqué qu'il
n'y avait qu'une seule offre viable sur
la table et que le gouvernement la
soutenait depuis lors la situation
semble avoir évolué puisque le ministre
des Outre-mer a précisé dans ses vœux au
calédoniens que le gouvernement fera une
nouvelle proposition très prochainement
prévoyant une implication plus forte de
l'État nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter notre collègue Gérard podja
les député calédonien a défendait depuis
plusieurs semaines l'idée d'une
participation ou d'une prise de contrôle
temporaire de l'État au capital de Val
afin que les acteurs disposent du temps
nécessaire à la construction d'un
consensus politique et industriel sur la
poursuite de l'activité industrielle de
la capacité du gouvernement a donné
véritablement corps à cette nouvelle
perspective dépend le maintien de 3000
emplois le retour à la paix civile ainsi
que la reprise d'activité mais de cette
impulsion dépend surtout la reprise du
dialogue politique en train
d'indépendantiste et non indépendantiste
dialogue essentiel dans le cadre de la
préparation du troisième référendum
d'autodermination prévu par l'accord de
Nouméa Monsieur le Premier Ministre ma
question est la suivante comment le
Gouvernement entend-il organiser
l'implication plus forte de l'État dans
le dossier de reprise de l'usine du Sud
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez la parole le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Longeot
et je m'adresse aussi au sénateur podja
puisque vous l'avez cité dans votre
question je vous remercie de me donner
l'opportunité de m'exprimer ce dossier
extrêmement sensible et que je suis très
directement avec bien sûr le concours
très actif de Sébastien Lecornu ministre
chargé des Outre-mer qui est ce dossier
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie vous le savez
toutes et tous et d'ailleurs votre
question le rappelle opportunément la
question du nickel est dans ce
territoire une question hautement
stratégique comme vous l'avez fait je
rappelle à la Haute Assemblée
qu'effectivement une usine valve vous
l'avez su au sud de l'île est
actuellement en cours de session 3000
emplois sont concernés au seul titre des
salariés et des sous-traitants
un seul repreneur vous l'avez dit est en
lice
l'état je le rappelle au Sénat
intervient déjà très massivement dans
cette entreprise
au point que il a décidé de maintenir
cette aide aux bénéfice de tout
repreneur je l'indique plus de 500
millions d'euros sous forme de prêt de
garantie de près et de défiscalisation
le projet de reprise là vient la
difficulté a fait l'objet d'une
opposition violente qui a conduit à des
troubles très graves dans l'île au début
du mois de décembre
la réponse de l'État par les forces de
l'ordre et l'autorité judiciaire a été
très claire et j'ajoute très bien
conduite et je veux le saluer devant la
Haute Assemblée
elle n'a malheureusement pas pu empêcher
de très nombreuses dégradations
commises dans cette usine et j'observe
avec vous qu'une partie des opposants au
projet de cession
pourtant tout à fait satisfaisant
opposant qui sont plutôt de tendance
indépendantistes ont finalement demandé
la nationalisation de l'usine par l'État
le problème ne s'est malheureusement pas
arrêté là puisque d'autres opposants ont
également fait le choix de bloquer une
autre usine que vous connaissez la SLN
dans l'état est actionnaire minoritaire
via Eramet
et là aussi pour je cite mettre la
pression sur l'état dans le dossier de
l'usine du Sud objet de votre question
en sorte que cet autre usine est-elle
désormais au bord de la faillite alors
que 10 000 emplois ils sont concernés
je voudrais rappeler du coup quelle est
la politique du gouvernement sur ces
dossiers plus généralement dans
l'affaire calédonienne puisque tel est
l'objet de votre question c'est d'abord
et toujours de rechercher la voix du
dialogue du dialogue le ministre des
Outre-mer a passé trois semaines en
Nouvelle-Calédonie en octobre tout de
suite après la consultation référendaire
et il avait après avoir rencontré tous
les acteurs
réussir à mettre tout le monde autour de
la table
et justement le sujet du nickel sans
surprise faisait partie de l'échéancier
des concertations appelées à être
conduite en novembre en décembre
évidemment on travaille par
visio-conférence pour les raisons que
vous savez la Nouvelle-Calédonie n'étant
pas épargnée par la crise sanitaire
l'état fait des propositions pour faire
évoluer l'offre de l'entreprise rassurer
les populations locales et apaiser les
tensions ces discussions mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs se poursuivent
et les autorités politiques locales
compétentissantes associées pour mettre
au point définitivement les modalités de
reprise du site son accompagnement par
l'État qui se poursuivra et son
acceptabilité sociale dans l'intérêt
commun mais pour pouvoir dialoguer je le
dis très tranquillement devant le Sénat
encore faut-il réunir les conditions du
dialogue c'est bien connu là-bas comme
partout on ne dialogue pas monsieur
sénateur sur la menace et les blocages
en cours sur les sites notamment de
l'autre usine la SLN je le dis devant
vous doivent cesser la paix civile
l'ordre républicains ne sont pas
négociables ne sont pas négociables et
cette affirmation loin d'affaiblir la
position et la volonté du gouvernement
de dialoguer au contraire la renforce
avec la tentation de la violence on ne
peut ni trancher ni tergiverser
de même je veux indiquer au Sénat
monsieur le sénateur que les décisions
de justice qui ont été rendues ces
dernières semaines pour condamner les
classeurs doivent être appliquées et
respectés
si on condamne les violences comme je me
plais à constater que d'aucuns le font
on accepte que les auteurs des violences
soient condamnés
et par ailleurs pour dialoguer il faut
que tout le monde soit présent autour de
la table et je le redis ici publiquement
la tribune du Sénat tout en étant ferme
sur le respect de certains principes je
continue inlassablement le gouvernement
continue inlassablement à appeler autour
de la table l'ensemble des responsables
politiques de l'île
monsieur le sénateur vous avez fait le
parallèle avec les terribles violences
qui ont marqué la Nouvelle-Calédonie au
début des années 1980
mais je crois que nous devons résister à
cette tentation d'informer cette ce
territoire dans cette référence le
contexte n'est plus du tout le même
30 années de rééquilibrage de partage du
pouvoir de dialogue sans passer par là
surtout surtout mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs aujourd'hui la moitié de
la population du caillou la moitié à
moins de 30 ans à moins de 30 ans
voilà donc la responsabilité historique
devant laquelle la République et
l'ensemble des acteurs politiques
calédoniens se trouvent non pas
reproduire revenir vers ce passé que
vous avez évoqué dans votre question
mais inventer une solution politique
nouvelle pour laquelle hédonie dans le
cadre de la République française vous
pouvez compter sur l'engagement de mon
gouvernement dans ce projet je vous
remercie et merci monsieur le Premier
ministre
mes chers collègues nous avons terminé
avec les questions au Gouvernement merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres nos prochaines
questions auront lieu le 20 janvier la
science est suspendue elle sera reprise
à
16h45 notamment pour la désignation des
membres de deux missions d'information
et le débat sur les conclusions du
rapport de la commission d'enquête sur
les problèmes sanitaires et écologiques
liés aux pollution des sols
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
premières de 2021 que vous avez pu
suivre en intégralité en direct sur
Public Sénat place tout de suite aux
réactions en salle des conférences nous
attend Alexandre Poussard car Alexandre
vous êtes avec Laurent pietrachevski
secrétaire d'État chargé des retraites
et de la santé au travail effectivement
pour parler des réformes du gouvernement
dans cette année 2021 marqués par la
crise sanitaire il y avait un séminaire
du gouvernement aujourd'hui pour voir et
bien les priorités en termes de réforme
et justement Laurent pietrachevski vous
êtes arrivés au gouvernement pour mener
la réforme des retraites est-ce que avec
cette crise sanitaire cette réforme des
retraites va avoir lieu au final
je suis déjà exprimé ce sujet vous serez
sans doute pas surpris de ma réponse
cette transformation du système de
retraite pour plus de justice sociale
mais aussi pour un équilibre on va
mettre à cette justice sociale cette
solidarité de vivre dans la durée fait
partie des engagements que nous avons
avec les Français nous sommes dans une
situation aujourd'hui qui est une
situation
on le sait de crise sanitaire de tension
économique de tension sociale toutes les
forces du gouvernement doivent être
consacrées à traiter cette crise
sanitaire cette crise économique cette
crise sociale et c'est aussi ce que je
fais aujourd'hui notamment avec toute la
dimension du portefeuille de la santé au
travail que j'ai aussi quand le moment
sera venu dans une situation apaisée
claire pacifiée nous reprendrons les
réformes pour lesquelles nous sommes
engagés auprès des Français quand le
moment sera venu avant 2022 ça va être
compliqué bah écoutez moi je vois qu'il
y a encore plus d'une année et demi
devant nous et c'est une année ennemi
qui sera
utile c'est une année et demie de projet
aussi de transformation vous savez le
fait que nous soyons là actuellement sur
un temps qui est si particulier si
exceptionnel au regard de cette crise
qui amène des réalités que nous n'avions
pas connu en matière économique et
sociale depuis la crise 1929 et bien ça
explique qu'il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui que nous soyons tous
concentrés sur cela il y aura
des temps meilleurs d'autres moments
vous le savez parce que nous traitons
cela aussi et que notamment avec toute
la stratégie vaccinelle que nous menons
nous serons aussi en situation dans les
mois qui viennent de passer à autre
chose alors autre réforme qui a été
suspendu c'est la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le
Conseil d'analyse économique qui est
rattaché au Premier ministre à Matignon
préconise dans cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage et bien de faire
varier les indemnités chômage en
fonction du taux de chômage également en
fonction des territoires et ce que le
gouvernement pourrait retenir et bien
c'est préconisations j'ai lu la note du
conseil c'est une contribution il faut
l'entendre comme cela c'est une
contribution au débat c'est toujours
bien d'avoir des contributions il y a
effectivement des propositions notamment
sur la gouvernance de l'assurance
chômage ces propositions n'engagent que
les auteurs de cette note vous savez
tout cela ça va se discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux ça fait partie de
l'agenda sociale que mène Elizabeth
borne avec les partenaires sociaux
rapidement Laurent pietrache qui est une
question sur les élections régionales
dans les hauts de France vous êtes
disponible pour mener une investiture la
République en marche vous êtes motivés
bien sûr que je suis motivé vous savez
je suis motivé pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est qu'on a une région haut
de France où je vis et j'habite depuis
plus de 40 ans où nous avons un
président de Région lui qui s'est
positionné pour faire de ces élections
régionales une rente de lancement pour
son ambition personnelle et moi je suis
pas comme ça que je vois les choses moi
je pense que si on veut s'engager pour
ses concitoyens dans une région c'est
parce qu'on a un projet c'est parce
qu'on veut faire porter à l'ensemble de
sa liste une volonté de transformation
dans sa région et c'est ce que je ferai
autour des valeurs à la fois que nous
portons tous dans la majorité
présidentielle si le mouvement
présidentiel de décide et donc peut-être
un match Laurent pietrachesse qui Xavier
Bertrand pour les régionales dans les
hauts de France merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour cette
première réaction et autres réactions
celle du président du groupe LR au Sénat
Bruno Retailleau pour une réaction à
cette séance marquée notamment et bien
par une réponse assez virulente de Jean
Castex le Premier ministre qui a défendu
la politique du gouvernement pendant la
crise sanitaire effectivement une longue
tirade du premier ministre Jean Castex
pour défendre la gestion de la crise
sanitaire du gouvernement Jean Castex
qui finalement regarde les chiffres de
l'épidémie sur le continent européen et
qui estime que la France est plutôt bien
loti et que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement a bien géré
vraiment je souhaite de tout cœur que
sur la vaccination que sur l'épidémie la
France puisse être en tête de liste
notamment des pays européens mais c'est
pas toujours le cas d'ailleurs le
président de la République lui-même a dû
pousser un coup de gueule contre lui
aussi puisque il est responsable des
décisions qui sont prises en conseil de
défense mais le président de la
République a indiqué que le rythme lui
convenait pas le gouvernement a dû
changer à plusieurs reprises stratégies
d'abord en élargissant jusqu'au 75 ans
pour l'instant à partir du 18 janvier et
en acceptant le principe des
vaccinodrome souvenez-vous des
déclarations de Monsieur Véran qui les
refusait c'est donc bien qu'il y a eu un
problème pourquoi est-ce que parce que
les chiffres sont têtus pourquoi est-ce
que pendant que les Anglais vont faire
entre 5 ou 7 ou 8 millions en un mois de
vaccination nous on en fera à grand
peine un million pourquoi cette
différence donc c'est la faute de la
Commission européenne qui ne commande
pas assez de vaccin non je crois pas
parce que regarder avec l'Allemagne nous
sommes aussi bien sûr il y a le brexit
mais l'Allemagne est beaucoup beaucoup
de pays européens l'Espagne l'Italie à
chaque fois nous sommes derrière nous
avons une sorte de bon état et ça les
Français ont senti de la colère mais
plus encore une forme d'humiliation
collective alors demain Jean Castex va
peut-être annoncer de nouvelles mesures
sanitaires et peut-être un couvre-feu à
18h généralisé dans le pays ce serait
vraiment utile un couvre-feu à 18h
écoutez moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
on accélère de vaccination ce que je
souhaite aussi c'est que enfin on puisse
déployer une vraie stratégie dépister
tracer mais surtout isolé pourquoi
est-ce que en France on ne parvient pas
à isoler les malades il vaut mieux
isoler ceux qui sont positifs qu'isoler
toute la population par des confinements
nocturnes comme le couvre-feu ou par des
confinements toute la journée comme le
confinement qu'on a pu connaître soit au
printemps soit l'automne merci beaucoup
Bruno Retailleau pour votre réaction
allez et puis une dernière réaction à
votre micro Alexandre une ministre qu'on
a beaucoup entendu lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
la ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche Frédéric Vidal car
effectivement et bien dans toute cette
période la situation des étudiants est
très difficile très compliqué
effectivement une séance de questions
d'actualité marquée par ce mal-être des
étudiants qui sont victimes des mesures
sanitaires et de l'isolement et ce que
disent les sénateurs madame la ministre
c'est que les mesures mises en place par
le gouvernement pour soutenir les
étudiants ne suffisent pas il y a 30%
d'étudiants dépression
alors en réalité ce que l'on observe
c'est effectivement mais c'était déjà le
cas lors du premier confinement et
encore lors de ce deuxième confinement
des difficultés psychologiques
renforcées chez les étudiants comme
d'ailleurs chez de très nombreux de nos
concitoyens on n'a jamais vécu une
situation de cette sorte et donc
évidemment c'est très difficile d'y
répondre comme le premier ministre l'a
dit notre objectif c'est maintenant de
travailler à ce que l'on puisse
accompagner le retour des étudiants dans
les établissements le président de la
République avait souhaité il avait
souhaité un deuxième semestre le plus
normal possible évidemment tout est
toujours conditionné à l'évolution
sanitaire mais néanmoins nous avons déjà
franchi un pas supplémentaire des
universités n'étaient pas fermées
pendant le deuxième confinement elles
peuvent accueillir en plus des étudiants
dans les salles de ressources en plus
des étudiants en travaux pratiques en
plus d'un certain nombre d'étudiants en
formation et bien des étudiants par
petits groupes de 10
nous allons continuer et amplifier et
permettre à plus d'étudiants encore de
retourner sur les bancs des universités
et des écoles dans les prochaines
semaines c'est un travail que nous
menons avec l'ensemble des
établissements depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà justement sur ces retours des
étudiants en présentiel par petit groupe
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres sur et
bien la proportion de la population
étudiante que ça représente et que ça
pourrait représenter
potentiellement l'idée c'est que c'est
avant tout une confiance aux
établissements c'est eux qui vont
choisir comment ils s'organisent choisir
de faire revenir 10 étudiants pour la
quasi-totalité de leurs cours les
étudiants par groupe de 10 pardon pour
la quasi-totalité de leur corps ils
peuvent aussi décider de faire revenir
les étudiants on a qu'on a qualifié de
fragile mais c'est eux en fait qui sont
capables de savoir ils peuvent les faire
revenir beaucoup plus nombreux toujours
par groupe de 10 mais seulement quelques
heures par semaine c'est une
organisation qui se met en place
et l'idée c'est qu'on puisse amplifier
cela en mettant en place de nouvelles
mesures que nous allons commencer à
travailler avec eux dès à présent
justement avec une concertation vendredi
qu'elle piste vous allez vous mettre sur
la table en tant que ministre pour
améliorer les situations l'idée c'est
vraiment d'essayer de répondre à la
problématique majeure qui est le
brassage des étudiants pendant les
intercours ou entre les cours du matin
et de l'après-midi donc voilà parmi les
choses que nous allons essayer d'évoquer
c'est la possibilité
de grouper les enseignements pour un
groupe donné sur des demi-journées la
possibilité de travailler plutôt en
gardant les étudiants toujours dans la
même salle toujours les mêmes étudiants
dans la même salle plutôt que de les
faire bouger entre amphithéâtre et celle
de travaux dirigés voilà tout un tas de
choses très pratiques très pragmatique
pour nous permettre d'augmenter le
nombre d'étudiants qui pourront revenir
au sein des universités et des écoles
merci beaucoup Frédéric Vidal d'avoir
répondu à mes questions après cette
séance de questions d'actualité merci
beaucoup Alexandre
vous sénateur les indépendants de laine
et avec moi également Sophie Taye
polliant bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice écologiste du Val-de-Marne
votre groupe a d'ailleurs posé une
question sur la situation des étudiants
les étudiants en détresse est-ce que
vous êtes satisfaits parce que vient de
répondre Frédéric Vidal la ministre
alors que on le voit à l'anxiété la
dépression en particulier chez les
étudiants de première année c'est un
vrai problème aujourd'hui y compris
reconnu par par Jean-François delfrecy
qui préside le conseil scientifique et
bien oui nous sommes particulièrement
préoccupés par la situation de
l'ensemble de la jeunesse et d'ailleurs
moi ce que j'observe c'est que cela fait
plusieurs semaines que nous tirons la
sonnette d'alarme au moment des débats
autour des projets de loi de finances
rectificative donc avant les congés de
fin d'année depuis la rentrée nous
parlons de la de la détresse des jeunes
et le gouvernement nous disait ne vous
inquiétez pas nous gérons est-ce que
nous observons là c'est une ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur qui nous dit on
va concerter vendredi pour voir on peut
faire des petits groupes et si on peut
travailler sur les questions du brassage
mais pourquoi n'a-t-on pas fait ça
depuis des mois on a aujourd'hui des
étudiants qui sont effectivement dans un
état extrêmement difficile de
démotivation et de détresse
psychologiques pour une partie d'entre
eux il n'y a eu aucune anticipation
malgré nos alertes sur ce sujet et moi
j'ai rencontré ce week-end une
enseignante à l'université de Créteil
dans le Val-de-Marne qui me disait on
est au courant de rien de ce qui va se
passer donc quand on nous dit que sur le
terrain tout va bien et non voilà et les
étudiants effectivement sont en
situation difficile et évidemment leurs
enseignants sont extrêmement démunis
d'autant plus que l'université souffre
d'un manque de moyens depuis si
longtemps donc n'a pas pu déployer des
outils performants sacrifiés pour vous
oubliez non il est encore temps d'agir
et en tout cas il est certain qu'il faut
mettre en place des des innovations
pédagogiques des rencontres
individuelles ou un petit groupe et cela
doit être mis extrêmement de façon très
très urgente et je crois aussi que on
doit s'adresser aussi à l'ensemble de la
jeunesse et pas seulement aux étudiants
mais les étudiants c'est une c'est une
spécificité là à laquelle on voit que le
gouvernement n'a pas n'a pas répondu en
prévoyant car Jean verzelen on comprend
on entend bien sûr cette détresse
grandissante des étudiants les étudiants
par exemple de l'Université de hôtel
Alsace qui ont aujourd'hui adressé une
lettre ouverte à Emmanuel Macron et en
même temps on voit le contexte sanitaire
qui se tend donc on va forcément et bien
que le gouvernement est face à un
dilemme dans cette situation il y a un
chiffre qui est extrêmement inquiétant
c'est le nombre d'étudiants qui suivent
les cours à distance là où on était
encore il y a quelques mois à 70% au
début du confinement on approche
aujourd'hui les 40 ça veut dire que une
partie en tout cas décroche ça veut dire
que dans le respect des conditions
sanitaires avec la jauge qu'il faut il
faut que de manière récurrente et petit
groupe par petit groupe les étudiants
puissent reprendre contact physiquement
avec le lieu d'enseignement et avec leur
enseignant encore une fois dans le
respect des préconisations sanitaires il
y a un deuxième élément qui qui
complique beaucoup la vie de certains
étudiants c'est les petits les petits
jobs que certains faisaient
essentiellement dans la restauration
dans les bars qui permettent qui
permettaient de financer les études et
tout ce qu'il y avait à côté des études
il est très aujourd'hui
des universités pardon c'est très peu
par rapport au nombre de gens qui
avaient d'étudiants qui avaient déjà à
côté et donc certains se retrouvent dans
des situations aussi de précarité qui
sont évidemment compliquées à vivre
après le malaise des étudiants je suis
pas convaincu qu'il ait des marais enfin
le malaise des étudiants sur le thème je
fais des études c'est quoi le boulot
après c'est quoi la vie est-ce que
demain c'est mieux qu'avant le malaise
il a pas démarré que là à partir du
confinement
est extrêmement préoccupante et
dramatique dans une des villes du
département du Val-de-Marne cachant on
me des élus locaux me faisait remonter
l'information selon laquelle lors d'une
d'une distribution de colis alimentaires
il y avait un tiers des nouveaux peines
nouvelles personnes qui demandaient
l'aide qui était des étudiants et cela
nous l'avons au Didi et Roady et redit
et c'est pas en créant 22000 petites
Jobs nous avons demandé nous demandons
et les organisations de jeunesse le
demande l'extension du RSA au 18-25 ans
pour ceux qui ne sont pas évidemment
étudiants l'augmentation également des
bourses et il de prendre la mesure pour
ne pas effectivement que nous payons les
conséquences de cette crise dans les
années à venir et pendant longtemps
parce que cette jeunesse aura trop
souffert aura trop subie autre sujet qui
a marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement la gestion
par l'exécutif de la crise sanitaire ça
a été marqué notamment par une
intervention remarquée de Jean Castex
Steve Jourdan est dans l'hémicycle c'est
vrai que c'était là le temps fort de
cette séance tout à l'heure Steve il
était question stratégie vaccinale et
des lenteurs constatées ces 15 derniers
jours alors comment expliquer ce retard
à l'allumage la question était posée par
le président du groupe socialiste
Patrick réponse de Jean Castex il faut
calmer le jeu selon lui la France n'est
pas dans une situation plus
catastrophique que les autres pays en
Europe d'ailleurs vous les sénateurs
vous avez bien approuvé la politique du
gouvernement en matière de vaccin
c'était lors d'un débat ici à la
mi-décembre écoutez Jean Castex
je
ne vous cessé de critiquer et de
contrôler le gouvernement c'est votre
rôle je demande simplement que nous nous
autoflagions pas
c'est de la Franc non non c'est pas
d'auto satisfaction monsieur c'est non
ce sont des faits c'est pas moi c'est
pas moi ce sont les Françaises et les
Français qui ont fait les efforts
nécessaires comme on l'avait demandé
entre noël et jour de là quand sont
largement responsables donc tout ne va
pas bien sûrement vous me direz
d'ailleurs dans quel pays tout va bien
vous voudrez bien les indiquer et nous
nous y rendrons
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que nous
menons une action déterminée contre
cette crise sanitaire c'est vrai que les
drames sont considérables les dégâts
tout autant mais à un moment donné
calmant le jeu je suis ici dans la
chambre de la sérénité voilà une réponse
sans sans doute qui n'a pas forcément
convaincu les sénateurs et je suis prêt
à parier tant qu'on reparlera vaccin
dans cette hémicycle dès mercredi
prochain merci beaucoup à Steve pour
toutes ces explications Pierre-Jean
verzelen virulence justifiée de Jean
Castex pour vous dans cette réponse il
est vrai qu'il n'a pas été ménagé par
par les oppositions jusqu'ici mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de ce ton
dans l'intervention du Premier ministre
est-ce que le gouvernement sans lire a
changé de stratégie depuis quelques
jours la réponse c'est oui
un retard à l'allumage la réponse c'est
oui globalement il y a plusieurs
questions dans l'architecture des choses
1 combien il y a de vaccins ils arrivent
quand on peut les déployer quand ensuite
à la logistique le transport les lieux
et ensuite il y a le personnel qui peut
vacciner les gens et puis dernièrement
il y a l'information trois réflexions
très rapides un on a confié à l'ARS
l'organisation de ces vaccins mais les
RS elle est pas faite pour ça c'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur et c'est les
préfectures avec les collectivités
locales qui peuvent au mieux gérer ces
vaccinations
deuxièmement à partir de lundi des
centres de vaccination ouvre dans des
centres où il y a des médecins
généralistes les prises de rendez-vous
vont être un vrai sujet c'est très
logistique mais il va falloir s'y
intéresser sinon ça peut être le bazar
dans pas mal d'endroits et troisièmement
il va falloir que quand tu rentres un
peu plus de vaccins on s'appuie sur les
pharmaciens qui comme pour la grippe
pourrait vacciner le plus grand nombre
de Français seront peut-être plus
simples à conserver à dire Olivier Véran
il y a eu des problèmes de logistique un
retard qui est pour vous et bien n'est
pas justifié Sophie taillé paulian bien
sûr qu'il y a eu des des difficultés
majeures dans la façon dont on se plant
stratégique a été déployée
donc voilà le gouvernement a changé de
braquet a changé un peu de
d'organisation des choses et pourquoi le
premier ministre est temps sur la
défensive en disant je suis très serein
mais n'en a pas l'air c'est parce
qu'effectivement il y a eu des il y a eu
des il y a eu des bougies il y a eu des
changements bon effectivement je suis en
accord avec ce que dit mon collègue
c'est-à-dire que là on nous a annoncé
que les plus de 75 ans pourraient aller
se faire vacciner sur rendez-vous mais
si effectivement on avait bien anticipé
cela la prise de rendez-vous tout
devrait déjà être prêt et les gens
devraient pouvoir commencer on aurait pu
prendre rendez-vous mais bien sûr et
c'est là qu'on voit qu'il y a aucune
anticipation alors c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que c'est extrêmement difficile de
gérer cette crise cependant on parle de
vaccination on parle de mise en place
des différents des différentes éléments
pour bien que tout cela se soit ancré
dans les territoires depuis trop
longtemps pour que on en arrive à cette
situation et moi je le dis il est les
mères les Présidents de Conseils
départementaux n'ont pas été
suffisamment associés à la mise en œuvre
de tout cela des registres pour prendre
rendez-vous peut-être qu'on va faire des
supers plateformes maintenant à la
va-vite en s'appuyant par ailleurs sur
des officines privées mais enfin on
aurait dit appeler tous les tous les
retraités de plus de 75 ans parce que
dans les mairies on les connaît bien et
voyez qui a envie et a commencé à
organiser des rendez-vous bah écoutez
peut-être qu'on serait plus avancé parce
que j'espère qu'on va pas se retrouver
la semaine prochaine avec des gens qui
restent des heures au téléphone ou qui
n'arrivent pas à se connecter avec des
plateformes qui qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas prêtes donc le gouvernement
c'est majeur encore attendu au tournant
donc la semaine prochaine merci merci
beaucoup
merci Pierre janverselen d'avoir
participé à ce premier débrief de 2021
débrief un peu écourté car place à
présent à l'audition d'Eric
Dupont-Moretti le garde des sceaux
auditionné et bien par la commission des
Lois du Sénat autour de la réforme de la
justice des mineurs il est attendu lui
aussi au tournant le ministre de la
justice car les sénateurs estiment qu'il
se précipite dans cette réforme et qu'il
cherche à court-circuiter la lecture au
Sénat qui est prévu fin janvier regardez
tout de suite son audition merci de
d'avoir accepté de venir cet après-midi
devant la commission des lois pour
aborder ensemble le texte plus
exactement la loi
ratifiant l'ordonnance créant le code de
justice pénale des mineurs je ne vais
pas refaire l'historique mais parce que
mais rappelez tout de même qu'au moment
où le Sénat a eu à connaître de la loi
sur la réforme de la justice notre
prédécesseur nous avions évoqué avec
votre prédécesseur la possibilité de
d'évoquer justement de traiter la
question du code de justice pénale des
mineurs il nous avait été répandus que
non qui aura un texte spécifique et
qu'on le verrait un autre moment j'étais
à la fin du débat parlementaire que on
nous a demandé finalement d'aviliter le
gouvernement à légiférer par voie
d'ordonnance
vous n'y êtes pour rien monsieur le
ministria aucun doute ce n'est pas ce
que je veux dire vous n'y êtes pour rien
nous le savons tous ici dans cette
hémicycle simplement nous avions été
quand même
on va dire pas content de cette façon de
faire
on peut tout comprendre mais là on a été
pas très heureux du tout bien nous
revoilà avec maintenant l'ordonnance qui
arrive
je ne refais pas la discussion que nous
avons eu au téléphone la semaine
dernière tous les deux à la suite de
rencontrer il m'arrive parfois de parler
à des membres du gouvernement
juridiction en prévision de la mise en
oeuvre venir vient pas mais
voilà on s'est expliqué je souhaite
quand même nous souhaitons c'est pas moi
à titre particulier mais l'institution
et le Sénat en particulier la commission
des lois spécifiquement
et ont été un peu chagrinés voilà je
m'en arrête là mais en revanche nous
profitons avec beaucoup d'intérêt de cet
après-midi et de votre présence pour
pouvoir évoquer avec vous ce dossier sur
lequel Madame Agnès canailler qui est
ici à notre collègue et rapporteur et
aura sans doute un certain nombre de
questions à vous poser et puis les
autres collègues aussi il va simplement
je vous propose de vous laisser tout de
suite la parole monsieur le ministre et
puis ensuite madame canaillé puis les
collègues qui le souhaiteront
naturellement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un honneur pour moi de présenter
devant la commission des Lois du Sénat
le projet de loi de rectification de
l'ordonnance du 11 septembre 2019
pourtant partie législatives du code de
la justice pénale des mineurs vous
l'avez rappelé et merci monsieur le
président
je ne suis en rien responsable de la
façon dont ce texte arrive ici devant le
Sénat
et
je ne veux pas ce serait pas juste vous
l'avez concédé être le réceptacle de
votre courroux sur cette question
bon cette réforme on va le dire elle est
attendue
de très longue date
2007-2008 je suis fier d'en débattre
avec vous c'est un texte qui était
largement concerté
par tous les acteurs de la justice des
mineurs
il a été enrichi en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une
concertation de plus de 10 ans quatre
garde des sceaux
et presque autant de majorité qui ont
préparé ce travail de codification et de
clarification
les réformes successives se sont se sont
empilées sans cohérence au gré des
alternances politiques transformant
l'ordonnance de 45 en un texte dont tous
les professionnels s'accordent à dire
qu'il est devenu illisible
ce très fort longuement mûri et
équilibré
vient maintenant devant vous et elle
parvient à répondre aux attentes des
Français
améliorer la procédure pénale applicable
mineure délinquants en renforçant les
principes fondamentaux de l'ordonnance
de 45 c'est la primauté de l'éducatif
l'atténuation de la peine la
spécialisation des acteurs
bon je vais commencer par corriger
rapidement un certain nombre de choses
entendues
ça et là
et en particulier
au sujet de d'un mépris d'une
condescendance c'est pas quel mot
utilisé
qu'aurait-il ministère de la Justice ou
moi-même moi-même d'ailleurs pour la
chambre haute nous sommes expliqués
monsieur le Président
je serai sans doute amené à fournir
d'autres explications mais en réalité
les mêmes car j'ai vu que le courroux
c'était également exprimé à la
télévision
et donc j'entends vous rassurer
l'intégrief l'une des préoccupations qui
est celle
que j'ai entendu à l'Assemblée nationale
que j'entendrai certainement ici au
Sénat
c'est est-ce que les juridictions sont
prêtes au fond
alors je vous répondrai complètement en
termes de moyens
en terme
d'analyse que j'ai demandé à mes
services
juridiction par juridiction
et donc on a souhaité
prévenir les juridictions de la première
mouture du texte en ajoutant j'espère
que tout a été lu je suis même convaincu
que tout a été élu que
le travail au Sénat devait intervenir
alors on a dit que c'était une
circulaire Canada je vous ai dit ce
Président vous aviez raison
circulaire qui a vocation à prévenir les
professionnels de ce que un texte
va arriver il sera évidemment
à modeler transformer vous ferez le
travail législatif que vous avez à faire
et je l'écris dans cette circulation je
dis que c'est pas terminé et que c'est
pas sur la base de ce texte là que les
juridictions vont travailler mais j'ai
quand même la secrété espérance que les
grands équilibres ne sont pas modifiés
je l'écris en toutes lettres donc ça
n'était pas pour moi une volonté de ne
pas regarder le Sénat comme il doit
l'être je respecte évidemment la haute
assemblée et j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec elle
j'espère bien sûr que il ne s'agit pas
là d'une polémique politicienne nous
avons eu déjà des débats parfois nous
étions d'accord parfois nous étions
opposés je n'ai jamais souhaité y mettre
une dose de politique politicienne je
pense que la qualité de nos échanges
sont trouvés sans doute
amélioré à défaut d'être déjà de bon
niveau et j'entends naturellement que
nous nous poursuivions sur sur cette
voie alors cette réforme
ceci étant étant précisé elle consacre
une justice des mineurs plus efficace
plus lisible plus rapide et désormais
prévisible pour tous
l'intervention judiciaire éducative
interviendra plus vite c'est important
parce que nous savons que nombre de
mineurs ont été condamnés après être
majeurs et parfois
encore jeune majeur mais mais
très très vieux mineur si vous me
permettez cette expression on est dans
des situations qui sont invraisemblables
la mise en examen était en serrée par
aucun délai ce qui d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon a permis le stock
c'est le ce mot néocapitalistique que
l'on utilise pardon je n'ai pas inventé
et vous avez des gamins de 16 ans qui
ont été jugés quand ils en avaient 22
c'est une perte de temps pour tout le
monde évidemment le message pédagogique
n'a plus aucune signification il doit
intervenir vite c'est le ministre de la
Justice qui vous le dit mais vous le
savez il suffit d'être père de famille
pour le savoir une sanction ou une
juridicative d'ailleurs que l'on inflige
ou que l'on impose à ses enfants à
l'intervient pas trois ans après bon
la rapidité de la première intervention
judiciaire avec une audience de
culpabilité
qui ne signifie pas la mise en place
d'une justice expéditive j'ai pu lire un
certain nombre de choses de cet ordre de
cette nature et je le répète les
équilibres sont préservés il y a le
temps de l'éducatif n'est pas réduit il
est au contraire encadré et il peut être
prolongé lorsque jugé nécessaire et le
travail éducatif s'inscrit bien dans un
continuum donc on a une première
audience de culpabilité puis une
audience qui sera consacrée à la peine
et entre les deux des mesures éducatives
et le regroupement de toutes les autres
procédures en cours ça le mérite de la
rapidité
et c'est extrêmement important pour la
justice des mineurs ça prend en compte
évidemment les victimes
l'éducatif est au cœur de cette réforme
et je voudrais en 2 secondes et ensuite
nous échangeons je veux pas qu'ils que
ce soit un monologue imposé
je veux clarifier les étapes d'abord
nous pouvons dire que
il y a eu un véritable débat
démocratique
ratification par voie d'ordonnance
j'ai entendu monsieur le Président ce
que vous disiez mais le débat
démocratique a été totalement intégré et
vous en êtes d'ailleurs les garants et
après d'un demi millier d'amendements
qui ont été discutés en commission des
lois à l'Assemblée nationale et autant
on science public en décembre dernier
une autre inquiétude de vous est soumise
c'est les juridictions et services de la
Protection Judiciaire de la Jeunesse
seront-ils prêts
alors la réponse elle est clairement oui
mais d'abord je tiens à vous dire que
toutes les réformes ont souvent été pour
ne pas dire toujours mal perçue et mal
reçu
le souvenir de la loi du 15 juin 2000
dites loi Guigou
qui aujourd'hui ne serait plus discutée
par personne qui faisait l'objet de
manifestations devant la Chancellerie
place Vendôme et je me souviens d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs judiciaires qui
jetaient les codes les jetés par terre
j'étais en avocats j'avais persiflé à
l'époque que on ferait mieux de les lire
que de Lester il y a pas de réforme qui
ont été accueillies les bras ouverts
c'est toujours compliqué une réforme ça
c'est sur ce qui s'est passé depuis
toujours historiquement je pense pas
avoir tort maintenant de façon de façon
plus précise
il y a des moyens et des renforts de
moyens
nous avons
dans les juridictions d'abord
l'expertise des services il y avait une
dizaine de juridictions qui se
trouvaient en fragilité
elles ont été
analysées d'abord répertorié analyser
dans les juridictions nous avons envoyé
72 magistrats qui ont été affectés au
1er septembre 2020
sans greffier qui ont permis un renfort
immédiat en anticipant évidemment les
les sorties d'école de greffe
je voudrais vous donner un exemple la
localisation de quatre emplois de greffe
depuis 2018 à Bobigny répondant ainsi
aux demandes exprimées par l'échelle de
juridiction au sein de la PJJ la réforme
a également été anticipée depuis 2018
avec 252 emplois nouveaux créés jusqu'en
2022 en complément 86 éducateurs
viennent d'être recrutés dans le cadre
des budgets qui ont été alloués à la
justice de proximité
un appui inédit naturellement légitime
et grâce à cette mission que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure de l'inspection générale
de la justice
nous avons pu apporter au juridictions
et aux services territoriaux de la pjg
une assistance méthodologique directe à
la mise en place de la réforme donc
j'affirme que les juridictions sont
prêtes
à recevoir et à appliquer cette réforme
nous avons d'ailleurs sur le terrain
numérique anticipé sa mise en œuvre de
façon bien sûr à ce que les dispositions
nouvelles soient plus rapidement
intégrées j'entends
j'entends maintenant si vous voulez bien
que nous échangeions sur ces questions
il y a un certain nombre de problèmes
qui ont notamment été évoqué à
l'Assemblée nationale qui seront
peut-être évoqués ici devant le Sénat je
prends monopoliser la parole notre temps
est un peu compter monsieur le Président
si je comprends bien donc je souhaite
plutôt et si vous le voulez bien que que
nous échangions sur les équilibres
nouveaux apportés par cette loi et je
suis à votre frontière disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre oui nous
avons le temps devant nous il y a pas
trop de difficultés particulières Madame
Agnès
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
alors effectivement
nous ne contestons pas la nécessité de
la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme qui
est attendue étant donné que
l'ordonnance de 1945 a été réformé plus
de 40 fois et que l'on voit bien
aujourd'hui un certain de décalage et
une nécessité de rendre comme vous
l'avez
annoncé une justice plus adaptée à
l'évolution et aux besoins des mineurs
néanmoins un certain nombre de questions
se posent à nous et la première vous
avez commencé à l'aborder c'est avant
tout celle des délais d'entrée en
vigueur de cette réforme qui nous
paraissent dans le temps que nous
connaissons dans le contexte que nous
vivons actuellement notamment et celui
des juridictions qui supportent cette
crise comme nous tous cette crise
sanitaire et ses effets qui a supporté
une grève des avocats qui a quand même
ralenti aussi un certain nombre de
procédures et augmenter un certain
nombre de stock nous étant effectivement
pas très beau mais
représentant le nombre de dossiers quand
on a
quand on se rend dans les tribunaux on
voit effectivement ces stocks de
dossiers papier qui s'empilent et ça a
une vraie réalité
et donc nous voyons aujourd'hui quand
même que cette mise en oeuvre a délai
très rapproché puisque 31 mars sera un
mois au mieux après la fin du processus
législatif alors tu as bien compris que
vous l'aviez anticipé ce qui en soi est
compréhensible
néanmoins on voit bien que ça risque
d'être quand même très compliqué alors
on peut considérer que la technique du
sparadrap c'est efficace d'un coup ça
fait mal et au moins comme ça on rentre
directement dans le vif du sujet
néanmoins là il nous semble quand même
que
certains nombre de juridictions ne sont
pas prêtes pour pouvoir
assimiler cette réforme quand bien même
des moyens supplémentaires ont été mis
en oeuvre on a eu ces débats au moment
du projet de loi de finances néanmoins
on voit qu'il y a quand même encore un
certain nombre de addictions qui sont en
fragilité pour lesquelles ça risque
compliqué d'être compliqué dans ce délai
raccourci de mettre en place non
seulement parce que tous les stocks ne
seront pas à purée parce que
la période de transition ou au moment où
il faudra pour ces juridictions
assimiler deux procédures l'ancienne et
la nouvelle n'est pas forcément toujours
bien encore préparé techniquement et
même juridiquement parce qu'on sent que
la formation et l'information voire
l'information pour certains acteurs de
cette démineur et pas tout à fait encore
assuré et
complètement affiné et on voit surtout
que les moyens informatifs vous l'avez
évolué et évoqué notamment le Cassiopée
est loin d'être au point on le sait pour
d'autres réformes que la difficulté d'un
manque que ce soit la réforme du divorce
ou celle du bloc Pen reste encore
compliquée à mettre en place faute de
moyens informatiques donc ma question va
être simple c'est comment entendez-vous
tenir ce délai quels moyens alors j'ai
compris des moyens humains mais ça va
pas suffire parce qu'il suffit pas
d'avoir des personnes en nombre il faut
aussi des personnels et des magistrats
des greffiers et
des acteurs de la PJJ qui soient
optimum est capable d'avoir assimilé la
réforme qui est quand même une réforme
d'ampleur on parle pas d'une petite
réforme de procédure on parle de la
réforme globale de l'ensemble du code
pénal des mineurs avec vous l'avez dit
une procédure innovante avec cette
procédure de la césure enfin qui me
change totalement les pratiques
de cette justice pénale des mineurs et
donc nous sommes extrêmement inquiet
aujourd'hui sur une mise en oeuvre Adel
et rapprochée qui pour nous va
fragiliser les fondations d'une réforme
qui est importante et qui est
essentielle et qu'on a manifestement et
a fortiori dans le contexte dans lequel
nous vivons besoin et les juridictions
ont besoin d'un délai supplémentaire
sans remettre en cause la réforme mais
vraiment pour renforcer sa mise en
oeuvre ça c'est une première question
deuxième question
c'est on voit que c'est une réforme
d'une partie simplement de la justice
des mineurs celle de la partie pénale or
le mineur avec un principe fondamental
qui est celui de l'éducatif qui doit
primer sur le répressif mais dès lors
que l'on aborde l'éducatif on doit
prendre l'enfant dans toutes ses
composantes et on sait qu'il y a de
forts rapprochement dans les dossiers
entre les problématiques de l'enfance
délinquante et de celle de l'enfance en
danger et donc comment
quels moyens entendez-vous mettre
comment entendez-vous mieux articuler
ces deux parties indissociables de la
justice des mineurs celle la partie
éducative et la partie pénale une
troisième question va concerner les
mineurs non accompagné qui est un sujet
en soit dans le sujet et notamment avec
une procédure qui l'aurait adaptée celle
de l'audience unique ma question elle va
être simple aussi cette pensez-vous
vraiment que cette mesure va être
adaptée à des mineurs non accompagné qui
sont pris dans des réseaux parce qu'on
voit beaucoup aussi de difficultés sur
ces mineurs particuliers qui se
retrouvent à paix par des réseaux et qui
sont difficilement
à la mesure et à la disposition de la
justice
notre question sur le recours au juge de
la liberté les détentions donc je vais
qui est un sujet qui nous pose problème
aussi alors qui a été ajouté par
l'Assemblée nationale pour répondre aux
respects des principes d'inspartialité
du juge telles que imposés par le
Conseil Constitution en application de
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme
comment voyez-vous cet articulation avec
la justice des mineurs notamment le fait
que le juge des mineurs n'est plus
présent dans cette partie celle de la
détention et la mise en liberté du
mineur alors que pour nous avoir aussi
une continuité éducative sur ce sujet et
j'ai un autre question concernant
puisque un des enjeux aussi la
spécialisation et la spécificité des
juridictions or vous avez maintenu dans
ce code de justice pénale des mineurs la
compétence du tribunal de police pour
les contrats
des quatre premières classes ça nous
paraît être un peu anachronique avec la
volonté de spécialisation pas très
opportun que ce soit le juge des enfants
ou le tribunal pour enfants enfin
justice des mineurs qui soient
compétente dans sa globalité puis une
dernière question là aussi nous les la
volonté d'une justice plus rapide pour
mieux répondre au développement de
l'enfant et de mieux prendre en compte
les victimes nous paraît opportuns
pourtant les délais sont des délais
indicatifs comment comptez-vous assurer
le véritable respect de ces délais
contraints dans cette procédure
qui l'a demandé puis ensuite monsieur
Lecomte merci monsieur le président
particulière bon le mieux aussi il faut
une réponse globale
alors monsieur le garde des sceaux je
voulais d'abord poser une question qui
n'a pas qui n'a pas très exactement à ce
texte mais qui est très urgence
vous savez que le Conseil
constitutionnel a demandé avec beaucoup
de force d'ailleurs les décisions du
Conseil constitutionnel s'impose à
toutes les autorités comme vous savez
qu'il y ait un texte de législatif par
rapport à la possibilité donnée au
détenu de contester leurs conditions de
détention pour indemnité vous aviez
pensé vous ne l'aviez d'ailleurs indiqué
présenté ce texte à la faveur du projet
de loi sur le parquet puis vous y avez
renoncé craignant que cela ne fut
considéré comme des innombrables
cavaliers bien mais alors je vous
demande simplement à quelle date vous
comptez déposer un projet de loi parce
qu'il y a deux solutions ou bien il y a
une proposition de loi mais sans le
concours du gouvernement je vois mal
qu'elle puisse être appliquée adoptée
avant avec deux navettes avant le mois
de mars
et donc il reste une projet de loi et
comme on ne peut pas ne va appliquer ce
que dit le Conseil constitutionnel je me
permets aujourd'hui 13 janvier de vous
poser la question même si ce n'est pas
le sujet de la réunion du jour parce
qu'il faudra bien trouver une solution
alors pour ce qui est du texte
madame cadey a déjà posé beaucoup des
questions que je voulais aborder et à
juste titre donc le premier point je
vais aborder trois points seulement le
premier point c'est en effet la date
d'application
compte tenu de ce que vous nous avez dit
je n'ai pas revenir sur le fait que le
texte d'implication soit préalable à
l'adoption balle de Sénat etc du texte
vous avez déjà répondu est-ce qu'il ne
serait pas sage de reporter la date
d'application tout simplement de
quelques mois pour le moins de manière à
ce que l'on se connait que les
différentes
personnes responsables de ce sujet dans
les juridictions puissent se préparer
deuxième question
nous avons longuement parlé l'autre jour
avec Jean-Pierre aux enzoeil qui nous
est dû parler en bien de vous monsieur
le ministre mais il nous a dit de toutes
les manières possibles qu'il était
vraiment incompréhensible
que l'on ne pose pas l'irresponsabilité
pénale des mineurs de 13 ans vous savez
ce débat sur la présomption simple à
laquelle vous tenez beaucoup si je
comprends vous tenez dans ce texte ou
pas beaucoup où il réfragable en tout
cas
quand on regarde
la Convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant que vous connaissez
ce serait quand même pas mal qu'on soit
en conformité avec elle ou avec aussi ce
que dit la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme donc
sur cette oui enfin ce qu'elle dit bon
d'accord mais vous allez répondre
monsieur le ministrement que par votre
porte très très harmonieux d'ailleurs
c'est très bien et toujours est-il que
c'est la deuxième cette question là vous
le savez se pose de manière centrale
nous avons reçu les représentants des
magistrats des représentants des avocats
des éducateurs cette question revient
toujours et enfin dernière question pour
ne pas être trop long
ce que vous dites enfin bon l'idée de la
césure est une bonne idée parce que ça
permet de faire une première décision
dans des délais rapides ce qui est
nécessaire s'agissant des mineurs de
donner à l'acte éducatif toute sa place
et d'avoir ensuite une autre décision
bien nous ne contestons pas cela par
contre Monsieur le Ministre pour les
réitérer
alors là on est dans un système
différent en fait
puisque on va arriver dans quasiment la
garde à vue le déferlement au parquet le
centre éducatif fermé pour les moins de
16 ans la détention provisoire pour les
plus de 16 ans et un tribunal qui va
statuer en une seule fois et donc pour
ces jeunes là ces mineurs là d'une
certaine façon la philosophie générale
du texte
ne paraît pas s'appliquer donc je
voulais vous interroger là-dessus c'est
ma troisième et dernière question merci
monsieur Sueur la parole est à Monsieur
le Comte
oui merci monsieur le Président moi
aussi je voudrais parce qu'il y avait
pas de
précision sur le sujet exact de cette
audition sortir un peu de de la question
de l'ordonnance concernant les la
justice des mineurs mais sur la question
des actes de naissance et la loi
bioéthique
l'article 4 bis tel qu'il est sorti de
l'Assemblée nationale
porte une rédaction qui avait été portée
par le gouvernement lors de la première
lecture au Sénat
qui remet en cause l'article 47 du Code
civil qui
pose que les actes d'état civil
étrangers font foi sauf si je résumerai
son notoirement faux
et donc
ce que la rédaction qui est proposée
dans dans la loi remet en cause ce
principe et va enregistre engendrer des
des complexités pour énormément de
personnes qui ont eu des naissances ou
des actes d'état civil enregistrés à
l'étranger pourquoi le gouvernement l'a
fait pour mettre un obstacle à la
transcription des actes de naissance des
enfants nés par GPA à l'étranger
toutefois sur ce sujet la France a déjà
été condamnée de nombreuses fois par le
cdH la Cour de cassation a plusieurs
fois renforcée indiqué
des ces positions sur le sujet qui font
jurisprudence et le procureur de la
République de Nantes a donné des
instructions sur sur ces questions
de manière à ce que les transcriptions
puissent être faites sans automaticité
avec un contrôle renforcé mais en
respectant les exigences de la cdH de
d'effectivité et de célérité on constate
que
ce que vous envisagez va faire obstacle
aux
exigence de la célérité de qui a été
posée par la CEDH et qu'un certain
nombre de situations en particulier pour
les mères seuls seront totalement
bloqués parce que nous pourrons pas
adopter leur propre enfant ça pose aussi
le problème de la réciprocité des de du
respect des actes d'état civil en entre
des actes d'état civil français à
l'étranger donc ma question monsieur le
garde des sources et est-ce que vous
êtes à l'aise avec la rédaction de
l'article 4 bises de la loi bioéthique
qui est sorti de l'Assemblée nationale
et qui est soumise aujourd'hui à notre
assemblée alors je suis désolé peut-être
vous pensez que c'était juste sur
l'autre thème que vous étiez interrogé
mais rien n'était indiqué dans la
convocation donc
comme nous n'aurons pas l'occasion de
vous interroger sur ce sujet et sur ce
point il me semblait utile d'avoir votre
avis d'autant que le sujet biotique
n'est pas pris dans notre commission
faut-il le dire et que l'objectif de
l'audition est effectivement bien le
sujet de la loi madame l'herbier non
monsieur Barbade excusez-moi monsieur
le Président je vous je vous remercie et
je vous remercie le ministre d'avoir
pris les devants et de s'être exprimé
après vous monsieur le Président et
après la démarche que vous aviez faite
sur les
consignes qui ont été adressées par le
Garde des Sceaux au juridictions pour la
mise en œuvre de cette ordonnance sur la
justice des mineurs si on regarde des
sauts
le formalisme est nécessaire à la
procédure judiciaire et il trouve de
multiples points d'applications qui
doivent tous se traduire par les
applications informatiques mises en
œuvre par les greffiers et qui
permettent aussi aux avocats d'ailleurs
de suivre l'évolution d'un dossier
si on règle dans les détails la mise en
oeuvre de l'ordonnance avant le vote du
Sénat et quel que soit les langues les
commentaires quel que soit les
précautions de langage que vous aurez
prises au risque de se trouver quand
même dans une situation où vous viendrez
nous dire
dans quelques jours que vous ne pouvez
pas accepter des amendements même bon du
Sénat parce que vous ne pourrez pas
tenir votre calendrier s'ils sont
acceptés et nous avons le sentiment
comprenez-le je vous je vous explique
que notre motivation est une motivation
au fond de qualité du débat
parlementaire et de respect du débat
parlementaire et non pas une
préoccupation mais vous ne m'en avez pas
accusé et vous n'en avez accusé personne
de politique politicienne si nous ne
pouvons pas amender ce texte parce que
les consignes ont déjà été donnés pour
son application dans un délai très
rapproché ou si nous n'arrivons pas à un
accord en commission mixparitaire après
nos amendements pour ce motif qui
pourrait être un motif non dit et bien
je regrette de vous dire que ça
constitue quand même un problème pour
les relations entre le Parlement et le
gouvernement alors j'espère je ne sais
plus comment dire français que ça n'est
pas du wishful thinking que d'espérer
une application de ce texte si
protéiforme si important si ambitieux
dans un délai aussi rapproché après le
vote du Parlement et je m'associe à
l'interrogation de notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Sueur et d'autres collègues
d'ailleurs
sur ce point parce que
je crois que quand on fait une réforme
aussi importante il faut qu'il ne manque
pas un bouton de guêtre je comprends que
vous avez voulu travailler en temps
masqué je ne vous le reproche pas au
fond vous avez sans doute eu un souci
d'efficacité mais il vient percuter le
débat parlementaire dans des conditions
qui sont tout à fait inhabituelles je
tenais à vous le dire
merci Monsieur barman l'herbier
le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux je voudrais revenir sur
l'urgence vous avez dit intervenir vide
dans le monde de la jeunesse et bien sûr
ici nous ençons tous absolument
convaincus tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous a confirmé
les chiffres
dramatiques d'augmentation de
maltraitance de violences
intrafamiliales
ces chiffres nous avaient déjà été
présentés par les gendarmes par les
procureurs pendant la période de
confinement
ces chiffres dans certains départements
sont extrêmement violents sont
extrêmement importants je suis du Nord
et vous en savez quelque chose on est un
département qui est
extrêmement touché par ces cette forme
de violence familiale alors je voudrais
revenir sur un cas les suites dramatique
de ces réitérations de violences en ces
formes d'impunité qu'on rencontre
vis-à-vis des parents quelquefois
peuvent être à l'origine de bien des
déstructurations d'enfants alors
aujourd'hui on parle de code de justice
des mineurs ça m'est pour moi toujours
extrêmement douloureux qu'on puisse
intéresser aux jeunes quand ils viennent
des lycans je trouve que on aurait pu le
faire bien en amont pour éviter
justement d'en arriver là
dès carences éducatifs certes si ça peut
y remédier tant mieux mais quand on
pense que dans la dans la période de
détresse de ses enfants les services
d'AEMO sont surchargés que les services
de placement d'enfance sont retardés et
il y a beaucoup de de signalements qui
me donne pas suite je bien sûr ce n'est
pas systématique les enfants qui sont en
détresse ne deviennent pas délinquants
heureusement mais si on peut les sauver
pour en sauver certains je trouve que
c'est notre responsabilité d'élus notre
responsabilité de juriste alors quand on
voit aussi que quand j'étais adjointe à
la sécurité je mets en place des
chantiers tiges les jeunes qui venaient
dans ces chantiers la plupart du temps
c'était la première fois qu'on
s'intéressait à eux c'est la première
fois qu'il pouvait montrer qu'on servait
à quelque chose qui savait faire des
choses et je trouve que c'est bien
gênant d'associer l'ascension à la à
l'éducatif il aurait fallu le faire en
amont avant qu'ils deviennent qui ne
passe à l'acte les services de PJJ quand
on les alertés sur des des cas de
détresse la plupart du temps ils étaient
très récalcitrants à venir participer à
nos réunions de police etc et je trouve
que c'était bien gênant ils avaient
une suspicion de se dire les élus ils
vont forcément tenir avec les jeunes et
ils vont forcément être nuisibles aux
jeunes et il ne faisait pas confiance et
ça je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dommage parce qu'il faut que ça soit une
anime que tout le monde soit solidaire
pour sortir les enfants quand ils
peuvent en être sorti de ces phénomènes
alors bien sûr le code il faut après
être sévère c'est tout ils sont passés à
l'acte il faut punir ça je suis
absolument convaincu mais je profite de
cette de cette rencontre pour aussi
alerter sur ce qui se passe avant et que
je trouve que c'est quand même bien
dommage de de laisser évoluer des choses
très négativement et de d'après de ne
pouvoir que constater merci
monsieur le Président donc beaucoup de
questions ont déjà été posées alors moi
je vais aller sur une question un peu
plus technique je vais quand même
rebondir
je vais la faire parce que là
effectivement tout le monde l'attend
c'est je vais rebondir donc sur deux
remarques de notre rapporteur la
première c'est Cassiopée sera-t-elle
prêt
ça je suis obligé de le faire
la deuxième c'est concernant les amendes
de police alors je comprends
qu'effectivement les infractions de de
première alors justement de 1 à 4 reste
à la police je me demandais parce que
quatrième catégorie
quatrième classe de Première quatrième
classe ça reste à la police et la
cinquième classe passe au juge pour
enfants
tu sais
et donc en fait le la quatrième classe
qui semble ne pas forcément très grave
pour un adulte pour un enfant relève
forcément d'un dysfonctionnement à
minima familial et donc mériterait
peut-être de passer plus rapidement vers
le juge pour enfants mais j'ai une
question un peu plus technique au moment
de la rédaction de l'ordonnance
vous aviez prévu dans les modules de
placement qu'un enfant puisse être placé
aussi à la zone
ce que vous avez supprimé via un
amendement du Gouvernement à l'Assemblée
nationale en faisant en sorte que un
enfant puisse être placé dans un cadre
familial donc ou chez une personne de
confiance mais plus à l'azo alors je
m'interrogeais moi sur les enfants qui
déjà étaient placés à l'azo qui ont se
soucis là et donc ça veut dire que parce
que je comprends que des enfants
nouveaux pas encore connus et pas encore
pris en charge par le Conseil
départemental on ne n'aille pas les
placer à l'ASEE dans une situation de
difficulté ça je le comprends mais par
contre un enfant qui était déjà placé
qui va rencontrer une difficulté comme
n'importe quel enfant de n'importe
quelle famille celui-là ne pourra pas
être remis dans une famille comme le
premier qui a déjà une famille mais
devra forcément aller à la PJJ c'est en
quelque sorte une double peine parce
qu'il n'avait une famille initiale
et donc je sais que on peut le placer à
la zone mais que en mode préventive mais
pas au moment de la sanction et du
placement ça c'était c'est dans
l'article l112-14 et c'est un amendement
qui a été présenté dans l'article 3 de
du de la pro du projet de loi que nous
sommes en train de regarder donc voilà
ma question c'est est-ce qu'un enfant
qui était à la zone forcément si il a
une mesure de placement cette mesure de
placement sera à la PJJ et réellement ne
pourra pas être éventuellement dans une
autre famille de l'ASE mais encore
encadre familial merci Madame cuckermann
c'est nous en tant
ez
oui monsieur le garde des sceaux
peut-être donc tout d'abord m'associer
bien évidemment à la remarque qui a été
déjà faite par mes collègues
précédemment sur en tout cas
l'interrogation nous pouvons avoir sur
le respect finalement de du travail du
Parlement et du bicamerisme et de
l'examen pour ton Intex déjà en
procédure d'urgence donc un examen
raccourci sur un texte pourtant si
important mais par une lecture en tout
cas à minima dans les deux chambres qui
feront bien évidemment à l'issue la loi
et pas avant une deuxième remarque
également sur le temps imparti dans le
cadre de nos travaux législatif quand
nous examinerons en séance puisque de
fait nous aurons deux jours pour
légiférer alors certes sur un projet de
loi qui ne concentre qu'une quelques
unités d'articles officiellement mais
quand on prend l'ordonnance dans son
intégralité ce sont très de 300 articles
de fait sur lesquels nous sommes amenés
à pouvoir réagir et même si monsieur le
garde des sceaux j'ai entendu ce que
vous avez dit dans vos propos
introductifs bien évidemment nous sommes
en semaine gouvernemental c'est une
gouvernement qui a la maîtrise cet ordre
du jour donc peut-être pas vous
personnellement et directement mais en
tout cas le gouvernement que vous
représentez ici j'avais une question
peut-être assez précise et qui concerne
la mise en place de ce que l'on qualifie
d'audience unique vous savez et chacun a
pu lire les différentes critiques
certains membres font le parallèle avec
ce que l'on appelle la comparution
immédiate notamment pour les publics
majeurs donc j'aurais souhaité monsieur
le garder sous vous entendre sur comment
est-ce que vous l'envisagez dans son
déroulé dans la protection tout de même
des mineurs et en tout cas comment
éviter que ces audiences uniques si
elles devaient être en nombre en tout
cas importante
empêche la mise en place d'une justice
que l'on pourrait qualifier et je la
mettrai entre guillemets à leur parlons
puisque ça pourrait me dire que c'est un
a priori mais en tout cas que certains
qualifient dans un déjà de justice
expéditive et je pense que bien
évidemment si nous avons tous conscience
nous allons prendre de l'encombrement
pardon des juridictions dans leur
diversité d'ailleurs et que qu'il
s'agisse de juridictions mineurs ou des
juridictions de majeures cela en tout
cas se désencombrement ne peut se faire
au détriment des justiciables je vous
remercie merci encore deux interventions
madame de la ganterie et puis madame
Boyer
merci président deux points le premier
concernant la date d'entrée en vigueur
de la réforme vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que toute réforme effectivement
en général et on ne peut pas vous donner
tort
rencontre son lot d'opposition et de
contestation mais on voit bien que c'est
un nombre très important de
professionnels qui
conteste la date d'entrée en vigueur et
par exemple la présidente de la
conférence des procureurs généraux le 31
mars qui a indiqué qui est en train
vigueur au 31 mars était un non-sens
donc
au-delà d'une frilosité d'incorporatisme
que sais-je on voit bien qu'il y a cette
inquiétude et au fond cette circulaire
traduit sans doute cette nécessité de
précipitation parce que autrement je ne
vois pas très bien pourquoi vous auriez
eu besoin de la prendre et afin qu'il
n'y ait pas de malentendu
il ne s'agit pas de d'amour propre du
Sénat la question n'est pas de savoir si
nous sommes eucés du fait que le Sénat
était ignoré lorsque cette circulaire a
été publiée la question c'est c'est la
loi et au fond qui dit balle a très bien
dit c'est que les choses sont désormais
figées de fait donc le problème est
celui là
le deuxième point concerne
plus précisément et donc on est un petit
peu hors champ du débat sur la justice
des mineurs mais c'est le calendrier qui
veut cela je voulais savoir Monsieur le
Ministre quel était votre position face
au fait que le procureur général près la
Cour de cassation et annoncé l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire avant à
votre rencontre devant la Cour de
Justice de la République après la vie
favorable de la commission des requêtes
vous avez indiqué la semaine dernière je
résume en substance le moment venu je
m'expliquerai je ne parle absolument pas
du fond mais de votre position de
ministre de la Justice je voulais donc
savoir si de votre point de vue c'était
problématique par rapport à votre
situation de garde des sceaux d'être
l'objet d'une information judiciaire
devant la CGR et si ça n'était pas le
cas aujourd'hui à quel stade de la
procédure pensez-vous que cela
deviendrait problématique pour assurer
vos fonctions de garde des sceaux
merci de la ganterie madame Boyer et
puis ensuite la parole sera ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je beaucoup
de questions que je souhaitais poser ont
été posées notamment sur Cassiopée sur
la zone et les mineurs non accompagnés
mais monsieur le ministre je souscris à
ce qu'on dit aussi mes collègues
jean-Pierre Sueur Philippe Bas ou madame
de La Gontrie à l'instant sur la
position compliquée dans dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui on le
sait tous cette réforme doit être mise
en place parce que ça fait longtemps que
nous parlons de l'enfance délinquante je
partage ce point de vue le texte est
ancien il est difficile il a été révisé
une quarantaine de fois mais
malheureusement une fois de plus j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement cherche
à transformer le Parlement en chambre
d'enregistrement
d'instructions qui ont été donnée par le
Président de la République et je
m'attendais moi à des débats un petit
peu plus fou plus long plus ambitieux
afin d'avancer ensemble dans une seule
et même direction c'est à dire trouver
un équilibre entre justice et fermeté on
le sait le temps presse et vous avez
décidé que cette réforme s'appliquerait
le 31 mars prochain et le temps presse
tellement que tout pour vous est acté
puisque enfin si j'en crois le courrier
que vous avez adressé aux professionnels
de la justice et vous vous féliciter des
modifications apportées à ce texte par
l'Assemblée nationale on s'en félicite
aussi mais nous sommes dans un régime
bicaméral et on le sait à chaque projet
de loi on nous parle d'urgence alors je
sais aussi que la pandémie a bousculé le
calendrier mais on peut pas continuer à
avoir ce genre de relation avec le
Parlement en tout cas à mon sens ça me
semble extrêmement compliqué et c'est ni
orgueil ni aigreur de la de ma part et
je pense de la part de mes collègues
sénateurs c'est pas ça qu'on peut
exprimer parce que le travail a été fait
par mes collègues de façon approfondie
avec sérieux avec avec un fort
investissement et si vous me permettez
monsieur le ministre et mes chers
collègues je vous citerai une phrase de
Georges Clémenceau qui aura marqué quand
même l'histoire de France et l'histoire
de cette très très belle maison qui
disait pendant une partie de ma vie j'ai
eu foi en la chambre unique comme
émanation directe du sentiment populaire
j'en suis revenue les événements m'ont
appris qu'il faut laisser au peuple le
temps de la réflexion le temps de la
réflexion c'est le Sénat et si vous me
permettez monsieur le ministre et mes
chers collègues je rajouterai c'est
aussi la qualité d'un texte législatif
qui a été remanié tellement de fois que
aujourd'hui compte tenu de l'ambition et
de l'ampleur que chacun a exprimé je
pense que ce serait difficile pour la
population difficile pour les métiers de
la justice et bien de travailler dans
des conditions que nous craignons
merci qui a demandé la parole et après
vraiment je vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde j'aurais aimé avoir votre avis sur
le discernement pour vous avec votre
expérience d'avocat bien connu qu'est-ce
que le discernement qu'est-ce que le
consentement pourriez-vous m'éclairer
sur sur ces deux points et que
pensez-vous aussi de l'accompagnement
des familles dans l'éducation de de nos
jeunes pour que on en arrive là et
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
nous dire à ce sujet merci merci et bien
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
et vous seul
merci monsieur le Président
dérogeons peut-être à l'ordre des
questions qui m'ont été posées je vais
d'abord répondre à l'aimable
interpellation de madame la sénatrice de
la Gontrie
mon crime madame la sénatrice et d'avoir
exercé mes fonctions exactement
comme l'aurait fait tous mes
prédécesseurs dans des circonstances
analogues
j'ai suivi en effet
les recommandations de mon
administration
j'ai suivi madame les recommandations de
mon administration vous ne pouvez pas
dire que c'est faux vous n'en savez rien
et je le et je le démontrerai madame je
voudrais vous répondre sans être
interrompu j'ai suivi les
recommandations de mon administration
madame je le démontrerai
composé de magistrats et j'ai saisi pour
une simple enquête rien de plus rien de
moins une autorité
indépendante elle aussi composée de
magistrats pour faire la lumière sur
d'éventuelles fautes déontologiques
pouvant avoir été commise
par des magistrats qui pour certains
d'entre eux n'ont pas déféré ou
convocations qui leur avait été adressée
alors puisque vous préoccupez de mon
sort à venir je voudrais vous dire
très calmement très aimablement et très
respectueusement
que si l'objectif de tout cela comme
c'est d'ores et déjà exprimées par
certains c'est de m'interdire de
travailler alors cela on seront pour
leurs frais et d'ailleurs je travaille
aujourd'hui avec vous sur le code de
justice pénale des mineurs voilà madame
la sénatrice ma réponse elle sera
ultérieurement sans doute plus complète
très complète je n'ai rien à craindre et
je suis mais totalement serein
alors maintenant monsieur le Président
si si vous mis autorisez je vais
répondre aux questions qui m'ont été
posées sur le code de justice de penal
des mineurs
d'abord madame madame madame la
rapporteur
suggéré un report de la date d'entrée en
vigueur
mais d'une façon paradoxale si vous me
le permettez vous dites l'un des
problèmes c'est la superposition des
dossiers anciennes procédure avec les
dossiers nouvelles procédure je voudrais
vous faire remarquer
que si nous retardons la mise en œuvre
de cette loi nouvelle alors il y aura
davantage cette superposition que vous
dénoncez à juste titre car il y aura
davantage encore d'anciens dossiers et
il y aura les dossiers nouveaux je vais
également dire sur sur ces questions je
veux y revenir une fois pour toute que
dans cette circulaire
qui ne fige en rien personne je ne crois
pas monsieur le Kester que vous soyez
timide 400 amendements ont été déposés à
l'Assemblée nationale et vous ne vous
interdirez pas je ne le crois pas une
seule seconde pas un seul instant de
déposer les amendements que vous
utile
mais dans cette circulaire Canada drive
Canada Dry ça c'est pas de l'alcool mais
ça y ressemble quand même sur le
Président on a quand même joint
un guide extrêmement important pour les
magistrats qui est le guide
igj d'entrée de la réforme un tableau de
simulation des orientations pénales qui
règle la question du stock pardon encore
pour ce mot et un tableau de simulation
du besoin d'audience et pardon de vous
dire
que là encore mais dans un domaine un
peu différent celui sur lequel j'ai été
interpellé par Madame le la Gontrie je
fais confiance en l'analyse de mes
services
elle est faite de magistrats indépendant
ils ont expertisé ils ont analysé et ils
nous ont dit je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je suis tout à fait transparent
avec vous une dizaine de juridictions
fragilisées mais le problème est réglé
alors ensuite on entend bien les autres
qu'il y ait quelques réticences
qu'on a du mal envisager une autre
procédure moi quand j'étais avocat
qu'une nouvelle procédure arrivée il
fallait d'abord que je la lise ça me
contraignait un peu et parfois je disais
il y a une inflation mais ici la réalité
c'est que cette loi elle est attendue
depuis 2007 le nombre de commissions on
aura l'occasion de rappeler tout cela
bon nous aurons des débats très complets
je veux également rassurer monsieur le
Kester c'est ces trois jours de débat
prévu donc vous aurez toute l'attitude
pour me m'interroger avec
la minutie
vous savez le
le pragmatisme la minutie du chirurgien
le pragmatisme de la sécurité sociale je
vous connais rien rien ne vous échappera
nous auront trois jours de débat
là-dessus donc vous êtes rassurés vous
faites celui qui ne va pas oser mais
vous oserez tout naturellement et pardon
monsieur pester vous oserez tout ce que
vous estimez utile à l'amélioration de
ce texte et je vous entendrai d'ailleurs
je peux vous dire que dans les 400
amendements qui ont été déposés il y a
un certain nombre d'amendements que nous
avons retenus que j'ai retenu le JLD moi
je j'avais pas une position très arrêtée
de la discussion avec les parlementaires
il faut que il en sorte forcément
quelque chose j'en ai retiré une
position qui était inverse donc là
dessus je tiens à vous rassurer mais je
pense je sais au fond de vous que vous
vous l'êtes déjà nous nous aurons ce
débat et enfin pour répondre
complètement à ces questions mais c'est
votre question a été envisagée par
d'autres notamment par Monsieur le
Sénateur sueur il y a aussi ce que nous
avons amené dans les juridictions
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure 72
magistrats ont été affectés 1er
septembre 2020
sans greffier
252 emplois nouveaux créés en 2022 86
éducateurs qui viennent d'être recrutés
donc nous avons fait cela
à la suite de l'analyse conduite par les
services de la Chancellerie qui l'ont
strictement aucun intérêt voyez-vous à
nous dire que les juridictions sont
prêtes si elles ne le sont pas parce que
ce serait d'une certaine façon une
catastrophe que d'envisager un texte qui
est un beau texte moi j'en suis
absolument convaincu inapplicable
voilà je pense la première réponse à la
question que vous posez monsieur le
sénateur sueur
vous êtes inquiet de ce que nous allons
faire je devrais dire de ce que nous
devons faire
à la suite de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de 12 octobre vous savez
que je souhaitais que l'on examine cette
question
pour des raisons on va le dire technique
ça n'a pas été possible je travaille
donc
activement pour que nous soyons
évidemment en conformité avec ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel a décidé vous
donner une date
[Musique]
alors on essaie de trouver le vecteur
législatif pour introduire ce recours
effectif dans notre droit on y travaille
je n'ai pas encore de réponse
je non
non je n'ai pas répondu s'il vous plaît
monsieur le garde des sceaux je n'ai pas
compris mais comment vous le dire
simplement
les adverbes sont utiles il convient
c'est urgemment il faut répondre à ça je
vous en dirai davantage je vous reçois
bientôt d'ailleurs demain pour évoquer
une autre question j'espère vous donner
la réponse sur Oui Oui
il suffit de demander
si on est responsabilité
bon les magistrats devront
systématiquement motiver le discernement
des mineurs
de moins de 13 ans pour engager des
poursuites
j'ai d'autres lignées tout à l'heure
vous m'en avez fait le reproche enfin le
reproche non non on a le droit mais
merci merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
sénateur à l'époque c'est une liberté
fondamentale mais enfin tout de même
j'ai de l'idée c'était ma façon
d'exprimer votre scepticisme qu'on vous
disiez que c'est parfaitement tranché en
droit international non c'est un vrai
débat toutes les législations ne sont
pas les mêmes 13 ans on peut discuter de
cela ensuite le caractère réfragable ou
irréfragable oui il y a une cohérence il
y a une logique on s'expliquera
là-dessus mais vous la connaissez déjà
au fond le discernement c'est l'analyse
du juge et moi je ne crains pas non plus
si vous voulez la décision du juge qui
est une décision sous l'égide de cette
philosophie de l'ordonnance de 45
c'est fait pour les enfants
pas contre les enfants et le débat que
nous avons eu notamment avec certains
c'était de dire que il n'y avait plus
il n'y avait plus d'enfants quand le
crime était grave comme si c'est à
l'aune de la gravité d'un crime que l'on
mesurait le discernement tout ça vous le
savez c'est bien plus subtil que ça il
faut fixer
un âge
évidemment il y a ceux qui vous diront
mais après c'est pas bien fallait 14
d'autres vous diront 12 bon ça fera des
parties naturellement du du débat
parlementaire mais en réalité il faut
laisser au juge le soir d'analyser le
discernement et ça répond pardonnez-moi
madame la cinématique un peu à votre
question vous me demandiez de mon
expérience d'avocat j'ai été assez
souvent au début de mon tribunal pour
enfants quand j'étais jeune avocat bon
j'ai vu des gamins très jeunes très mûrs
et puis j'ai vu des gamins bien plus
âgés sans aucune maturité et sans aucun
discernement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faisait laisser me
semble-t-il au juge qui est un
professionnel de l'enfance le soin de
fixer les choses il faut lui laisser lui
laisser me semble-t-il beaucoup de
flexibilité
monsieur le sénateur le compte
bon
alors sur l'audience unique
pardon elle est réversible l'audience
unique voilà ce que je peux vous dire
d'abord elle est exceptionnelle elle est
enterrée dans des conditions qui sont
très strictes et elle est réversible
c'est-à-dire qu'à tout moment on peut
revenir à cette procédure classique
et d'ailleurs vous faites bien de
m'interpeller j'allais oublier de vous
répondre et vous avez bien fait de
m'interpeller sur cette question parce
que c'est une des contestations que l'on
a entendu qui a été reprise certains
poussaient les prix d'orfray en disant
que c'était beaucoup plus répressif
c'est une procédure l'audience unique
tout à fait exceptionnelle nous en
débattrons il y a de vraies conditions
et le juge a toujours la main là-dessus
il peut toujours si j'ose dire revenir
en arrière considérer que ce choix de
l'audience unique n'est pas le bon choix
et c'est une véritable garantie pour
l'enfant
monsieur le sénateur Jean-Yves Lecomte
j'adore échanger avec vous mais là vous
me posez une question pardonnez-moi à
laquelle je ne peux pas répondre j'y
répondrai ultérieurement sans aucun
doute je n'ai pas la prétention d'être
omniscient je le regrette infiniment au
quotidien bioéthique ça n'était pas le
sujet si j'ose dire l'ordre du jour
pardon je ne veux pas fuir la question
vous me la reposerez le moment venu et
j'essaierai d'y répondre
bien sûr oui oui oui
bien monsieur le questeur
bon je vous ai déjà amplement amplement
répondu et je veux une fois encore vous
rassurer sur votre plaine et entière
capacité à monter ce texte
non
et non mais est considéré au fond que
les choses se réfugigent parce que je
redressais une circulaire Canada Dry au
magistrat et que ça vous interdirait au
fond de bouger le texte
c'est assez précieux comme argument
pardon de vous le dire ainsi avec cette
liberté c'est curieux bon ce que l'on a
envoyé c'est au fond les grandes lignes
les très grandes lignes puisque l'une
des raisons de de discussion c'est en
réalité nous dit-on l'impréparation en
dépit du fait que j'ai rassuré les uns
et les autres enfin je l'espère sur les
moyens que nous y avons mis sur
l'expertise des services sur la volonté
pour les services de évidemment d'aller
vers une loi qui est applicable sinon
tout cela ne reste strictement aucun
sens ni moins ni vous ni nuagistrat dans
le goût de l'effort inutile madame la
Sénat Chrysler je vais essayer de vous
répondre je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce que vous dites évidemment que si
on pouvait détecter plus vite avant si
on pouvait empêcher oui mais pour autant
pour autant qu'il me soit permis de vous
dire que il y a des textes
relatifs bien sûr à la protection de
l'enfance 2007 2016 je vous les rappelle
pour mémoire ils ne sont pas abrogés par
la loi que nous examinerons ils sont
toujours là bien sûr et donc cette
texte-là ont vocation à s'appliquer ce
qui rejoint d'ailleurs une autre
question qui m'a été posée tout à
l'heure sur le parcours pénal au fond et
l'analyse madame la sénatrice
vérien vous faites de l'article
112-14 en réalité ceux qui sont déjà
placés à l'azo la combinaison des
dispositions civiles et pénales ont
vocation évidemment à se poursuivre ça
n'est pas exclusif c'est possiblement
cumulatif donc je tiens à vous rassurer
pleinement et d'ailleurs heureusement
parce que sinon ça n'aurait ça n'aurait
pas de sens d'affirmer que cette loi
privilégie l'éducatif et au fond nous
verrions l'éducatif balayé et la
protection balayée au profit c'est j'ose
dire de la répression ça n'aurait
évidemment pas de sens sur le tribunal
de police
cinquième classe devant juge des enfants
les autres restent donc tribunal de
police nous avons eu des tas des tas
d’état dont demande présenté par la
France insoumise qui souhaitait
absolument que ce contentieux du
tribunal de police bascule vers le juge
des enfants dont on nous dit déjà qu'il
serait surchargé bon alors nous avons
essayé d'expliquer alors présentation
nationale
l'assemblée nous avons été me
semble-t-il entendu il fallait pas
modifier les choses il y a un certain
nombre de précautions qui sont prises
notamment en matière de droit de la
défense puisque nous verrons tout cela
et et au fond il était important de
préserver ces équilibres j'ai également
été interrogé par Madame Cécile
madame la sénatrice pardon pour cette
coupable hésitation qu'est-ce que la
procédure de saisine du TPE au fin
d'audience unique alors c'est une
procédure j'ai déjà dit à Monsieur
sénateur sueur dérogatoire à la
procédure de mise à l'épreuve du captive
décidé par le parquet seule hypothèse
qui permet le placement des tensions
provisoires dès le défairement hors
ouverture d'information le mineur est
jugé dans un délai de 10 jours à trois
mois sur la culpabilité et la sanction
et le TPE peut prononcer toute mesure
éducative ou peine le TPE peut
d'ailleurs assortir une peine ferme
d'emprisonnement d'un mandat de dépôt
sans condition de Quantum ou de récidive
et
nous verrons les conditions pour
recourir à cette procédure
exceptionnelle et je redis ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à monsieur le
sénateur sueur il y a toujours la
possibilité de revenir en arrière vers
la procédure qui sera la procédure
classique si vous me permettez ce mot
madame la sénatrice Boyer j'entends ce
que vous me dites j'entends raisonner
les mots de Clémenceau trois jours de
débat en séance publique le 26 janvier
prochain
l'urgence c'est aussi l'urgence de
justiciable
la justice des mineurs aujourd'hui n'est
plus adaptée
et je dis qu'une justice qui intervient
trop ouais ça ça revient pardon à
enfin c'est cohérent avec ce que nous
avons appelé la justice de proximité
j'aurai l'occasion de décliner de
redécliner il n'est pas cohérent qu'un
gamin soit jugé trop tardivement ça n'a
aucun sens donc ça aussi c'est l'urgence
l'amélioration de la procédure pénale
applicable au plus fragile aux mineurs
et beaucoup de professionnels nous
aurons l'occasion de redire cela on va
pas faire du culturisme
j'allais dire politique en disant nous
avons plus de gens favorables que il y a
de gens contre il y a des gens contre il
y a des gens qui sont favorables chez
les professionnels il y a une très très
grande consultation les juges des
enfants ont été consultés enfin nous
reverrons tout ça j'aurai l'honneur
d'expliquer tout ça c'est une réalité
mais les professionnels dans leur
ensemble réclament cette réforme même
s'il y a un certain nombre de points
névralgiques dont je redis ils ont été
pris en considération par les services
voilà monsieur le Président ce que trop
longuement
je voulais vous dire et maintenant alors
MNA sujet très important et menace sont
des mineurs accompagnés ou non si si
vous me permettez ce raccourci ils sont
juste iciables de ce code de justice
pénal des mineurs ce n'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui mais je pourrais
développer bien sûr ce que notamment
nous sommes allés faire au Maroc le
véritable problème des MNA c'est leur
identification parce qu'il y a des MNA
qui sont des majeurs non accompagnés il
y a des MNA marocains par exemple qui
sont des majeurs non accompagnés
algériens ou d'une autre nationalité et
la grande question pour nous
c'était d'obtenir un certain nombre
d'assurance pour que l'on puisse
identifier ces gamins
bien sûr et
la vérification a également été conduite
par les services de la qualité des
structures d'accueil qui se trouvent au
Maroc
et c'est structures ont été visitées
elles ont été regardées de près ainsi
d'ailleurs que le Service de Protection
Judiciaire de la Jeunesse au Maroc et ce
qui m'est revenu de ces différentes
visites qui ont été faites avec le
magistrat de liaison sur place c'est que
c'est de grandes qualités mais ça change
évidemment la donne si nous avons la
possibilité de travailler avec les
autorités marocaines sur
l'identification donc il y a un certain
nombre de choses que nous avons
protocolisées et un certain nombre de de
techniques auxquelles nous avons songé
par exemple la vérification du portable
si vous avez le préfixe marocain 20 fois
jour vous avez compris qu'il s'agit
vraisemblablement d'un MNA marocain
alors peut-être pas mineur mais voilà et
puis nous nous voulons vraiment régler
cette question mais de façon très
générale les M&A sont justiciables du
code de justice pénale des mineurs enfin
le JLD JLD spécialisé avec des
formations particulières j'y reviendrai
sans doute parce que c'était ça faisait
partie des nombreuses interrogations qui
ont été celles des
députés JLD spécialisés pour éviter
justement
comment dirais-je le procès qui pourrait
être fait procès inéquitable dans la
mesure où on a considéré moi j'ai
longuement réfléchi sur cette question
mais finalement on a considéré que
c'était peut-être plus conforme à la
jurisprudence de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme voilà monsieur le
Président je pense avoir répondu à peu
près à toutes les questions qui m'ont
été posées merci monsieur le ministre je
crois que Monsieur barre demandez la
parole même canailler peut-être
merci monsieur le Président je ne veux
pas abuser de cette parole que vous me
rendez et je voudrais vous dire monsieur
le garde des sceaux que j'ai mal dû
formuler ma question tout à l'heure si
j'en juge par la réponse que vous m'avez
faite à deux reprises je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude sur notre capacité à
exercer notre droit d'amendement à vrai
dire ce droit ne nous est pas conseillé
par le gouvernement nous le dirons de la
Constitution et nous n'avons aucune
espèce d'inhibition face à son exercice
cela va de soi même si vous avez bien
voulu nous rassurer sur cette latitude
que nous manquerons pas d'exercer notre
préoccupation c'est plutôt comment faire
en sorte que le jeu normal
du processus législatif puisse aboutir
et nous l'espérons un accord en
commission mixte paritaire qui prennent
en compte le travail du Sénat si le
débat est à l'avance fermé par
le fait que la en céleri a déjà décidé
ce que serait le dispositif final
j'entends ce que vous nous dites et je
l'interprète comme un propos destiné à
nous rassurer je crois que vous êtes
attaché comme nous à un débat de bonne
foi et
on accepte tout à fait l'augure je note
l'ouverture que vous faites par avance à
nos amendements et la preuve par 9
viendra dans le débat parlementaire et
dans les travaux de la commission mix
paritaire
voilà donc pour cette audition du garde
des sceaux ce soir au Sénat Éric
Dupont-Moretti il y a notamment justifié
sa volonté d'accélérer sa réforme de la
justice des mineurs sans pour autant
assurent-ils manqué de respect au
travail des sénateurs cette audition va
y revenir dans le match des idées c'est
l'heure d'aller plus loin